Almost heaven, older Twitch chat, all these emotes, wondering how to spell that.
Now everyone's moved on, but I remember Twitch chat from those days that are gone.
Twitch emotes, from long ago, made you feel.
Tap a PogChamp, keep a forehead, Bible Thumb, Twitch emotes, typing dance games, forehead swift rage, PJ salt and fail fish.
A time when TOS was nowhere, Twitch emotes, from long ago, made you feel.
You're not alone, tap a PogChamp, keep a forehead, Twitch emotes, still here is bark in the morning.
From yesterday, yesterday, Twitch emotes, made you feel, Twitch emotes, happy hands.
Fynn, Topsport videos, dare to shine like a rocket.
Enough KakaoNah-Musik....
Lustig, dass man gleich die gleiche Youtube Startseite hat.
Ja viele Sachen hängen, glaube ich, gar nicht so sehr davon ab, was man sich anguckt.
Also ich mein zum Beispiel das da.
Warum kommt Youtube jetzt auf die Idee, mir ein sechs Jahre altes Video zu zeigen, wo einer eine 2. Weltkriegswaffe nimmt ?
... und ich mir eine 2. Weltkriegswaffe gibt.
... und ich mir eine 2. Weltkriegswaffe nimmt.
nachlädt. Das ist jetzt nicht
unbedingt das, was ich mir sonst so
angucke. Aber YouTube
ist jetzt der Meinung, oh ja, das
musst du jetzt gucken.
Logisch, versteht man nicht so genau.
Also YouTube-Algorithmus
wird schon wissen, was er macht.
Weil ich da manchmal so wirklich meine Zweifel
habe. Also
der Algorithmus weiß das eh nicht, aber
ob es noch jemanden gibt, der weiß,
was er macht, weiß ich nicht so
genau.
So, was
empfiehlt uns YouTube, der noch schön ist heute?
PC Gaming
und Raspberry Pi. Das ist doch Schwachsinn, das funktioniert doch nicht.
Selbst mit irgendeinem
fetten Kühler drauf.
Das Ding hat einfach nicht genug
Wumms. Ich meine, Raspberry Pi ist
nun wirklich nicht
noch nicht mal eine der
Single-Board-Computer-leistungsfähigen
Kisten. Das Gute
am Raspberry Pi ist, dass der
relativ günstig ist und
das Beste am Raspberry Pi ist,
ehrlich gesagt, der Support drumherum.
Also sprich,
dass es für alles irgendwelche
Guides gibt, Tutorials gibt,
eingebaute Module gibt, fertige
Aufsteckboards
und alles mögliche. Also das Ökosystem ist eigentlich
das, was den Raspberry Pi gut macht.
Die Hardware jetzt nur
sekundär, ja.
Ich hab ein Päckchen, das
wundert mich bei Google nicht.
Aber Google erzählt auch viel, wenn der Tag lang ist.
So, easy.
My Home Date.
So Zeug gucke ich mir immer gerne an,
dass ich dann mich ein bisschen
über die Hardware anderer
Leute lästern kann. Wobei manches,
das meiste ist ja deutlich advanceder als das,
was ich daheim habe. Ich denke mir dann immer so,
ey, was ist das mit dem? Was versteht
denn da für ein Teil?
Ach, ein alter Mac. Warum die da riesige
Racks und Gedulds? Alter, warum?
Warum hat, vor allem ist das Hardware
von, von, naja,
nicht aus der Jugend von
meinem Opa, aber
nicht die allerneueste
Hardware auf jeden Fall. Was das für Strom
kostet. Ich hab übrigens jetzt mal
geguckt, ähm,
weil, weil es ja immer heißt,
so nach dem Motto, hier Max, das Zeug verbraucht
so viel Strom und, äh,
sonst was. Ich hab jetzt mal geguckt,
was ich im Jahr an Strom bezahle.
Und ich bezahle, oder besser gesagt, wir bezahlen
für das ganze Haus
ungefähr 1000,
äh,
1150 Euro
ungefähr.
Geht doch eigentlich.
Also, ist jetzt nicht so, als hätte ich hier
extrem viel
Eidelzeug laufen, was wie verrückt
Zeug zieht, ne?
Ich sag's so. So, ich bin mir jetzt nicht sicher,
ob es 1250 oder
1150 waren, aber ich glaube, es waren 1150.
Ähm, ja,
das weiß ich aber auch nur, weil
die Stadtwerke letztens einen Brief geschrieben haben,
wo drin stand, sie wollen mehr Geld haben. Easy.
Ja. Das ist natürlich jetzt in dieser
Zeit für die meisten Leute ganz toll.
Wenn die teilweise wegen Corona
kein Geld haben oder ihren Job verloren haben oder sonst was
und wenn jetzt dann noch die Rundfunkgebühren kommen,
erst mal, ey, easy, erhöhen, dann kommen die Stadtwerke,
easy, Stromkosten erhöhen, ja, das ist kein Problem.
Aber ansonsten,
wisst ihr, was ich mir überlege? Ich, ich
mach's nicht, ich mach das nicht, aber
ich hab mir überlegt, ich hab jetzt, ich hab jetzt gehört,
dass es bis zu 5000 Euro
Einmalzahlung gibt
für Solo-Selbstständige.
Und ich bin ja
Solo-Selbstständig.
Wenn man's so will, ne?
Zwar nicht einzig, aber zwar nicht
allein, aber ich bin selbstständig und ich bin Solo-Selbstständig.
Ich hab mir gedacht,
vielleicht soll ich einfach mal Corona-Hilfe beantragen
und sagen, Alter, auf YouTube läuft's ja
gar nicht mehr seit Corona.
Ich schieb das einfach auf Corona.
Guck mal, ich sag dann hier,
ich bin Content-Creator
und, ähm,
ich weiß gar nicht, ob man das begründen muss, ja,
ich bin Content-Creator und
seit Corona, man sieht's ja auch hier genau,
hier, also, ne, hier ist so die Zeit,
wo das mit Corona losging. Seitdem läuft's
überhaupt nicht mehr auf YouTube.
Wollen wir mal gucken, was rauskommt.
Ne, das mach ich nicht.
Das mach ich nicht, aber eigentlich
müsste man's machen.
Weil ich sag ja immer so nach dem Motto, man kann sich nicht drauf verlassen,
dass irgendjemand was für einen macht, man muss sich da selbst
drum kümmern.
Naja.
So, mit was fangen wir denn jetzt an?
Äh, Kirby-Musik ist
immer pepo-happy.
Wo hab ich denn,
wo hab ich mein pepo-happy-Bild?
Wo ist es?
Leute, wo hab ich's denn?
Wo, wo ist mein pepo-happy-Bild?
Ich seh's nicht, wo ist es?
Leute, sagt mir mal, wo, wo hab ich's?
Hier.
Äh,
Planket hatte ich doch auch irgendwo. Wo ist Planket?
Ich find meine eigenen Bildchen nicht mehr.
Ich hab hier eigentlich ne Suche oben eingebaut, ne?
Da kann man zum Beispiel nach A,
A-Jaja suchen, aber das funktioniert nicht, weil's
broken ist.
Aber ich, den ersten Buchstaben kann ich suchen.
Die Suche ist kaputt, die ist schon seit,
eineinhalb Jahren kaputt, ich hab's noch nicht repariert.
Ach hier.
Ne, die Suche ist kaputt.
Und vor allem haben sich jetzt irgendwie die,
haben sich die Bilder grad verdoppelt?
Hab ich den echt zweimal drin?
Ja, tatsächlich, den hab ich sogar zweimal drin.
Aber ich kann jetzt keine Bilder löschen,
weil wenn ich Bilder löschen, dann ist die Anordnung
wieder total durcheinander.
Also man sieht, so ganz optimal,
so ganz optimal ist diese Geschichte nicht.
Was ich immer noch nicht so genau verstehe,
ist, warum alle GIFs irgendwie,
es, es spielen alle GIFs okay ab, ja?
Einziges GIF, was übelst rumspackt, ist das hier.
Guck mal, dieses GIF, vollkommen okay.
So, und dieses GIF sollte eigentlich so aussehen.
Und wenn ich dieses GIF aufmache,
ist der Hyper, am Hyper-Scheißen gerade.
Also es sollte eigentlich so sein, aber es ist so.
Und übrigens, das verursacht auch übelst CPU-Last, ne?
Naja, es geht so.
Aber es zieht schon ein bisschen was.
Speed-Run-Scheißen.
Ja.
Excellent.
Gut.
Das ist übrigens der Grund, warum ich dieses Ding nie released habe,
weil es halt einfach nicht funktioniert.
Das funktioniert gut genug, dass ich es verwenden kann.
Aber alles andere ist übelst unpolished und kaputt.
Wir machen, wir machen zumindest die Windows-Seite neu,
wenn es mal irgendwann WinUI 3 gibt.
Aber die kriegen es ja nicht gebacken.
Sie haben sich jetzt rausgeredet,
dass sie dank Corona erst nächstes Jahr releasen.
Manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, denen kommt Corona ganz gelegen,
was die Ausredenvielfalt angeht.
Früher musste man sich irgendwas aus den Fingern saugen,
warum man nicht fertig ist.
Und jetzt, und jetzt können sie alle sagen,
ja, Corona-bedingt wurde es dieses Jahr auch personell schwierig.
Deswegen müssen wir unsere Roadmap noch mal nachschärfen.
Das blablabla.
Nachschärfen ist übrigens bei uns auf der Arbeit,
habe ich so den Eindruck, so das neueste Stonks-Wort in gefühlt jedem Meeting,
wo irgendwelche Stonks-Leute drin sind,
wenn die sich über irgendwas unterhalten, wo es nicht funktioniert,
wo es nicht funktioniert hat, wo es kaputtgegangen ist oder so,
sagen die immer nicht, es ist kaputt oder es geht kaputt.
Das muss nachgeschärft werden.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die alle im gleichen Rhetorik-Kurs waren,
weil es ist auffällig.
Es ist auffällig, wenn das jetzt auf einmal alle sagen.
Da war wahrscheinlich Führungskräfte-Rhetorik-Kurs 25
und da hat man dann gelernt, eine weitere gute Umschreibung für ist kacke, ist nachschärft.
Unschärfen gab es ja früher schon, aber jetzt können die Unschärfen nachgeschärft werden.
Gibt es, ist der Source Code irgendwie online?
Von was da?
Von dem hier?
Nee.
Es gibt die allererste Version, die ich gebaut habe.
Die gibt es hier irgendwo auf GitHub.
Nicht in Monark S, sondern hier.
Das ist die allererste Version, die ich mal gemacht habe.
Guck mal, drei Jahre ist das jetzt schon ewig.
Und da gehen glaube ich Shortcuts noch nicht.
Da gibt es noch kein Web-Interface und nichts.
Das ist ein bisschen unfertig.
Sprich, das, was ich jetzt hier habe, ist auch unfertig,
aber es hat zumindest ein Web-Interface, ein Zeug, wo man hinzufügen kann und alles.
Ja, also, genau.
Wenn sie das mal schaffen, dass das hier endlich mal rauskommt,
dann mache ich das UI vom Meme-Board neu.
Weil dann brauche ich kein WPF mehr.
Dann machen wir das hier mit.
Ich meine, ich brauche jetzt auch kein WPF mehr.
Ich habe ja auch schon mal probiert,
ob wir nicht einfach ein ganz normales Fenster machen,
da drinnen ein bisschen in den DirectX-Content
und dann unsere Frames mit FFmpeg reinrendern.
Hat auch funktioniert, aber hat ab und zu rumgebuggt.
Deswegen habe ich es nie verwendet.
Und zum Fixen war ich zu unmotiviert.
So, genau.
Weil die wollten eigentlich Ende dieses Jahres, glaube ich, releasen,
haben sie aber nicht geschafft.
Abnext.
Da steht schon ewig seit Abnext.
Und ich weiß nicht, wann.
WinUI 3, Preview 3.
Also, da freue ich mich wirklich drauf,
weil angeblich werden dann zum ersten Mal
Windows-Desktop-Anwendungen unterstützt,
die nicht UWP sind oder die nicht packaged sein müssen.
Also sprich, im Prinzip die UWP-Unterbau haben.
Also sprich, man kann zum ersten Mal dann
moderne, zum ersten Mal seit 20 Jahren
wieder moderne Windows-Desktop-Anwendungen machen,
ohne irgendeinen Scheiß zu verwenden,
den man nicht verwenden will.
Also das ist...
Das hat Microsoft doch jetzt schon mal auf die Reihe geklappt.
Okay, sag mal seit 15 Jahren.
WPF kam 2005, glaube ich, oder so.
Ja.
Übrigens, es haben ja schon ganz viele gesagt,
wir sollen mal so ein bisschen Einsteiger-C-Sharp-Stream machen.
Und ich habe jetzt was gesehen bei Microsoft.
Und zwar, da gab es irgendwie so ein Learn-Event.
Learn.net.
Das ging noch bis Mitte Dezember.
War das das?
Fuck, wo ist das denn?
Es gab so einen...
Das ist so diese typische Microsoft-Geschichte.
Du findest den Kram nicht.
Das war so ein Kurs mit, glaube ich, 45 Übungsaufgaben.
Und die waren alle relativ gut aufgebaut
und abgegrenzt voreinander.
Ich finde es jetzt aber nicht.
Die könnten wir im Stream machen.
Das ist, glaube ich, gar nicht so verkehrt.
Vielleicht nicht alle 45.
Ich gucke mir in dem Vorfeld mal an,
was sich da irgendwie lohnt.
So, genau.
Wenn das rauskommt, bin ich wirklich mal gespannt drauf.
Wir haben die erste Preview ausprobiert und festgestellt,
dass noch nichts ging von dem, was ich machen wollte.
Ja, jetzt schauen wir mal.
Das muss ich mir jetzt anhören.
Warte mal.
Wo ist meine Kirby-Musik?
Wo ist meine...
Ah, hier.
Haha, das geht ja schon gut los.
Hahaha.
Stage 1 Emitters in...
Das ist ja geil gemacht.
3, 2...
Stage 2 Emitters activating now.
Forehead Capacitors to 105%.
Ey, das könnte wirklich aus dieser...
Das ist, glaube ich, eine Serie, ne?
Das ist echt geil gemacht.
Mal gucken, ob sie später noch ein paar Sounds irgendwie sinken,
wenn Leute was sagen oder so.
Das ist ja super.
Das ist echt geil gemacht.
What the fuck ist da unten los?
Was sehe ich hier gerade?
Was sagt mir das?
Also, jetzt mal Atomkraft-Flex-mäßig.
Was sehe ich da?
Aber die Half-Life-Sounds passen übelst gut dazu.
It's not.
But the Sound-Effects,
von Half-Life passen da immer,
extrem gut da und zu,
beziehungsweise,
hat der hat das wahrscheinlich einfach,
nur gut zusammengeschnitten.
Das ist echt gut gemacht.
Was hat jemand im Chat gesagt?
Is es Terminator Half-Life Sounds?
Oder SFX?
Terminator Dubs bis halfway miterlebt.
Hahaha, der Türsound, so geil.
Aaaah.
Aaaaah.
Das ist der Half-Life-Sound, wenn man Gegenstände rumschiebt.
Der Half-Life-Sound, wenn man Kisten rumschiebt.
Das ist ultra geil gemacht.
Wie sie bei der immer diesen Silent-Test-Sound machen.
Das haben die super, also das haben die extrem geil nachvertont, oder?
Haha.
Hoffentlich ist das nicht Toss, man hätte das echt 1 zu 1 verfilmen können, ja.
Das ist richtiges Kokona-Shooting hier gerade.
Aus der Hüfte einfach mal in die Richtung gesprayt.
Easy.
Haha, ist doch geil gemacht.
Haha.
cryo cooler perfektiert peltier peltier peltier oder so heißt das wahrscheinlich
das ist diese geschichte muss auf der einen seite warm wird auf der anderen
seite wird es kalt ich weiß nicht wie man das ausspricht wie spricht man das aus
aussprache von peltier okay das müssen wir uns jetzt anhören wie spricht man
das aus peltier was was peltier what the fuck peltier nein nee oder das kann
nicht sein peltier was ah ja okay hier kriegen wir es die pronunciation academy erklärt uns das
das ist so ein video mit zehn sekunden intro und dann kommt ein wort peltier
ne das sind die amis jetzt
okay google translator wie gehen das überhaupt hier google translator google
translator peltier nein french french peltier peltier nee eher nicht
irgendwie failen die alle an dem an der an dem wort okay german
peltier peltier nee
oder die amaus sei ist egal für das video wir müssen uns nicht richtig
aussprechen können zumindest gibt es ein giving mal gucken ob das was taucht weil
wir hatten es noch letztens davon dass es sich nicht lohnt quasi alltäglichen
computerkram irgendwie mit flüssigstechstoffen zu kühlen
zusammen ich hat es genauso ein dann haben wir haben teams hatte sachen von
ihnen geschickt bekommen eine technologie von der ich anfang dieses
jahres niemals gedacht hätte dass das so schnell zurück kommt und vor allem nicht
von so einem großen Hersteller wie Intel.
Hätte ich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht erwartet.
Es wird euch auf jeden Fall, wenn ihr meinem Kanal schon länger folgt...
Also ich hätte das nie erwartet, weil ich mir nie Gedanken drüber gemacht habe.
Sehr bekannt vorkommen, 2014 habe ich so einen Kühler selber entwickelt.
Und 2018 haben wir uns das gemeinsam in einem YouTube-Video angeschaut.
Das ist die Controller-Box dazu.
Der Kühler ist dann letztendlich mal in der PC-Welt-Höllenmaschine gelandet.
Deswegen habe ich den auch nicht mehr hier.
Das Kühlprinzip ging nämlich um Peltier-Elemente.
Das ist ein Peltier-Element für die, die es nicht kennen.
Wir haben hier diese weißen Platten.
Das sind meistens Keramikplatten.
Also das ist doch diese Geschichte.
Das muss auf der einen Seite irgendwie...
Auf der einen Seite fühlt es warm und auf der anderen Seite fühlt es kalt.
Umso größer der Temperaturunterschied ist...
Nee, warte mal. Wie ging das nochmal?
Egal, er erklärt es wahrscheinlich.
Aluminium-Ausführung ist aber relativ selten.
Und zwischen diesen Keramikplatten eingefasst sind Halbleiterbau-Elemente.
Und wenn man dann eine Spannung anlegt an die Kabel hier,
dann erzeugt man eine Temperaturdifferenz zwischen den zwei Platten.
Das heißt, die eine wird heiß, die andere wird kalt.
Und man kann Wärme quasi durch dieses Teil durchpumpen.
Ist generell eigentlich...
Aber man muss doch auf der anderen Seite kühlen, ne?
Also auf der warmen Seite muss man doch Kühler drauf machen,
dass es weiterhin richtig funktioniert.
Interessant.
Weil wenn es zu warm wird, geht es irgendwie nicht mehr gut.
Wenn man sich das mal vorstellt, wir haben die heiße Seite,
die haben wir bei 50 Grad Celsius, was relativ warm ist.
Aber bei so einem großen Petit-Element, da kann man schnell mal Temperaturdifferenzen
von 40, 50, 60 Grad Celsius erreichen.
Das bedeutet, halten wir die oben bei 50 Grad Celsius, die warme Seite,
dann ist die kalte Seite bei 0 Grad Celsius.
Und das ist ein Kühlprinzip.
Das kommt vor allem zum Beispiel in so Mini-Kühlschränken zum Einsatz
oder so Transportboxen, die man ins Auto packen kann,
die man so an den Zigarettenanzünder anschließt.
Da sind meistens Pelletier-Elemente...
Der Chat wieder, der Chat.
Hakenkreuzlichter.
Da muss man aber viel Fantasie haben, dass man da draufkommt.
Ich meine, wenn man es...
Also man kann es erkennen, ja?
Also Chat, ich hätte es jetzt nicht erkannt.
Aber wenn man es einmal gesehen hat, erkennt man es eigentlich, ja?
Relativ günstig, sind aber sehr ineffizient.
Das ist das eigentliche Problem an dieser Thematik.
Bei so einem Kühlschrank, ehrlich gesagt, nicht so das Problem.
Bei einem CPU-Kühler, was wir damals festgestellt haben,
2018, ist das gar nicht so einfach.
Man braucht so ein riesig großes Pelletier-Element,
wie das, was wir hier haben.
Und die haben dann einfach...
Okay, jetzt müssen wir mal gucken, wie er das ausspricht.
Riesig großes Pelletier-Element.
Pelletier-Element.
Okay.
Easy.
Wieder was gelernt, Leute.
Eleven Head.
Educational Stream.
...wie das, was wir hier haben.
Und die haben dann einfach mal eine Leistungsaufnahme von 300 Watt.
Okay.
Pelletier.
Alles klar.
...which we hier abführen.
Und mit diesen 300 Watt kann man keine 300 Watt quasi kühlen,
sondern ich sag mal so als groben Anhaltspunkt immer so die Hälfte.
Bedeutet beim 300 Watt...
Ich hab ihm jetzt aufgrund dieses Ausspraches gar nicht richtig zugehört.
Ich muss mal kurz zurückspulen.
...aufnahme von 300 Watt.
Und diese 300 Watt,
an dem wir hier haben,
zusätzliche Abwärme, die müssen
wir ja abführen. Und
mit diesen 300 Watt kann man keine
300 Watt quasi kühlen, sondern ich sag mal
so als Gruppenanhaltspunkt immer so die Hälfte.
Bedeutet beim 300 Watt Peltier-Element
kann man so maximal effizient 150
Watt Abwärme abführen. Und das ist so
der Bereich, den wir bei einer CPU
haben. Und jetzt hat Intel
sich gedacht, okay, wir greifen
dieses Prinzip nochmal auf und
schauen, ob da eine Grafikkarte drin ist oder
ob das nur der Karton ist.
Also er hat definitiv
der 3090, ich glaube er hat sogar ein Video schon gezeigt,
ein bisschen besser machen können als das, was die Vergangenheit
gezeigt hat. Also das, was ich zum Beispiel gemacht
habe oder auch Cool-IT
oder Cool-It, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man die ausspricht.
Die haben sowas auch vor. Die Cool-Leute würden das wahrscheinlich
Cool-Eit oder so aussprechen,
weil die ja auch Ubuntu
Jubantu aussprechen.
Jahren schon mal gemacht, haben das dann aber
auch wieder verworfen unter
gewissen Gründen. Wie gesagt, die Effizienz
ist immer so ein großes
Problem. Ich hatte das damals mit dieser
Controllerbox als sogenannten
Zweipunktregler. Das
heißt, ich hatte hier ein
Relais drin, ein Solid-State-Relais, also
das kann Gleichspannungen schalten und
hier vorne den Regler an sich und dann
wurde eben das Peltier-Element
angeschlossen an 12 Volt Spannung
mit einem Temperatursensor und wenn
der Temperatursensor 20 Grad zum Beispiel
erreicht hat, dann ging das Ding an,
dann kühlt es runter bis auf 16 Grad zum Beispiel
und dann geht es wieder aus, geht wieder hoch
auf 20 Grad, geht wieder an.
Das kann man so machen, hat aber ein riesengroßes
Problem. Das heißt, sobald das Peltier-Element
ausgeht, fließt
ja quasi die Wärme
wieder zurück. Also die Wärme fließt
immer von der warmen zur kalten Seite.
So ist es einfach physikalisch. Das stimmt.
Weil es eigentlich keine Kälte gibt, sondern eigentlich
nur Wärme oder halt Wärmedifferenz.
Oh, Big Brain, educational
hier wieder. Fließt immer von der
warmen zur kalten Seite. Das muss man einfach
wissen und wenn man das Peltier-Element dann ausmacht
und oben drüber ist der Teil, der quasi
gerade gekühlt wird, der 50 Grad hat,
dann fließt die Wärme eben sehr, sehr schnell nach unten
wieder runter und das Ding muss sofort wieder angehen.
Und damit ist es meistens
relativ oft im Dauerbetrieb
und das ist dann eben ziemlich
ineffizient und man hat eben zusätzlich
immer 300 Grad Abwärme. Klingt logisch.
Intel hat eine eigene Controller-Platine
entwickelt. Wir schauen uns das auch gleich alles
im Detail an. Ich habe es selber noch null ausprobiert,
habe es gerade selbst erst ausgepackt. Ich war zwar
ein bisschen bei der Entwicklung beteiligt, gerade
was so Software und Features betrifft.
Da haben die mich vor einigen Wochen kontaktiert,
haben mir quasi den Prototyp mal so
vorgestellt und haben gesagt, das wollen wir machen.
Siehst du da irgendwo Probleme?
Und dann habe ich so ein bisschen Feedback gegeben,
was auf jeden Fall wichtig ist.
Das Problem ist, dass es das noch nicht gibt.
Er hat wahrscheinlich gesagt, ja, ich will es morgen haben.
Und jetzt haben wir das Ding da und können das testen.
Und Intel hat, wie gesagt,
so ein eigenes Controller-Board entwickelt,
was sehr, sehr gut ist.
Ich sage mal, es ist das Beste, was man aus einem
Peltier-Element rausholen kann.
Es ist kein reiner Zweipunktregler, sondern
es kann eine Spannung regeln. Das bedeutet,
das kann dann das Peltier-Element
nicht nur bei 12 Volt betreiben, sondern eben auch
bei 4 Volt zum Beispiel.
Und dementsprechend, wenn dann eure CPU im Idle sitzt
und die Leistungsaufnahme
sehr, sehr gering ist, dann kann auch die Leistungsaufnahme
vom Tag zurückgefahren werden.
Was auf jeden Fall gut ist.
Das sollte die Effizienz
deutlich verbessern. Vor allem wird es dann ja
nicht ausgeschaltet. Das bedeutet,
die Wärme fließt nicht komplett zurück.
Und damit sollte auch die Leistung
gerade im Idle deutlich besser sein.
Das werden wir uns aber gleich anschauen.
Alles klar.
Den Kühleraufbau, den ich damals hatte, ist auch
der hier von EK.
Da ist ein Peltier-Element drin zwischen
einer Kühlseite und einer dicken
Kupferplatte. Schauen wir uns aber gleich im Detail an.
Und dann gibt es hier eben
diese Controllerbox dazu. Aber ich glaube, ich hole mal die Kamera
und wir schauen uns das Close-Up an. Das ist ein bisschen interessanter.
Dieses Video wird präsentiert
von Corsair und den Neuen.
Das geht nicht los. Das ist Sellout-Modus.
Wenn wir das Video vornehmen, gucken wir uns jetzt noch
Sellout-Modus an.
Und wenn du maximale Kühlleistung suchst, könnt ihr das
4000D Airflow mit der perforierten Front
eine gute Wahl für dich sein. Wenn es dann doch lieber
ein bisschen auffälliger sein sollte und du dem Drang
nach RGB einfach nicht nachgeben kannst,
dann ist das IQ4000X RGB
eine gute Option für dich. Alle Varianten sind in
schwarz oder weiß verfügbar, bieten mit dem
Rapid-Root-Kabelführungssystem eine
aufgeräumte Rückseite, USB 3.1 Type-C,
USB 3.0 und Audio in der
Front sowie ein großes... Ich finde, der macht
die Sellouts immer gut. Das hört
sich immer so richtig nach Sellout an.
Nicht, dass er Bock hat, das zu erzählen,
weil du hast ja manche Leute, wenn die
irgendwelche Produktanpreisungen
machen, dann stellen die das immer so hin,
als finden sie das Produkt selber
extrem geil. Und er stellt sich immer so hin
und liest so das Datenblatt vor.
Ja, das ist das neue Gehäuse von Corsair,
das hat einen An-Button, das hat einen Aus-Button, das hat
einen USB 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 Anschluss,
Platz bis zu 75 Festplatten
und das Ganze wiegt dann bloß noch 2 Kilo
und am Ende kriegt man dann auch
noch irgendwie die private
Handynummer von der Entwicklerin dabei
und das ist das neue Corsair-Gehäuse und weiter geht's.
Ja.
Das Platzangebot für bis zu
620 mm oder
140 mm Lüfter und dementsprechend auch
für Radiatoren. Der MadaFaka361
hat abonniert, dankeschön, für 4 Monate.
Excellent Subscription.
Wo ist mein Subscription-Sound?
Weiß.
Mit was?
Mit was kann ich das kombinieren?
Okay, es ist eine Wasserkühlung,
das habe ich verstanden.
Aber das war mir jetzt zu kompliziert.
Ach, was für ein Teil, Alter.
Millimeter Lüfter und dementsprechend auch für Radiatoren.
Damit könnt ihr die Gehäuse natürlich auch perfekt
mit der neuen IQ...
IQ? Elite?
Capellix?
IQ, Elite, Capellix?
Ach du Scheiße, das kann ich
beim Leben noch nicht merken.
Was Produktnamen immer, Alter.
IQ, Elite, Capellix Duo.
I-O, I-O, I-O.
Oh, geil.
Eine wunderschöne Optik.
Im Lieferumfang findet ihr auch den Commander Core Controller,
mit dem ihr alles ganz bequem über IQ steuern könnt.
Mehr erfahrt ihr über den Link in der Beschreibung.
So sieht der Kühler jetzt aus.
IQ, Elite, Big Brain Kühler.
Der ist auf jeden Fall mindestens dreiteilig.
Also wir haben oben eine vernickelte Abdeckung.
Also das Teil ist auch aus Kupfer.
Dann haben wir quasi hier in der Mitte
eine Platte.
Die ist nicht vernickelt. Das ist die Kühlplatte.
Das ist das, was man hier sieht, wenn man jetzt ein bisschen reinschaut.
Und dann sieht man die ganze Struktur innen drin.
Das ist die Kühlplatte.
Also die kühlt quasi die heiße Seite vom Pelletier-Element.
Und dann haben wir hier unten eben
noch mal ein relativ massives Stück Kupfer.
Das verteilt dann einfach noch so ein bisschen
die Wärme, beziehungsweise
entzieht die Wärme eben von der CPU
ein bisschen effizienter.
Hier seht ihr, zwischendrin ist das Pelletier-Element.
Fasst so aus, als wäre Keck W auch aus Kupfer, oder?
Von der Farbe her.
Das Pelletier-Element ist von der Größe her eben viel, viel größer als die CPU.
Und deswegen ist dann hier oben, sage ich mal,
die Wärme, die wir hier haben,
dieser zusätzliche Heatsplatter noch drauf.
An der Seite hier gehen dann
zwei Kabel raus. Da haben wir hier oben
einen Temperaturfühler drin.
Der misst dann
die Temperatur von dieser Kupferplatte
und dann haben wir Stromanschluss
für das Pelletier-Element selbst.
Und falls ihr euch gewundert habt,
wozu diese beiden...
Das sieht von der Konstruktion her, ehrlich gesagt, ziemlich simpel aus.
Schrauben hier an der Seite da sind,
das ist für den Controller.
Der wird dann später hier oben
so drauf montiert,
über die zwei Schrauben.
Dann haben wir hier noch das Steuergerät selbst.
Wie ihr sehen könnt, hat das Teil drei Anschlüsse.
Einmal links Stromanschluss, müsste
8-Pin-EPS sein oder PC-Express.
Dann in der Mitte den Stromanschluss
für das Pelletier-Element selbst.
Und ganz rechts eben...
Sieht man da irgendwie, was da für ein Controller drauf ist?
Das, was wir gerade vom Kühler selbst gesehen haben.
Irgendwie gesehen, was da...
Man da irgendwie sieht, was da drauf ist?
Das Ganze eingefasst
in ein Aluminiumgehäuse.
Hier ist noch so ein bisschen
ein Wärmeleitpad dran.
Ich glaube, wir schrauben das mal schnell auf.
Schauen wir da kurz rein.
Ja, genau. Zeigst du mir ja, was ist da drauf?
Hier haben wir jetzt den geöffneten Controller.
Da sehen wir das nochmal.
Ich hatte übrigens den USB-Anschluss hier oben.
Natürlich zur Steuerung.
Was ist das denn?
C?
Nee, das ist kein MediaTag, keine Ahnung.
Was ist das?
Also gut, das wäre ja auch bescheuert, wenn Intel irgendwelche MediaTags haben
oder so verbaut.
Das ist wahrscheinlich Intel-Gedöns.
Nuvoton.
NPC, keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Äh, das ist die, das ist die
HUM-MCU.
... vergessen. Hier innen drin
ist ein interner Anschluss, der ist wahrscheinlich dazu,
um die Firmware von dem Controller zu flashen.
Ähm, hat man von außen
keinen Zugang. Ich glaube, das wird
für uns auch erstmal nicht notwendig sein
oder irgendwie wichtig sein.
Das kann man da suchen. NPC-E9.
NPC-E9.
Oh.
Nee, danach können wir nicht suchen.
Das ist zu, zu, äh,
...
Die Frage, ob das in der Retail-Version dann immer noch dran ist.
Und dieses Teil hier oben, wo hier HUM steht, ist Humidity-Sensor, also ein Feuchtigkeits-Sensor.
Und das ist wirklich, wirklich cool.
Denn das große Problem in der Vergangenheit bei solchen Kühlern war ja immer Kondensation.
Das bedeutet, wenn die Platte hier unten zu kalt wird, weil rein theoretisch das Peltier-Element,
wenn ihr dem sagt, hau rein, volle Power und ihr habt eine Wassertemperatur von, keine Ahnung, 25 Grad Celsius,
dann habt ihr hier unten vielleicht minus 10 Grad.
Das heißt, ihr könntet sich nicht nur Kondenswasser bilden, sondern auch Eis.
Und das wäre wirklich ein Problem, wenn man das Ganze nicht vernünftig isoliert.
Und über den Feuchtigkeits-Sensor kann die Platine nämlich auch aktiv berechnen, wo ist euer Taupunkt.
Weil wenn ihr zum Beispiel 20 Grad Celsius Raumtemperatur habt und eine gewisse Luftfeuchtigkeit,
dann kann die Platte durchaus zum Beispiel 14 Grad Celsius haben, ohne dass sich hier Kondenswasser bildet.
Und so ist eben die niedrigste Temperatur möglich.
Die wir mit normalen Kühlmethoden so einfach erreichen können.
Und das ist auf jeden Fall deutlich, deutlich intelligenter als die Lösung, die ich damals hatte.
Und um das Ganze dann nochmal ein bisschen besser und ausgereifter zu machen, gibt es noch diesen Rahmen hier.
Also es ist ein Teil irgendwie aus...
Das sieht aus wie aus dem 3D-Drucker.
Das ist Schaumstoff.
Sieht aus wie aus dem 3D-Drucker.
...artiv interessant gestaltet.
Ihr seht unten die Form entspricht genau dem, was man beim Mainboard-Sockel hat.
Und dann gibt es eben diesen Rahmen hier, der so ein bisschen weich ist.
Ob das nur auf Intel-CPUs funktioniert?
Ja, das ist ein bisschen weich.
Und dann gibt es quasi einen...
Von der Technik her natürlich nicht, aber vielleicht haben die es so gebaut, dass es anschlusstechnisch nur auf Intel-Mainboards geht.
...einen Raum und dann gibt es noch weniger, beziehungsweise dann gar keine Kondensation.
Weil dann habt ihr eben nur die Feuchtigkeit, die hier in diesem Raum ist.
Und das ist dann eben sehr begrenzt wenig.
Und selbst wenn dann der Kühl...
Der Sockel ist nur Intel-Comp...
Okay, das wundert mich nicht.
Das ist so ein typisches Intel-Ding.
Eigentlich würde sich das super eignen für alle Arten von CPUs, aber nein, muss Intel auch nicht.
...kalt wäre, dann kann da eigentlich nichts mehr passieren.
Zumindest in der Theorie.
So, jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt drauf, wie es kühlt.
Ich baue das Teil auf.
Übrigens habe ich dafür auch einen 10.900K bekommen.
Und der ist von Intel auch extra selektiert.
Das soll ich auch extra dazu sagen.
Die wollen natürlich zeigen, was man damit erreichen kann, wenn man einen guten 10.900K hat.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie gut er ist.
Die haben dir wahrscheinlich jetzt die beste CPU der letzten drei Jahre gegeben, so nach dem Motto.
Das ist jetzt auch...
Bissauf fragt mich nicht, wie viel Gigabyte.
Ja, es geht.
Ich soll das nicht vorenthalten.
Dass das gut ausschaut für Intel.
Dass der auch gebindt ist.
Finde ich fair.
Schauen wir mal.
Ich baue das alles zusammen.
Bin gespannt.
Ich verwende für den Test jetzt Cruenaut Extreme.
Normalerweise würde ich für sowas eigentlich noch lieber Flüssigmetall verwenden.
In dem Temperaturbereich geht es auch noch absolut.
Aber ihr könnt ja sehen, dass die Oberfläche von dem Kühler...
Ich glaube, das ist halt eben noch ein Prototyp von EK Waterblocks.
Und dementsprechend ist der hier nicht vernickelt.
Und nicht vernickelte Oberflächen sollte man mit Flüssigmetall vermeiden.
Deswegen verwende ich jetzt lieber normales Cruenaut Extreme.
Als Intel mir das Ganze vorgestellt hat, da hatte ich ein bisschen Bedenken, was die Rückseite betrifft.
Weil die Rückseite ist komplett offen.
In Kombination mit Kupfer ist das wohl extrem doof, wenn man das mit Flüssigmetall-Legierung macht.
Ich kenne mich da mit den chemischen Sachen nicht wirklich aus.
Aber ich habe das ja auch mit meiner CPU gemacht.
Ich habe ja oben den Heatspreader abgemacht und dann Flüssigmetall dazwischen.
Ja.
Und dann nochmal irgendwas komisches zwischen CPU und Kühler und sowas.
Und da stand überall, man soll gucken, dass man keinen Kühler hat, der Kupferkontakt hat oder irgendwie sowas.
Deswegen habe ich jetzt hier auch mal noch einen Temperatursensor angebracht.
Und dann messen wir hier gleichzeitig eben Rückseite vom Mainboard.
Das ist auch mit Absicht hier an diesem Metallteil dran vom Sockel.
Und auch mit Absicht in dieser Position, also weit weg von den Spannungswandlern.
Weg von dem Bereich hier.
Da sollte so der kühlste Bereich vom CPU-Sockel sein.
Dann haben wir hier noch...
Seit wann sehen Mainboard-Rückseiten so fancy aus?
Seit es 800 Euro Mainboards gibt.
...gegen den Temperaturfühler.
Und mit dem können wir dann nochmal die Lufttemperatur messen.
Einfach nur um zu checken, dass es da hinten auch nicht zu kalt ist.
Ich weiß nicht, was das kostet.
Gucken wir doch mal.
Das war irgendwie Rock Maximus.
Ja, Extreme wahrscheinlich.
Easy.
Das sind halt nice Mainboard-Preise, ja.
Das ist kein Wunder, dass die so fancy aussehen.
Ein Schnapper.
Der Kühler soweit montiert, hat eigentlich alles gut funktioniert.
Ich muss zu meiner Schande gestehen, als ich den das erste Mal gesehen habe bei Intel,
da ist mir auch gar nicht aufgefallen, dass der USB-Anschluss oben so dämlich platziert ist.
Das sieht echt nicht gut aus.
Ich muss sagen, die restlichen Kabel gingen eigentlich, habe ich mir schlimmer vorgestellt.
Aber der Stromanschluss fehlt natürlich noch.
Aber die restlichen Kabel jetzt einfach in den Block.
In den Block reingehen, zum Peltier-Element und Temperatursensor.
Die konnte ich da relativ bequem reinstopfen.
Also so sieht das eigentlich schon mal ganz interessant aus.
Das System läuft jetzt.
Der 10900K ist von mir soweit auch schon voreingestellt.
Das zeige ich euch im BIOS gleich auch nochmal.
Gestern hat mir einer auf Twitter geantwortet, fällt mir gerade bei CPUs ein.
Das habe ich nicht verstanden, was der gestern geschrieben hat auf Twitter.
Ja, guck mal.
Vielleicht kann mir das einer von euch erklären.
Und zwar, gestern hat einer darauf geantwortet.
Äh.
Hallo, sieht man nicht.
Wer mir was schreibt da?
Hier, das da.
Er hat gestern auf Twitter geschrieben.
Er hat mein PC-Bau-Vorschlag-Video von vor 6,5 Jahren geguckt.
Und hat sich damals einen Rechner gekauft.
Den fand er gut.
Und jetzt hat er geschrieben.
War alles eine super Empfehlung.
Bis auf den Xeon-Prozessor.
Da hätte ich doch eher zu einem Intel greifen sollen.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, okay, was genau?
Was?
Was genau möchte er mir sagen?
Das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Weil ich meine, der Xeon ist doch ein Intel-Prozessor.
Meint er, er hätte lieber zu einem i5 oder so greifen sollen.
Aber warum?
Der Xeon war damals preis-leistungsmäßig die mit Abstand beste CPU.
Besser als jeder i5, 7, was auch immer.
Aber es ist ja nicht so, als rechnet der falsch oder so.
6,5 Jahre.
Ja, ja, ja.
Leona-Bomb war 97.
15 Monate.
Boah.
So viel.
Das ist ja schon.
Eigentlich für die Subs hier.
Der Xeon war damals heftig.
Ja, das war der beste.
Das war beste Preis-Leistung.
Ich habe mir damals ja auch so einen Rechner gebaut.
Was genau ich alles gemacht habe.
Alles auf Maximus 12 Extreme.
Ja, das ist das 700 Euro Mainboard, was er hier hat.
Das andere läuft jetzt bei 3600 C18.
Genau, ein 1230 V3.
Genau sowas.
MP geladen.
Das ist eher wahrscheinlich auch zu hart.
Ich glaube, dass wir jetzt noch eine Pause haben würden.
Was denkst du über den Kühler, den der Bauer vorstellt?
Ja, bis jetzt haben wir ja noch nichts wirklich gesehen.
Außer wie es aussieht und funktioniert.
Aber nicht, was er macht.
Unten haben wir jetzt die Intel Tech Software.
Alleine, dass es nur für Intel funktioniert, ist halt.
Ja, macht es nicht sinnvoll.
Die ist eigentlich echt geil gemacht, weil die sehr, sehr schlicht gehalten ist.
Das gefällt mir dabei wirklich am meisten.
Das heißt, wir haben hier keine nervige Software, die irgendwelche großen Ressourcen im Hintergrund benötigt oder sowas.
Das ist hier auf jeden Fall schon mal gar nicht der Fall.
Wenn wir jetzt einfach mal anschauen, was es hier so gibt.
Hier sehen wir ganz oben, Kühler ist in Standby-Mode.
Das heißt, hier passiert erstmal noch gar nichts.
Hier sehen wir die Leistungsaufnahme vom Peltier-Element.
Da passiert auch noch nichts.
Der ausgerechnete Taupunkt, gerade bei mir, bei der Raumtemperatur von geschätzt 22 Grad Celsius, relativ niedrige Luftfeuchtigkeit, liegt bei 13,6 Grad Celsius.
Kühler-Temperatur im Boden gerade 31,2 Grad Celsius.
Also das wird hier alles schon mal gut ausgelesen.
Ja.
Wenn man auf Mode geht, gibt es hier zwei Funktionen.
Verschiedene Modi.
Einmal Kryo und einmal Unregulated.
Kryo ist eben der geregelte Modus, dass man über das Taupunkt bleibt.
Und Unregulated ist volle Pulle.
Und dann eben auch, wenn das System im Idle läuft, dann geringe Leistungsaufnahme.
Schauen wir uns gleich an.
Unregulated ist einfach 100% immer volle Leistung.
Das Tag läuft dann immer voll ausgelastet.
Hier noch so ein bisschen Zusatzsachen, die wir nicht brauchen.
Hiho, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich komme das Video zum ersten Mal.
Kein Schermer.
Wir schaffen jetzt auch mal mit Unregulated Mode.
Schauen wir einfach mal, was passiert eigentlich, wenn wir das Teil komplett unreguliert laufen lassen.
Und ob das ein Risiko für unser Mainboard und unser System darstellt.
Da kriegen wir jetzt auch so eine Warnmeldung, die wir erstmal bestätigen müssen.
Also, dass wir das Ganze auf eigenes Risiko machen.
Und dass hier Condensers entstehen.
Da hat die Rechtsabteilung gesagt, Leute, baut sowas ein.
Es ist uns egal, ob es kaputt geht, aber ihr müsst einen Hinweis einbauen.
Wie euer System isoliert ist, bla bla.
Und wir bestätigen das Ganze mit OK.
Dann sehen wir unten Success, also läuft es jetzt.
Da sehen wir auch schon die Kerntemperatur.
Das seht ihr hier oben mit hardware-info.
Oh, das ist aber kühl.
Da geht es jetzt direkt zackig auf die 0 Grad.
Das ist aber kühl.
Also unter 0 liest hardware-info normalerweise nicht aus.
Auch Core-Temp nicht.
Wir sehen aber hier das Tag.
Also das Peltier-Element zieht jetzt gerade hier ca. 160 Watt.
Okay, okay.
Also der Kühler braucht ungefähr so viel wie die Grafikkarte.
Unter ordentlicher Last.
Das ist, glaube ich, preis-leistungsmäßig nicht so für einen täglichen Betrieb gut.
Unser Taupunkt steigt minimal an.
Ist eigentlich davon unbeeinflusst.
Und die Kühler-Temperatur ist jetzt bei minus 2 Grad.
Das ist natürlich echt cool.
Obwohl es jetzt erst gefühlt 2 Minuten läuft.
Mal schauen, wo sich das Ganze gleich auspendelt.
Overclocking machen wir mit Intel XTU, weil da können wir den Thermal Velocity Boost richtig einstellen.
Das zeige ich euch gleich alles, wie das funktioniert.
Hier oben seht ihr meine Basis-Einstellung.
Ich habe tatsächlich 1,46 Volt mit Adaptive Mode eingestellt.
Power Limits sind in Kraft.
Das heißt, sie sind nicht ausgehebelt.
Da seht ihr hier 250 bzw. 125 Watt Power Target.
Und bevor jetzt gleich wieder rumgeheult wird und es heißt, oh, der Bauer empfiehlt wieder so hohe Spannungen.
Diese Spannungen wurden mir von Intel empfohlen.
Das möchte ich auch direkt mal festhalten.
Der arme Bauer.
Da steht bis zu 1,52 Volt drin.
Und solange ihr die Turbo-Werte so lasst und euch an das Datenblatt haltet, ist das auch okay.
Und Intel hat mir diese Werte, wie gesagt, auch vorgegeben.
Der Bauer ist natürlich jemand, der sich immer ganz strikt an das Datenblatt hält.
Das wissen wir ja.
Wie gesagt, damit erreichst du die beste Performance mit dem, was wir hier machen können.
Also wenn ihr euch beschweren wollt, beschwert euch nicht bei mir.
Und die ganze Magie, die wir jetzt hier benötigen, kommt über den Thermal Velocity Boost.
Also das müsst ihr hier oben auf Enable setzen.
Und dann gibt es hier die zwei wichtigen Punkte.
Also erstmal hier links habt ihr den Ratio Table.
Den habe ich soweit erstmal für mich konfiguriert.
Das bedeutet, wenn wir zehn aktive Kerne haben, dann laufen die zum Beispiel alle bei 5,3 Gigahertz.
Ach stimmt.
Ich habe ja ganz vergessen.
Das Ding hat ja mittlerweile zehn Kerne.
Das haben wir übrigens auch nur AMD zu verdanken, dass es das jetzt gibt.
Ansonsten würde Intel wahrscheinlich immer noch bei sechs oder höchstens acht Kerne rumkripsen.
Im Desktop-Segment.
Haben wir jetzt nur acht aktive Kerne, dann geht es 100 MHz höher.
Und ganz oben, wenn wir sehen, okay, nur zwei Kerne sind aktiv, dann kann sich die CPU bis auf 5,8 Gigahertz boosten.
Das ist so aktuell von mir eingestellt.
Und hier rechts haben wir einen Link.
Hier rechts haben wir ein Limit mit 70 Grad Celsius aktuell von mir eingestellt.
Intel hat zwar empfohlen, ich soll das mal mit 80 versuchen.
Das war bei mir aber zu hoch.
Da hat es gecrashed.
Das bedeutet, wenn die CPU eine Temperatur von 70 Grad Celsius erreicht, dann taktet sie sich um den Wert, der hier rechts ist, runter.
In dem Fall dann auf 5,5 Gigahertz.
Oder wenn wir dann zehn Kerne verwenden, dann eben auf 5,2 Gigahertz, wenn es über 70 Grad Celsius geht.
Also über 70 Grad wird mit dem Kühler schwierig.
Coole Funktion.
Das wird in Zukunft auch bei vielen Boards im BIOS hinterlegt werden.
Und ist dann nicht nur für das Peltier-Element interessant, sondern auch zum Beispiel für Wasser.
Max Riss droppt hier wieder die Wahrheiten im Chat.
Mehr als zwei Kerne kann das menschliche Auge nicht sehen.
Tja, deswegen braucht man ja auch diese Übertaktungssoftware von Intel.
Sonst wäre das gar nicht möglich.
Overclocking.
Wir starten jetzt eine Cinebench R20 Single Threaded Run.
Also Cinebench R20 mit AVX, das ist ein bisschen anspruchsvoller.
Trotzdem eben nur ein Thread, der ausgelastet wird.
Und dann können wir jetzt hier bei den Frequenzen schauen, dass die komplette CPU aktuell bei 5,6 Gigahertz boostet.
Ist das der volle Boost?
Wenn ihr jetzt noch eine entspanntere Anwendung habt, wie keine Ahnung, SuperPi oder sowas.
Also was kein AVX benutzt und nur SSE zum Beispiel.
Warte mal, warte mal, warte mal.
5,6.
Auf was habe ich meinen nochmal übertaktet, nachdem ich ihn geköpft habe?
5,1?
Also mittlerweile ja nicht mehr, weil es...
Ich habe es dann irgendwann wieder runtergenommen.
Ich glaube 5,1.
Das ist schon ordentlich.
Was hat denn der standardmäßig so?
Was ist das denn? 10.900K?
Was hat denn der Standard so? Boost-Takt?
5,3.
Ja, das ist schon ordentlich.
Also ohne, dass der jetzt da großartige Sachen gemacht hat.
Dann boostet die auch auf 5,8.
Aber mit AVX sind 5,8 zu viel.
Und mit AVX ist klar.
Deswegen packt die CPU sich jetzt runter auf 5,6.
Aber ist trotzdem absolut beachtlich.
Mit AVX, das musste ich bei mir auch einstellen.
Mit AVX ging es nicht.
Selbst geköpft und das Originale der Bauer-Dings, Wärmeleitpaste drauf.
Das war noch damals nicht die offizielle der Bauer-Wärmeleitpaste.
Das war noch hier, frag mich nicht, Conductor-Naut, Kryo-Naut, sonst was.
Mittlerweile ist das ja irgendwie der Bauer-Wärmeleitpaste.
Sind die 5,3 gleichzeitig auf allen Kernen?
Ne.
Also normalerweise haben sie das ja so eingestellt, dass das, je nachdem wie viele Kerne du hast, runter geht.
Also wahrscheinlich ist es bei, normalerweise bei 10 Kernen 5,3 oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Bei 5,3 oder bei 4 oder so.
Bei 4,9 oder, ich kann dir ehrlich gesagt das nicht sagen aus dem Kopf, wie das ist.
Aber standardmäßig ist es so eingestellt, dass du diesen vollen Boost nicht mit allen Cores aktiv hinkriegst.
Deswegen musste ich damals bei mir im Mainboard auch All-Core-Boost-Turbo oder wie das heißt einstellen,
dass der quasi immer unabhängig davon, was Intel da einprogrammiert hat an Kurven und sonst was, immer den maximalen Boost nimmt.
Ja.
Das hat sich, das lohnt sich leistungsmäßig auch schon ordentlich.
Weil es ist ein Unterschied, wenn du mal wirklich die CPU ordentlich auslastest, ob du jetzt das Ding mit, frag mich nicht, 4,6 oder 5 laufen hast.
Ne, 4,3 war glaube ich.
Ich glaube der Boost bei mir, bei meinem 8700K war glaube ich 4,3 bei allen Kernen.
Und ich habe jetzt irgendwie glaube ich 4,8 oder so auf allen Kernen.
Irgendwie.
Ist auch egal.
Zumindest lohnt sich das.
Leistungstechnisch ganz gut, wenn man einen ordentlichen Kühler hat.
Kommt.
Und da sieht man auch den Grund, warum das Ganze bei diesen Taktraten überhaupt laufen kann.
Kerntemperatur liegt hier die ganze Zeit zwischen 10 und der Kern, der belastet wird eben 40 Grad Celsius.
Das ist ultra niedrig.
Ja.
Ich hatte ja das Bedenken, was die Rückseite betrifft bezüglich Kondenswasser.
Aber wie ihr sehen könnt, also der obere Wert ist die Rückseite vom Mainboard.
Da sind wir mit 33 Grad Celsius noch ganz, ganz weit davon entfernt.
Dass wir Probleme hätten.
Und unten seht ihr die Raumtemperatur.
Also ist auch gerade schnucklig warm bei mir im Zimmer.
Und bei dieser Einstellung seht ihr, haben wir einen Single Core Score von glatten 581 Punkten.
Das ist wirklich sehr, sehr ordentlich und ganz stark über dem, was die CPU normalerweise kann.
Multicore Score ist gar nicht so viel höher.
Der liegt gerade mal bei knapp über 6.000 Punkten.
Multicore zerstört den wahrscheinlich jeder aktuelle Ryzen, weil er einfach mehr Kerne hat.
Für den eigentlichen Gamingbetrieb später ist allerdings der Kryo Mode von dem PC.
Deutlich interessanter.
Beim Unregulated Mode ist es ja so, dass einfach das PLT-Element die ganze Zeit die volle Leistung ausnutzt.
Das bedeutet eben auch im Idle.
Dementsprechend hättet ihr dauerhaft eine Leistungsaufnahme von 160, 180 Watt zusätzlich.
Und das ist nicht unbedingt gut.
Ja, das stimmt.
Das ist ganz schön viel Strom für fragwürdig viel Gegenleistung.
Beim Kryo Mode wird die Temperatur vom Block knapp überhalten.
Knapp überhalt des Taupunktes gehalten.
Das können wir uns gleich nochmal in der Software anschauen.
Wenn ich jetzt hier eine Raumtemperatur von 120 Grad habe.
Ich meine, man muss sich überlegen.
Man hat dann permanent so viel Verbrauch zusätzlich nochmal wie eine Grafikkarte unter Last.
Das ist schon ordentlich.
Dann ist der Taupunkt bei einer relativ niedrigen Luftfeuchtigkeit bei vielleicht 14 oder 15 Grad Celsius.
Und dann ist der Kühler immer noch sehr, sehr kühl.
Schauen wir uns das mal an.
Für den Kryo Mode einfach unten wieder auf dem Icon und dann bei Mode Kryo auswählen.
Das sehen wir.
Das ist jetzt auch gerade hier der Fall.
Sehen wir hier Taupunkt knapp über 14 Grad Celsius.
Und mein Kühler läuft deswegen bei um die 16 Grad Celsius.
Und hier sehen wir jetzt auch im Idle die Leistungsaufnahme.
Okay, das geht ja noch.
Das geht ja noch.
Das ist dann eben von dem Element auch sehr, sehr gering.
Das ist was, mit dem man im Idle auch leben kann.
Ja.
Zumindest meiner Meinung nach.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Also hier haben wir 10, 15, manchmal 20 Watt Leistungsaufnahme.
Das ist absolut vertretbar.
Das ist okay.
Deutlich besser als 160 Watt.
Ja, das stimmt.
Der Boost im Spielemodus ist natürlich abhängig von dem Game, das ihr zocken wollt.
Ich habe jetzt hier gerade mal PUBG 1440p.
Wisst ihr, was mich bei PUBG echt immer wieder beeindruckt?
Dass das Spiel nach, frag mich nicht, 4 Jahren in der Entwicklung immer noch unfertig aussieht.
Und so unzusammenpassend alles.
Wir haben so um die 250 FPS.
PUBG sieht immer noch aus wie Early Access.
Das Ganze im System ja gepaart mit einer RTX 3090.
Die Systemtemperatur, also CPU-Temperatur, ist hier in der Regel...
PUBG ist auch ein Spiel, was...
...in der Regel...
...was grafisch absolut keine Identität hat.
Das ist einfach so...
Es sieht aus wie ein...
Also optisch sieht es aus wie ein Asset Flip.
Ist es nicht, ich weiß.
Aber es sieht aus wie einer.
Das hat keine eigene Identität grafisch.
Man kann jetzt zum Beispiel Fortnite oder Apex oder was auch immer...
...kann man jetzt vielleicht sagen, oh, alles so casual-mäßige Kackdinger gegen PUBG.
Gibt es ja welche, die das brauchen.
Aber die haben zumindest grafisch und gameplay-mäßig irgendwie eine eigene Identität, ja.
PUBG irgendwie gar nicht.
Die CPU ist natürlich, also...
...die CPU ist von 5,3 Gigahertz bis jetzt...
...zwischen...
...das sagt man 30 und 45 Grad Celsius.
Und da boostet die CPU zwischen 5 und 5,3 Gigahertz.
Das ist natürlich echt ordentlich vom Takt.
Und 5,3 Gigahertz ist selbst bei einer normalen Custom-Wasserkühlung eigentlich mit einem 10900K nicht möglich.
Da braucht man schon wirklich eine goldene CPU, um da 5,3 Gigahertz möglich zu haben.
mode wo das was braucht er jetzt nicht unfassbar viel strom verbraucht sondern in der regel hier
zwischen 80 und 120 war das ist aber trotzdem also sag mal so im durchschnitt 100 war zusätzlich
obendrauf das ist schon nicht ohne ja während man zockt und im eitel dann eben deutlich weniger
jetzt wechseln wir aber noch mal in den anregelated mode weil mich persönlich interessiert auch was
könnte ich jetzt maximal bei dieser cpu weil die ja auch in allen kern das bedeutet ich werde im
windows den power saving mode auf high performance stellen dann sollte die cpu hier aufhören sich
runter zu takten und dann schauen wir einfach mal was auf allen kern möglich ist dazu werde
ich auch mal die lüfter auf dem radiator ein bisschen mehr aufdrehen und dann vielleicht
noch so ein zwei grad rausholen während das system noch runterkühlt kurzer blick ins xtu das war
übrigens im gaming setup quasi gerade unser table also so war thermal velocity boost eingestellt
und eben die einzelnen taktraten ihr seht dass 10 9 und 8 kann er bei 53 liefen wenn nur sieben
oder weniger verwendet werden 54 und wenn zwei oder weniger kerne verwendet werden 56 gigahertz
und das ganze hier an den thermal velocity boost gekoppelt das bedeutet die 56 gigahertz sind nur
möglich kühler ist als 50 grad celsius und die anderen frequenzen nur wenn die cpu kühler als
65 beziehungsweise kühler als 70 grad celsius
ansonsten taktet es sich eben um den wert auf der rechten seite runter dann schauen wir jetzt
doch mal was letztendlich noch an maximaltakt dieses intel über takta tool sieht mittlerweile
viel besser aus ich habe ja noch die uralt version installiert und das sieht richtig
das sieht richtig kaputt und unbedienbar aus hier das ist eine uralt version die ich da installiert
habe das sieht übelst räudig aus das ding ey da gefällt mir das guck mal sogar noch mit diesem
windows 10 ding um da äh das gefällt mir das was da bauer hat das ist ja auch ein bisschen
die neue version hat es deutlich besser könnte das auch mal abdehnen in höchstleistung energiespar
modus alle kerne bei 53 gigahertz wir haben eine schnuckelige cpu spannung von 1,5 volt wie ihr hier
oben sehen könnt und die cpu temperatur ist typisch bei ungefähr fünf bis zehn grad celsius also 56
gigahertz haben wir schon mal auf allen kern gibt alles 57 scheint auch noch zu funktionieren ja und
5,8 das ist schon mal das ist schon mal wirklich krass ja damit sind wir auch am ende von diesem video
angekommen danach ist er abgekackt wahrscheinlich oder das war das maximum 5,9 gigahertz intel hat
bestimmt gesagt zeigt nicht wie der rechner crasht mit der cpu das ist das würde mich nicht wundern
so ein typischer marketing move man möchte nicht dass man das mit mit mit crashenden pcs irgendwie
verbindet kam dann direkt freeze und das system ging aus ja aber ist halt ein zehnkerner bei 5,8
das ist halt schon echt hart also sechs gigahertz und sowas aufwärts das sind halt die frequenzen
die man normalerweise mit trocken eis und flüssig schickstoff dann erst erreichen kann also für
mich persönlich der kühler auf jeden fall ein sehr cooles spielzeug also es ist genau das was
mir eben spaß macht damit so ein bisschen rum zu hantieren schauen was kann ich damit rausholen
dieser thermal velocity boost ist leiche phoenix doch bei 55,9 ist abgekackt das ist so was von
genial das schöne ist vor allem dass in zukunft je nachdem was für ein mainboard ihr habt
der thermal velocity boost auch im bios hinterlegt ist das bedeutet mal ignoriert mal diesen cryo
cooler sondern denkt einfach mal darüber nach ihr habt jetzt custom wasserkühlung dann könnt
ihr den thermal velocity boost ja genauso nutzen könnt sagen ey wenn die cpu so und so warm ist
die und die takt abkommt kann die cpu dann erreichen da kommt ihr auf jeden fall höher
als wenn ihr ein manuelles oc auf allen kernen dauerhaft bei einer fixierten spannung macht
also dementsprechend thermal velocity boost auch mal unabhängig von diesem cryo cooler definitiv
eine coole funktion der cryo cooler an sich für mich wie gesagt sehr sehr schönes spiel zu machen
ich habe dann erstmal internet spielerei kann ich behalten jetzt die lösung dafür sein dass
man eben immer noch quasi bei 14 nanometer hängt und immer die frage die frage mag intel bestimmt
gar nicht aus und kardas ist die frage jeder von euch stellen würde und ob das jetzt die lösung
sein soll gegen reisen 5.000 das war so mein erster gedanke als ich von dieser ganzen technologie gehört
Und das würdet ihr wahrscheinlich auch so denken.
Und die Antwort von Intel war,
dass dieses Projekt nicht als Riesenmassenprodukt gedacht ist
und dafür, dass man sagt, alles klar,
mit 10.900k und Cryo-Cooler,
dann stinken wir hier gegen den Ryzen 5.
Ich muss da mal kurz was sagen,
wo wir gerade bei unangenehmen Fragen sind.
Das war ja schon so ein bisschen,
ihr kennt ja das, wenn ihr dabei seid
und Leute fragen, andere Leute was,
und ihr wisst genau, dass diese Frage
demjenigen, der gefragt wird,
übelst unangenehm ist
und es zieht sich schon ein bisschen in euch zusammen,
so nach dem Motto, oh fuck, Alter.
Ah, zum Glück muss ich das jetzt nicht beantworten.
Und bei, ich weiß nicht, wann das war,
bei irgendeiner Gamescom,
da waren wir eingeladen bei Nvidia
zum Spachteln, zum Futtern,
nach dem Gamescom-Tag.
Und da waren auch jede Menge Nvidia-Leute logischerweise da.
Und da war gerade diese Zeit,
wo, vielleicht könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern,
dass mit dieser 4 GB Grafikkarte,
die nur 3,5 GB hat.
Und da ging es dann auch,
ich weiß nicht mehr, wie man da drauf gekommen ist,
aber da ging es dann auch so drum,
so nach dem Motto, ja okay,
so welche Frage wolltet ihr schon immer mal
an Nvidia stellen?
Und dann hat halt jemand gemeint,
so nach dem Motto, ja wann gibt es Grafikkarten
mit 4 GB?
Und ich habe mir schon gedacht,
also Alter, das will er jetzt bestimmt nicht hören.
Musst du dir halt mal vorstellen,
du bist dann auch noch eingeladen da
und ich meine, diese Dinger sind ja schon irgendwo dafür da,
um die Leute ein bisschen so darauf einzuschwören,
dass der jeweilige Hersteller halt der geilste und beste
und sonst was ist, ja.
Bei mir zieht das nur zum Teil,
aber es gibt bestimmt genug,
die sich davon beeinflussen lassen
und denken sich so nach dem Motto,
ah ja gut, Nvidia hat mir jetzt hier immer zwei Burger ausgegeben,
ich kann jetzt nichts schlechtes sagen oder sowas.
Also diese Veranstaltungen sind schon eindeutig dafür da,
dass man eben geprieft wird,
dass der Hersteller halt geil ist
und der eine, der war halt echt schmerzlos,
der war halt echt schmerzlos.
Ja wann gibt es Grafikkarten mit 4 GB?
Mit echt 4 GB.
Und da hat die Frau von Nvidia
dann bloß gemeint, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja.
Nächster.
Oh man.
Tja, es ist auch nicht,
ihr wisst, ich gehe nicht gerne auf solche Veranstaltungen, ja.
Aber es waren doch ein paar ganz lustige,
lustige Sachen dabei.
Und auch mega sinnlose,
zum Beispiel das Battlefield 1 Event,
das war echt huge sinnlos.
So ist es nicht gedacht,
sondern das ist ein Projekt, wo Intel gesagt hat,
das ist eine interessante Technologie
und sie schauen einfach mal,
was sie da technologisch rausholen können
und wie man diese Technologie verbessern kann
und was da rein theoretisch so mit Intel-Wissen
das Maximum möglich ist.
Was ich sehr, sehr cool finde,
weil bisher das, was man als Pelletier-Element-Kühler gesehen hat,
auch das, was von mir kam,
war bei Weitem nicht so ausgereift wie das.
Klar, ich habe halt nicht die Möglichkeit...
Ich finde, das ist eine echt coole Technik.
...auf den CPU so zuzugreifen,
dass man da einfach so Sachen regeln kann.
Kaufen würde ich es mir nicht,
aber ich finde die Technik nice.
Dementsprechend ist das wirklich das Beste,
was man so aus einem Pelletier-Element rausholen kann.
Gerade mit dieser Funktion,
dass es den Tau-Punkt aktiv berechnen kann.
Es ist cool gemacht.
Dass es eben eitel die Leistungsaufnahme vom Pelletier-Element
an die Leistungsaufnahme von der CPU anpasst.
Die Funktionen sind technisch einfach,
die sind einfach,
die sind einfach perfekt gelöst.
Besser kann man das mit dieser Technologie einfach nicht machen.
Es ist sehr, sehr cool gemacht.
Ich persönlich finde das Teil mega cool.
Ja, es ist cool.
Es lohnt sich halt überhaupt nicht,
aber cool ist es.
Und ihr kennt mich ja,
ich mache auch die ein oder anderen Sachen,
weil sie technisch nice sind,
nicht, weil sie unbedingt wahnsinnig sinnvoll sind.
Also eigentlich wäre das was für mich,
aber das ist mir dann doch zu übertrieben.
Probieren zu schauen,
was kann ich aus meiner CPU rausholen,
ein bisschen rumspielen,
ein paar Benchmarks machen.
Mal ich mir eh einen Ryzen hole für den nächsten Rechner.
Ja, ich sehe es halt absolut nicht als Massenlösung.
Ja, ist es auch nicht.
Also es ist halt einfach so,
wenn ihr euch überlegt,
wir hätten jetzt eine Million Gaming-PCs da draußen,
die alle mit dem Kühler ausgestattet werden
und alle brauchen plötzlich 100 Watt mehr Leistungsaufnahme,
dann ist es natürlich quasi global gesehen
so viel mehr Leistung,
die dann quasi gefressen wird für,
weiß ich nicht,
dass ich das in dieser Form nicht unterstützen würde,
sondern wie gesagt,
so als Spiele-Lösung so,
dass es halt einfach was ist zum
ich will schauen, was ist das Maximum
und probiere gerne als Enthusiasmus,
ja, ist da mein PC rum,
ist das ein geiles Teil
und da macht das auch mega viel Spaß.
Dann gibt es noch eine Sache mit der Kompatibilität
und das betrifft die Tatsache,
dass aktuell der Kühler nur mit der 10er-Generation kompatibel ist.
Und da habe ich Intel auch schon mehrfach gesagt,
dass sie von dieser Politik quasi abweichen müssen.
Sie sagen natürlich,
die Software ist so gestaltet,
dass sie auf den Thermal Velocity Boost angewiesen ist,
aber ich sehe es eben so,
dass das Teil auch unabhängig wunderbar funktioniert.
Klar.
Keine Ahnung, ich habe halt auch Bock damit,
keine Ahnung,
einen 770K zu übertakten oder irgendwas älteres.
Du darfst ruhig AMD sagen.
Und dann sollte das auch unabhängig davon ja gut funktionieren,
wenn man jetzt keinen Thermal Velocity Boost hat.
Das darf er wahrscheinlich in dem Video nicht, aber...
Aber dann trotzdem schon, keine Ahnung,
was kann ich validieren,
was kann ich im Super P1M machen und solche Geschichten.
Deswegen hoffe ich,
dass Intel da die Meinung noch ändert.
Also ich bin im regen Austausch mit Intel,
habe auch schon viel Feedback gegeben zu der Software.
Auch die Tatsache,
dass das, was man im Cryo-Mode
beziehungsweise das,
was man in der Cryo-Software,
einstellt auch beim System Startup jedes Mal übernommen wird.
Weil aktuell ist es so,
man startet das System und dann muss ich erst mal auswählen,
mache ich Cryo-Mode oder Anreg-Lade.
Das ist natürlich doof,
aber das ist eine Software-Geschichte.
Das macht schon Sinn.
Aber wenn ich den Kühler eben im Alltag verbaue,
dann sollte auch der Cryo-Mode im Alltag immer gleich starten.
Und solche Geschichten,
da bin ich mit Intel noch dabei,
dass das,
wenn das Produkt und dieses Video dann eben auch öffentlich ist,
das wahrscheinlich in,
keine Ahnung,
Mitte November.
Jetzt ist aktuell für mich Mitte Oktober.
Genau.
Kurzer Nachtrag.
Es sind jetzt circa zwei Wochen vergangen,
viel mit Intel hin und her geschrieben
und Intel hat sich jetzt doch entschlossen,
auch ältere CPUs noch zu supporten.
Also zum Beispiel 8700K.
Ach, geht doch auf einmal.
Kaby Lake, Coffee Lake kommen noch mit dazu.
Das wird allerdings noch sechs bis acht Wochen nach Release dauern,
hat Intel gesagt.
Also es ist ungefähr vielleicht noch ein bisschen länger.
Ja, aber das ist ja noch sinnloser.
Dann kaufe ich mir so ein fettes Ding,
pulver nochmal 100 Watt für meine CPU raus,
um die noch ein bisschen mehr übertakten zu können.
Das ist irgendwie,
irgendwie nicht,
so die gute Investition.
Die Investition wird auch dann letztendlich implementiert werden,
dass die Software die Einstellungen vor dem Reboot behalten wird.
Das bedeutet,
ihr könnt dann einstellen,
keine Ahnung,
Kryo Mode,
was auch immer ihr möchtet machen
und dann behält die Software die Einstellungen bei.
Ihr könnt rebooten und es ist dann immer im Kryo Mode
und ihr müsst nicht bei jedem Start das Ganze neu einstellen.
Ihr könntet das einfach in irgendeinem Flash von dem Controller speichern,
was man zuletzt hatte.
Ich bedanke mich fürs Zuschauen.
Lasst mich sehr, sehr gerne wissen, was ihr davon haltet.
Wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder.
Bis dahin.
Ciao, ciao.
Exzellent,
aber ich also eigentlich mal gucken,
wie viel Abos hat.
Also dem gönne ich das wirklich.
Ja, der macht die Sache ja auch schon ewig
und ich glaube,
er hat auch ziemlich gestruggelt teilweise,
dass man das so.
Ja, die das das Hobby quasi da irgendwie zum Beruf zu machen,
aber dem gönne ich das echt.
Ja, es gibt ein paar,
es gibt ein paar Leute,
wo ich echt sage,
die könnten meinetwegen auch viel,
viel mehr Abos haben.
Ah, der Bauer auf Twitch,
dem,
dem Lost Aiming,
da hat der nur noch Lost,
dem gönne ich es auch voll.
Ja, gibt ein paar Leute,
hauptsächlich halt die,
die nicht so irgendwie Cringe Content machen,
wo ich mir denke,
das kann man sich doch nicht angucken.
Leider ist zumindest in YouTube Deutschland,
die, die so Content machen,
den ich mir nicht angucken würde,
mit am erfolgreichsten,
aber das ist halt meine Geschmackssache.
Ja, kenne ich nicht.
So, schauen wir uns denn jetzt mal an.
Windows 98,
Moment, das haben wir das,
haben wir das nicht schon gesehen?
Wie gut oder schlecht sind eigentlich Gaming-PCs von Lidl?
Xbox Series S Tierdawn.
Äh, what?
Was ist das?
Ich glaube nicht,
dass ich das aufmachen wollte.
Klingt nicht so spannend.
Die 10 besten Linux-Apps,
was haben wir?
Worst 7 Operating-Apps,
okay, das gucken wir jetzt.
Da stimme ich wahrscheinlich nicht zu.
Network Troubleshooting,
was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Sony CD.
Keine Rack-Server bei Host Unlimited.
Aha, das ist ja fast schon sehr laut,
wenn ich das hier zeige, oder?
Elon Musk will unser Gehirn aufrüsten.
Und ein bisschen Battlefield.
Komm, wir gucken jetzt mal hier die,
ähm, gucken wir jetzt.
7 Worst Operating-Systems.
Okay, zeigt mal her.
Okay, lass mal überlegen,
haben wir das Video nicht schon mal geguckt?
Okay, lass mal überlegen.
Das schlechteste Betriebssystem,
was ich je verwendet habe.
Also das,
womit ich am meisten Probleme
hatte im Nachhinein,
war glaube ich
echt Windows
98?
Das hatte ich halt
relativ lange,
es ging mir immer richtig aus.
Also Windows 98, so viele Nostalgie-Sachen man da hat,
aber, äh,
Windows 98 hat
echt extrem gesackt.
Was auch richtig schlecht war,
war Suse, das erste
Linux, was ich verwendet habe hier,
das war ein Suse, äh,
Suse Linux 4 oder so
war das noch.
Es kam noch auf CDs.
War noch so blaue CDs.
Das war
so beschissen,
dass man damals noch nicht mal,
ähm, sein DSL daheim
zum Laufen gebracht hat.
Lag zum Teil sicherlich daran,
dass ich damals noch relativ wenig Ahnung
von Linux hatte, aber, ähm,
es war einfach Müll.
Okay, gucken wir mal, was er dazu erzählt.
Okay, in History,
da kannst du jetzt ja auch zurückgehen und kannst sagen,
ja, irgendwelche uralte Computer
mit Bandlaufwerken oder so.
Aber das ist ja nicht Sinn und Zweck der Sache.
Sollte ja schon was sein, was die Leute kennen.
Achso, übrigens, eine Sache, die auch
mega beschissen gewesen sein muss für Entwickler,
war das Betriebssystem der Wii.
Weil es so
ein, äh, weil es so ein komisches
Nintendo-Konstrukt wieder war.
Mit, äh, teilweise im Flash
und teilweise auf den, äh,
CDs mit ausgeliefert. Ganz, ganz merkwürdiges
Konstrukt. Da haben ex-, da haben wir
sehr viele drüber geflamed.
Dass das unter aller Sau gewesen sein muss,
was sich Nintendo da ausgedacht hat.
So, starting off with number seven,
we have Windows ME.
Officially pronounced Windows ME.
This came out in the year 2000.
Windows ME kriegt so viel Hate ab,
das war auch nicht schlechter als Windows 98.
Das war, die ganze Windows, äh,
äh, DOS-Serie
war halt
instabile Kacke.
Aber es hat das gemacht,
was es machen sollte zum größten Teil.
Also,
ich weiß gar nicht, warum Windows
ME immer so gehatet wird.
Das ist halt der Abschluss von der,
von der DOS-Reihe.
Das stimmt.
Ich hab's benutzt.
Stimmt, Vista hab ich nie verwendet, Leute.
Chat.
Oh, 3D-Pinball. Beste.
Das hatte sogar,
ich weiß nicht, ob dieses 3D-Pinball,
irgendein Pinball hat einen Level-Editor
gehabt. Da hab ich da mal Stunden
irgendwelche Pinball-Dinger gebastelt.
Und eine Sache, die ich bis heute
nicht verstanden habe,
das gab's, glaub ich, seit Windows 98
oder so, wofür war diese
Briefcase-Funktion da?
Ich hab es nie verstanden,
wofür das da ist.
Bis heute nicht.
Ja.
So schlimm war das gar nicht.
Ja, genau.
Ja, nur mit dem Unterschied, dass 2000
gut war,
weil es diese MT-Linie war
und Windows ME war halt DOS,
das letzte DOS-Windows.
Auch wenn sie das verstecken wollten.
Stimmt.
Die haben mit Windows ME,
mit Windows ME gab's den Windows Movie Editor
als erstes.
Ja, und diese hässlichen
Media-Player-Themes.
Richtig schlecht.
Okay, da kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Das war vor meiner Zeit.
Da war ich zwei Jahre alt.
Okay.
einen DOS File Manager. Das war der einzige
brauchbare File Manager.
Jetzt ist es
Midnight Commander, ja. Damals war es
Norton Commander.
Sieht halt aus wie DOS, ne?
What the fuck?
Ja gut, das kannst du
jetzt da nicht, das kannst du
doch jetzt nicht da bringen. Ich meine,
das waren Zeiten, wo die Leute noch
Hex-Dinger
über einen 3D-Drucker,
äh, nicht über einen 3D-Drucker,
wo die Leute noch irgendwelche Hex-Nummern
über einen Drucker ausgedruckt haben, als grafisch
ausgedruckt, äh, naja.
Das war ja ein ganz dunkles Zeitalter.
Ja, in was sonst?
Das war 1960.
Also quasi
Cloud-Computing 1960-Style.
Ja.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja.
Es gibt heute noch immer Sachen, wo das so ist.
Zum Beispiel das Standard-ESP32-Filesystem, wenn man es so nennen mag, hat auch keine Ordner.
Hat auch nur Dateien.
Das hast du damals auch nicht gebraucht.
Damals musstest du erstmal ein Hochsicherheits-Dings da in ein Gebäude rein, dass du überhaupt
dran kommst.
...login to anyone else's session, but it was apparently polite to apparently log in
so that people could see you wanting to get on.
I don't exactly know how it worked, but there were no passwords.
And also that meant that anybody could edit anyone else's files in their other directories.
Ja, die hängen sich aus, das war 1960, die hatten da andere Probleme.
...system files and source code, so if someone was malicious, they could literally just go
in and just delete everything off, but I believe because it was at MIT and probably everyone
using it was faculty or something.
Das war irgendein Forschungsprojekt.
Okay, next.
...in everyone's best interest to behave in there.
So yeah, not exactly an operating system that I think would work out too well these days.
Alright, now on to number four, we have Java OS.
This was an operating system built in...
Iih!
Sowas gab's mal!
Es könnte ja kaum schlimmer kommen.
Na gut, heute ist Minecraft so eine Art Java OS.
...entirely or mostly on Java by Sun Microsystems.
...or mostly on Java by Sun Microsystems.
Jesus da bin ich alt!
...inarbescensure my
Gra...
... realization!
Java oder Java? Man wird es nie wissen.
Oder Hira oder Jira?
Sehen Java-Anwendungen nicht immer noch so aus? Ja, ohne Styles und so sieht es so aus.
Was verwendet man heute eigentlich? Swing ist doch out, oder? Swing ist doch überhaupt nicht mehr angesagt.
Like it said, pagers, very small, discreet, purpose-built devices.
It was actually licensed by several major companies, but apparently they never actually used it, even though they licensed it.
Also, from what I've read, because the operating system was written in Java as opposed to C, which was like most other operating systems,
people said that this operating system would have tended to run a lot slower than the other operating systems, so that probably didn't help.
Based on what I could find...
Es lief langsamer als andere Sachen. Das erinnert mich ja überhaupt nicht an Java.
Anwendung.
Really the only computer that ever did actually run on it was the Java Station.
Sowas gab's mal!
Oh je, das ist ja der Teufel in Person quasi hier.
Java Station.
Ach du große Kacke.
Weiter.
Computer, which was created by Sun Microsystems themselves.
And this thing was even so unpopular that I could really only find a few grainy screenshots.
From ancient documentation files.
But I would recommend, if you're interested in this Java Station, there's another YouTuber by the name of Cameron Gray,
who did a whole video about the Java Station.
He was able to get it to boot up.
So rather than, you know, steal his screenshots and stuff, I will direct you to go check out his video.
It's very cool.
He's able to boot it up and you can see the whole interface and stuff on his video.
So mutig bin ich heute nicht, dass ich das gucke.
That only lasted three years.
And it only ran on pretty much one computer that was officially built by Sun Microsystems.
And no one even...
Alright, on to number three.
You guys knew this one was going to be on the list.
It's Windows Vista.
Okay, bevor wir dazu...
Ich hatte wenig Kontakt mit Sun Hardware und Solaris und sowas.
Das einzige, was ich jemals so halb administrieren musste, war eine uralte Sun Firewall.
Und die sah wirklich echt antik aus.
Die sah ein bisschen...
Ne, ne, ne, so modern sah die noch nicht aus.
Das war weiß, dieses Gehäuse.
Old, old Sun Server.
Ja, ne, nicht ganz so schlimm.
So, und das Ding war da und es wusste keiner, was es macht.
Es war einfach nur da.
Ich weiß noch, das stand...
Wenn ich ins Rechenzentrum gekommen bin, ganz unten links in dem einen Rack-Verbund,
war das ganz unten links.
So eine Kiste war das.
So eine ähnliche Kiste hier.
Es wusste keiner, was sie macht.
Sie war einfach nur da.
Und es hat sich keiner getraut, sie auszuschalten.
Und irgendwann hat man das Rack mal abgeschaltet und ich glaube, danach ist das Ding nicht mehr gebootet
und man hat sie für immer ausgelassen und es ist nichts passiert.
Also so richtige uralte Leiche im Rechenzentrum war das.
2006.
Nun, ich muss bemerken, dass nach einigen Service-Packs die Vista okay aussah,
aber auf der anderen Seite...
Ja, Vista.
Vista.
Äh, Aero fand ich nicht schlecht, fand ich eigentlich ganz gut.
Es war sehr Hardware-intensiv.
Also, viele Leute, die vielleicht von ihrem aktuellen Computer zu Vista von XP upgraden,
würden bemerken, dass Vista viel schneller auf das äquivalente Hardware läuft.
Also dachten sie, Windows Vista ist einfach schlecht, aber wirklich war es wahrscheinlich nur ihr Computer.
Aber gleichzeitig war es nicht genau ihre Furcht,
weil man kinderlich erwartet,
einen bestimmten Niveau der Leistung zu erhöhen, wenn man es upgraden will.
Außerdem, weil viele Dinge auf der Rückseite wieder gemacht wurden,
gab es auch Kompatibilitätsprobleme, die auf Equipment-Grenzen gelegt wurden.
Also das Problem bei Windows Vista zum größten Teil war,
dass Microsoft dort einige neue Sachen eingebaut hat,
die heute Standard sind und gar nicht so schlecht waren.
Zum Beispiel den neuen Windows, äh, nicht Windows Manager, ähm, DWM,
diesen, ja, doch, der Windows Window Manager und 3D-beschleunigte Oberflächen und sowas.
Da war viele sinnvolle Sachen dabei.
Das Problem war, dass Microsoft bei Windows Vista einen Fehler gemacht hat,
den sie bei, also eine Sache nicht gemacht haben,
die sie bei alten Windows-Versionen immer hochgehalten haben,
nämlich, dass Sachen eigentlich so gut wie immer rückwärtskompatibel funktionieren.
Ich meine, du kannst nicht umsonst heute zum größten Teil,
na gut, vielleicht nicht DOS-Software,
aber du kannst Spiele von 1998 auf einem aktuellen, also theoretisch zumindest, ja, laufen lassen.
Mit ein paar kleinen Problemen.
Also, das haben die halt bei Windows Vista richtig verkackt.
Da kann ich mich noch erinnern, es gab, und ab Windows Vista gab es irgendwie so ein neues Grafikkartentreiber-Modell,
was dann auch nicht richtig unterstützt wurde.
Da haben sie es ziemlich verkackt.
Bei Windows 7 haben sie es dann halt gut gemacht.
... zu updaten die Fahrzeuge, die man downloaden kann.
Und manchmal waren sie langsam, oder nicht überhaupt.
Also, vielleicht dein Keyboard oder Maus, wenn es nicht geupdatet wurde,
könntest du es auch nicht nutzen.
Und appellierend, noch mehr zentrale Geräte,
die für Core-Komponenten, wie Nvidia für Grafikkarten, verwendet wurden,
obwohl sie die Fahrzeuge updaten konnten,
haben sie Träger und so verursacht,
also gab es einfach viele Probleme mit den Fahrzeugen.
Eine andere Sache, die die Leute nicht liebten, war das User-Account-Kontrollen.
Das war eine wirklich gute...
Oh ja, stimmt!
Stimmt, das kam ja damals mit Vista.
Man denkt im Kopf immer, das war Windows 7.
Nee, nee, das kam ja schon mit Vista.
Uack!
Und die Leute fanden es einfach sehr erstaunlich und intrusiv,
weil jedes Mal, wenn du etwas tust,
es würde aufgeploppt werden.
Aber jedem Scheiß ist es aufgeploppt.
Und vielleicht war es zu intrusiv,
weil auch jetzt, in den heutigen Tagen,
auf Windows 10, denke ich, es ist viel besser.
Ich habe sogar mein UAC auf Maximum auf Windows 10 gesetzt,
und ich glaube, das kommt viel weniger oft auf,
als es auf Windows Vista in den letzten Tagen war.
Und es gab einige Features, die ich wirklich liebte,
zum Beispiel die Gadgets-Pain.
Ich war ein bisschen traurig,
als das in späteren Versionen entfernt wurde.
Und nach ungefähr einem Jahr wurde Service Pack 1...
Und was wurde entfernt?
... und ein Jahr später Service Pack 2.
Aber bei dem Zeitpunkt war Windows 7 nur um die Kante,
und die Leute haben die Beta benutzt,
um zu sehen, wie toll es war.
Und weil Windows XP bereits so populär war,
haben viele Leute die Repetition gesehen.
Ja, wir haben damals die Windows XP-Beta installiert
und kamen uns wie die größten Hacker aller Zeiten vor.
Das muss dann irgendwie...
Frag mal, wann war denn das, so 2000 rum oder so vielleicht?
Ja.
Und jetzt, wo ich da gerade dran denke,
die Mutter von dem, also von den Freunden aus der Schule,
das war die erste Feministin, mit der ich jemals Kontakt hatte.
Ich wusste damals gar nicht, was Feministen sind,
oder Feministinnen.
Das war die Hardcore-Feministin,
die wurde von denen...
Das war so eine Mischung aus Feministin und so...
Also, die war halt ihrer Zeit voraus.
Heute könnte die damit Geld verdienen, ja?
Die war Feministin und...
Feministin und so öko in einem.
Also, heute wäre die garantiert Veganerin und Feministin,
aber damals war es halt so,
die wollten...
Also, der wollte nach der Schule immer mit zu mir,
zu meiner Oma essen, weil das Essen da gut geschmeckt hat.
Und ich kann auch...
Ich verstehe auch heute, warum.
Also, ich habe damals schon verstanden,
warum.
Weil ich war ab und zu mal auch nach der Schule mit bei ihm.
Und wenn die Mutter von ihm gekocht hat,
die hat dann sowas gemacht wie Vollkorn-Klöße mit Vanillen-Soße und sowas.
Alter!
Boah!
Vollkorn-Knödel!
Vollkorn-Knödel hat die gemacht, ey!
Stellt euch das mal vor!
Wie kann man sowas machen, Alter?
Oh!
Selfmade-Eis, sechs Monate Subscription, dankeschön.
Excellent!
Samuskulaiwa!
Wie sieht denn sowas...
Kennt ihr...
Kennt ihr diese...
Diese bayerischen Dinger, diese, diese...
Diese Hefe, Hefe-Klöße, das heißt in Bayern Hefe-Kloß.
Diese Dinger, so.
Sowas hat die gemacht, nur aus Vollkorn.
Sowas hat die gemacht aus Vollkorn.
Vollkorn-Kloß.
Kann ich mal richtig schreiben?
Klöße.
Ja, sowas hier!
Sowas hier hat die...
Alter, das war so eklig!
Grrr!
So, sowas hat die...
Ja, und man konnte das nur essen, man konnte das nur essen mit wirklich literweise Vanillensoße drüber.
Ja, die, die war echt nicht normal, sowas war heute nicht...
Ja, Wahnsinn.
Ja, an so ein Kram erinnert man sich dann.
Tja.
Alter.
Ist das heute was anderes? Aber auf Mobile
Smartphones ist Windows, ist ja vorbei.
Hinüber.
Weiß gar nicht, ob das noch supported wird.
Also offiziell gibt es das ja nicht mehr,
aber vielleicht irgendwelche Hersteller.
Keine Ahnung.
Das war, by the way, das war noch
vor dem aktuellen
Microsoft CEO.
Das waren die letzten
Zuckungen der Ballmer-Zeit bei Microsoft.
Und das war so eine typische
Ballmer-Aktion, so nach dem Motto, ich hab zwar keine
Ahnung, warum die alle Tablets
verwenden, aber die müssen
unsere Sachen auf ihrem Tablet verwenden.
...bekommen just a full screen start screen.
And while yes, this may have played out well
if you were using a touchpad device.
Ja, was keiner gemacht hat.
Ist Windows 8 eigentlich noch supported?
...which are now known as Universal Windows
Platform Apps. And these were a bit
confusing as well, because they would open in
full screen, but they had no way to
minimize or close out.
There was no close out or minimize button on these,
so people were really confused by them.
There was also the charms bar, which
had to be accessed by swiping from the right
or moving the cursor over, but it was
not really intuitive, there were no real
instructions on how to use anything, so if
someone came up to the computer and didn't
know how to access those things, they would
just not be able to access them.
Another really weird thing was that you
could get to the desktop...
Die haben ja auch, also was die Leute damals
halt übelst schockiert hat, ist, dass du
kein Startmenü hattest, dass wenn du
Windows-Taste gedrückt hast, dieses
komische Overlay aufgegangen ist.
...only by clicking on the desktop tile
on the start screen. And there was no way
to boot to the desktop by default.
And once you were there,
there was no start button, so it was not
exactly clear how to get back to the start screen.
You had to basically press the Windows
key on your keyboard, which is not
intuitive at all. I almost never use that
key anyway. Now eventually Microsoft did
release Windows 8.1 in 2013, which
improved a lot of the Windows interface
for keyboards and mouse. For example, it
brought back the start button, which
would open the start screen, so there
was still no start menu, but at least the
button was there. It also allowed you to
boot to the desktop by default, and also
they later added the closed...
...minimized buttons to Windows Store apps.
So obviously a lot of people found this
super confusing coming from previous
versions of Windows, though it wasn't
all necessarily bad. There were actually
some good additions, for example, to be fast
structured. Man muss sagen, so undurchdacht
war die Touch- und Tablet-Oberfläche gar
nicht, wenn man sie halt dann so
verwendet hat, wie man sie verwenden
sollte auf dem Gerät, wofür es gedacht
war. Das Problem war nur, dass es halt
komplett anders war, als die
vorangegangenen Windows-Versionen. Und
eine Sache, die Microsoft heute noch macht,
auch nach Ballmer, ist, den neuesten Scheiß
als das Ultimative verkaufen und so tun,
als wird jetzt alles so. Die haben dann
damals so getan, als wird jetzt alles so.
Und da haben die Leute gesagt, was? Wollt ihr uns verarschen?
Wie, wie? Es wird alles so. Es wird alles
Kachel, es wird alles... Das haben die ja auch
eine Weile probiert, bis sie dann
irgendwann festgestellt haben, das
benutzt echt keiner. Microsoft verkauft
die neuesten Dinger ja immer so, so nach
dem Motto, okay, das ist jetzt die
ultimative Entwicklung, die wir aus 20
Jahren Erfahrung gezogen haben und jetzt
wird alles so. Die Windows 10 Suche habe ich
übrigens aus, weil ich es gerade im Chat
sehe. Die Windows 10 Suche habe ich aus,
weil die bei mir einfach 15 Prozent
Hintergrundlast permanent verursacht und
irgendwie nicht fertig wird. Ich habe
eigentlich gedacht, wenn ich das mal drei
Tage laufen lasse, dann hat er, dann hat
er endlich sein Index aufgebaut und
hält die Klappe. Macht er aber nicht.
Ja.
Das stimmt. Ich habe Windows 7 auf...
Ich habe abge-created, ich habe abge-created
Windows XP zu Windows 7, Windows 7 zu 10.
Ich glaube, das war so die einzigeSirrelung. Ich habe es bekommen und habe es jetzt aufgeschaut. Und so, wie es auch 모르 ich bin ich hier, ich habe es auch gekostet. Also ich habe es auch gekostet, aber es hat sich nicht gelungen. Deshalb habe ich nicht vorgestellt. Ich habe es nicht erfüllt. Einfach nur das Internet-Telefon. Stimmt. Ist nicht gut. An den Moment habe ich einfach nicht so schnell aufgedacht. Was macht ihr denn da? Was macht ihr da?
upgrade passt in die meisten gemacht habe es gibt ich habe windows 8 es gibt und davor ja
gut davor habe ich habe ich die sachen doch schon mit 95 98 ich hatte sogar 2000 und dann
xp aber danach habe ich eigentlich noch xp 77 10 wisst da wisst da hatte ich auch so eine
media center pc und das lief überhaupt nicht in history we have lindows von 2001
lindows
of trying to develop it, the creators eventually scrapped the initial idea and focused on just
making an operating system that would make it very easy to install Linux applications
on it.
But there were actually some interesting features they did add to it, for example a so-called
click and run software distribution service, which was GUI based, which made it very easy
to install any number of Linux software packages.
Also ich war ja eher im ICQ Team, MSN und AOL habe ich nicht so verwendet, ich habe
hauptsächlich ICQ verwendet damals und später, ja, ICQ war damals schon ihrer Zeit voraus,
muss man sagen.
Die hatten damals schon quasi so eine Game Plattform, kennt auch jemand Sumo Volleyball?
ICQ Sumo, Sumo Volleyball, Alter Sumo Volleyball, das hat sogar Multiplayer, ja, Sumo Volleyball,
ah ja, ICQ war ein bisschen ihrer Zeit voraus, aber ich kann es mir bis heute nicht so richtig
erklären, warum ICQ so abgeschissen ist, irgendwann kam dann Skype und alle haben Skype
verwendet.
Die haben wahrscheinlich sich zu sehr drauf ausgeruht und den Anschluss verloren.
Dann wird Discord wohl auch abkacken, warum, warum, da würde mich jetzt mal interessieren,
verliert Discord den Anschluss, also insgesamt finde ich Discord eigentlich, wirst du jetzt
nicht, was ist in Discord, was, was mir da jetzt erstmal so fehlt, ah, warum?
Da kannst du in die Zukunft, ne, Moment, da kannst du in die Zukunft, da kannst du in die
Zukunft, ne, Moment.
Darum geht's ja nicht, ne.
Wenn du das jetzt so sagst, hört sich das ja erstmal so an, als vermisst du irgendwas
an Discord.
In der Zukunft kann alles irgendwie passieren mit ein bisschen Glück, Pech, was auch immer.
Kennst du einen Open Source PDF Editor?
Ne.
Es gibt ja Leute, die schwören halt immer noch auf Teamspeak 2.
ownership over the year so it is a legitimate operating system it just never really became
popular because of all the criticism and well it's just kind of a weird concept and there's
plenty of other way more popular distributions of linux such as ubuntu so it really just never
took off which is probably why you've never heard of it so let me know down in the comments if you
have an operating system that you think should have been number one or you think that should
have been on the list in the first place let me know down there if you guys want to keep watching
the next video i'd recommend is one i made recently talking about windows features that
you probably didn't know that you could disable so i'll put that link right there you can just
ja man könnte theoretisch windows komplett disablen wenn man sich das leisten könnte
heutzutage ja ich meine es gibt genug leute die quasi sagen sie kommen nur mit linux aus
aber bei mir ist es halt leider nicht der fall auch wenn ich es gerne würde
pepo happy sound stimmt basti du hast recht die mit mit handy und smartphone haben
mit handy und smartphone haben mit handy und smartphone haben mit handy und smartphone haben
mit handy und smartphone haben mit handy und smartphone haben ist richtig verschissen man
ist richtig verschissen man ist richtig verschissen man testest du eigentlich mal proton ich habe da
testest du eigentlich mal proton ich habe da
testest du eigentlich mal proton ich habe da jetzt nicht so großartiges verlangen dazu da
jetzt nicht so großartiges verlangen dazu da
jetzt nicht so großartiges verlangen dazu da bräuchte ich nämlich native linux ich habe
bräuchte ich nämlich native linux ich habe
bräuchte ich nämlich native linux ich habe nicht so das anwendungszweck für native
nicht so das anwendungszweck für native
nicht so das anwendungszweck für native linux macht alles was die jungs machen
linux macht alles was die jungs machen
linux macht alles was die jungs machen will meiner vm die vm hat vier kerne
16 g ram das fühlt sich an wie eine linux voll installation außer wenn man halt so sachen wie
hardware-accelerated sachen geschichten braucht was ich mir vor allem eigentlich nicht brauche
weil die sachen mache ich unter windows so was haben als nächstes hier genug oldschool zeug wie
gut schlecht sind eigentlich gaming pcs von lidl kann man später angucken ich brauche sie aber
gucken jetzt eine runde battlefield wir gucken jetzt ohne battlefield was gucken wir einen
battlefield 3 top place oder battlefield 4 top place tja chat 3 ok ich sehe schon keiner will
vier gucke beides vielleicht kommen wir beides ja und ist aber ganz schön lang den mache ich
immer ein bisschen leiser weil er erzählt jedes mal das gleiche dass konsole das ist so fett nee
das ist jetzt nicht konsole das pc aber das ist so fett was ist das 8 1024 mal 768 oder wie ist
es nicht spannend
wegsprayen lassen wieder jetzt hätte ich wieder erzähle ich wieder erzähle ich mir der ärger
gekriegt wenn ich das den clip bei mir auf youtube gezeigt hatte max warum promotest du gameplay wo
die leute nicht wiederbeleben das abo ist raus wie sie immer japanisch shotgun oder rauch
oder
oder wer gespräht
oder hat wiederbelebt jetzt darf ich das zeigen
raffel drei war schon wirklich der großzügig was hier boxen
angeht deswegen fühle ich mich in battlefield 3 immer wieder übelste
aiming gott und in anderen spielen träum ich nix und was auch in battlefield 3 geil war
waren die voice samples von den soldaten da gibt es ja diese eine woche irgendwie
irgendwie was erzählt i get fucked in the ass over here
das haben sie sich wahrscheinlich im späteren teil nicht mehr getraut so
samples rein zu machen da oben überleb ich nicht länger als
fünf sekunden moment haben wir uns das video nicht schon angeguckt ich bilde
mir ein wir haben den gleichen clip schon mal gesehen ich habe genau das
gleiche gesagt oder die sind sehr ähnlich
kam das raus 2000
es ist auch wieder nice wegsprengen 149 hätte ich eigentlich auch mal mehr
spielen sollen aber das ist eine waffe da muss er eben können für so preschen
exzellent bis jetzt nicht demnächst auch wenn dies an liege rauskommen
klub ist once again a knall street but this time it's gonna be a bit more
of a run and gun street starting off on top of the crane which is really
important to have this controlled by your team unless the server of course it
doesn't allow you to go up there it's a bit of a difficult position i suppose to
es ist übelst unfaire position
definitely control a large portion of the map and then jumping down you can get
a good understanding of where the enemy players are a really nice aggressive
infantry play
klick klick
klick der gegner ist wieder so extrem blind was ändert wenn dies an licht denn
das ändert gar nichts das ist quasi ein neues game wenn das so willst also die
haben battlefield 3 genommen und haben irgendwie mod tools dafür erstellt und
hast du nicht gesehen
der typ mit webcam richtig richtig professioneller professioneller
battlefield 3 streamer hier mit web cam mit webcam und irgendwie fragwürdig im
green screen
Smokes a lot in BF3 and I do see a lot
of players missing out on this opportunity.
You run Smokes, it gives you the chance
to push on a lot of areas,
especially on Metro, where you can get
camped in and get really stuck down
if you don't try and play more aggressive.
He always encourages his team to
play aggressive and he often leads the line in doing
so. A nice little clip though
and a nice little defib there as well.
Beep!
Got you, boss!
Defib!
Das ist es!
Wo kommen die Gegner
alle her? Alter, wie blind kann man
sein? Ist er irgendwie
unsichtbar oder so?
What the fuck?
Cleaned.
This episode of the Battlefield Top Plays
is sponsored by Instant Gaming.
As you know, they've been supporting the channel for quite some time.
Warum gibt es überhaupt noch Noobs in Battlefield 3?
...have them on board, especially
during these difficult periods.
If you're looking for some cheap games, whether it's
for...
...as all three of these will be sent in
from T4.
Ich glaube, da spielt noch Metro
Oli hier, der Typ.
...on the right and the left
and you're just gonna see how many he can take down.
...like, fuck, he's getting free.
Brrrrrrrr!
Ah, ich dachte, jetzt kommt G18
raus und er schreddert auch mal das ganze Gegner-Team.
Alter!
Oh, die sind so blind!
So blind!
Alter, und das hat ihn auch keiner gespottet.
Ah!
Das tut weh!
Ah, das tut weh!
Monarch-S-Gegner!
Go, fucking, go!
It was an awesome push, I have to say that.
Excellent push!
Salami!
Nochmal!
Normalerweise wirst du immer schon umgesprayt,
bevor du aufstehen kannst.
Bam, bam, bam!
Ich glaube, er spielt echt...
Auuuuh, da sitzen sie!
Lull, und es checkt keine Sau!
Nice.
Es checkt keine Sau.
Ist der Wahnsinn, ey!
Der Typ steht einfach links neben der Tür
und bewegt sich nicht.
Bam!
Oh, so mein Knife-Team hat hier...
...nice.
Ein bisschen ein anderes Klick hier heute von Hypertech.
Wir sehen nicht oft Damovan-Peak-Klips in dieser Position.
Die Verteidiger laufen über den Berg,
er versucht, sich an dieser Strecke zu halten.
Die Enemies passen ihn,
es kann wirklich sehr lukrativ sein,
aggressiv zu spielen als Verteidiger,
besonders wenn die Verteidiger vielleicht nicht so viel drücken, wie sie sollten.
Sie könnten alle auf einer Seite des Maps drücken,
viel Smoken und runtergehen,
ein paar Beacon runterlegen und auf das Ziel gehen.
Sie wissen es nicht, und er bekommt da ein paar Töne.
Ah, Alter, die kriegen wir wieder auf den Sack.
Äh, ist das Nosha?
Ja, das ist Nosha, Rush.
Das Ding macht...
Du siehst da ja halt überhaupt nichts, wenn du mit dieser Minigun schießt.
Wow!
Ah, die haben auch einen Repair-Mensch dabei.
Wären da ein paar Leute,
ein paar Engies mit, äh,
mit easy. Guck mal, da ist sogar die Luftabwehr. Die Luftabwehr schießt nicht auf die. Okay,
na dann will man es nicht besser. Oh, das ist aber echt satisfying to watch. Oh,
der Transport-Heli war OP, weil das so viel aushält. Ja, ich glaube, der hält ja drei
Raketen aus oder so. Ah, erstmal schön oldschool 4 zu 3 Auflösung. Wahrscheinlich spielt
er noch auf einem 17 Zoll CRT.
Also die Auflösung und 4 zu 3, das erinnert mich schon hart an alle alten Spiele, die
man in, was weiß ich, 1280 mal 1024 oder so gespielt hat. Ja, das ist ja noch nicht
mal 4 zu 3 Stretch, das ist einfach nur 4 zu 3.
In your face. Oben über ihm steht er. Ey, ich wäre jetzt schon längst weggesniped
von irgendeinem Typ, der auf dem Kran steht oder so. Alter, die ganzen Schneiber-Dudes,
die will ja nichts kapieren. Sie sind komplett lost. Na, Stretched wird nicht mit aufgenommen,
das ist richtig. Stretched ist ja eine Sache, die im Monitor passiert und nicht, die man
im Spiel merkt. Vielleicht spielt er wirklich Stretched, ja, das kann gut sein.
Stretched für mehr 11-Head-Headshots. Oh, RIP.
Also es mag durchaus sein, dass man Spiele mit Stretch-Settings hat, aber wenn du heutzutage
auf dem 16 zu 9 Monitor spielst, stellst du das auf 4 zu 3 und dann sagst du deinem Monitor,
du willst das quasi 4 zu 3 stretchen auf 16 zu 9, das ist was, wovon das Spiel nichts
mitbekommt.
Das ist der extrem fiese Position, vor allem, wenn du Support pisst und es noch nachfüllen
kannst.
Ja, kannst du dann endlich viel C4 legen.
Oh, oh, oh, jetzt hat er es.
Jetzt hat er es gegen das Fenster geschmissen.
Huge Shotgun.
Shotgun mit A-C-O-G sieht man auch nicht so oft.
Zum Glück ist er so blind.
Da drin ist er aber auch dunkel, du kannst mal Leute übersehen.
Sagen wir mal so, das Ultra-High-Skill-Gameplay ist es jetzt vielleicht nicht, aber er macht
übelst viele Kills.
Normalerweise könnte der gegnerische LRW jetzt mal da oben reinrotzen und ihn killen,
was er auch versucht.
Aber er hat es nicht gebacken gekriegt.
Übrigens, das wäre eine Sache, die man im Battlefield auch einbauen könnte.
Ihr kennt ja das aus Warzone, wenn du einen killst, wo du dann kurz das Mikrofon aufschalt
und immer die Leute rumschreien hörst.
Am besten sind es, wenn es irgendwelche Franzosen sind oder so.
Pogurks.
Das wäre in Battlefield teilweise auch witzig.
Wenn du da irgendwie 10 Leute wegsprähst und du hörst dann auf einmal alle, was die
in dem Mikrofon schreien.
Ich muss sagen, der hat einen Kap, oder zumindest einen Arm, diese zwei M-Comps.
Er verteidigt, aber von vorne.
Und diese Spieler werden niemals von da hinten einen Kap haben, also macht er ihnen wahrscheinlich
einen Vorteil.
Er schafft, wie gesagt, 19 Kills insgesamt.
Er läuft einfach nur rum, auf der Rückseite des Mapps, suchend für Waffen, die sich
aufnehmen.
Die sind so gut.
Bam.
Oh, voll in die Fresse.
Das war echt krass.
Das war voll in die Fresse, ey.
Das war ja mal eines der heftigsten Shotgun-Headshots ever.
Guck mal hier.
Wie der...
Alter!
Also der ist ja wirklich...
Der hat die komplette Ladung ins Gesicht gekriegt, ey.
Bam!
Alter!
I'm so confused.
Der wurde danach wieder richtig geflamed.
Ja, ja, ich weiß, dass man spulen kann mit Punkt und Komma.
Ich...
Ich mach so irgendwie nie.
Frag mich nicht, warum.
Ha!
Da liegt der Schneiber-Mensch.
Was auch immer er da macht.
Wie der sich freut.
I gotta keep my points going.
Don't fall off.
This is a horrible job.
So, that shotgun is pretty OPA.
Yeah, but...
I gotta keep my points going.
Don't fall off.
This is a horrible job.
I gotta keep my points going.
Don't fall off.
This is a horrible decision.
Oh, Pointstreak vorbei.
And finally, today a clip from Rari.
You saw them at the start of the episode.
Now we're gonna see them at the end.
A nice one on Grand Bazaar.
Und ich meine, andere Map.
This very difficult choke point whenever I play Grand Bazaar as an attacker and...
Das einzige, was man hier gut machen kann, ist...
Was?
Battlefield 3-Tipps in 2020, lull.
Das einzige, was man hier gut machen kann...
Now we're gonna see them at the end.
Was?
Und ich meine, dass es am Anfang mal halbwegs funktioniert.
Ah Fuck, man siehts gar nicht.
Man kann hier oben, dagegen schießen und dann fällt der ganze Bau...
der ganze Schutt auf die Gegner und killt ein paar.
Also, das kann man ein-, zweimal machen, bis es da oben nichts mehr gibt und hat dann
die Chance mal durchzupuschen, aber ansonsten ist das wirklich saumäßig schwierig hier
durchzukommen.
Through this very difficult choke point whenever I play Grand Bazaar as an attacker and you
just get in this situation where the enemies have kind of bunkered down, it can just be
so difficult to push.
und das erfasst jetzt ja besser spielt als nie oder m 16 m 16 mit der m 16 kann
dass jeder wobei da eben die schon ganz gut da muss ja der hat m 16 geübt oder wenn sie
weggesprayt wieder alter richtig in your face die m 16 war halt nicht nur übelst gut was damage
angeht schussgeschwindigkeit time to kill was denn was denn sonst noch so alles mögliche dass
die war auch noch easy zu kontrollieren du musstest einfach nur ein bisschen runter ziehen
so hier sieht runter bis immer genau drauf geblieben warum habe ich eigentlich nie so
blinde gegner das ist das was man sich immer fragt wenn man so gameplay sieht okay was kommt
man jetzt an keine rex server bar haus was auch immer ich weiß nicht warum ich das aufgemacht habe
ehrlich gesagt vielleicht kann ich mich auch die wollen es aber wissen stimmt warum haben
die warum haben die warum haben die nur
warum haben die nur gehäuse nur tower wahrscheinlich weil es billiger ist rex
server koste halt mehr ist halt so rex gehäuse generell rex sachen sind halt so business
enterprise rechenzentrum sachen die sind halt teurer der gute rechenzentrum sound
zettel
wer macht denn so was wer hätte da windows installiert warum warum macht man das herunter
verboten das heißt ich muss einmal rumlaufen einmal den shutdown knopf am server drücken
damit herunter fährt der moment begleitet da wer vor allem wer gibt sich so was wir hatten
gerade glück ich dachte gerade echt jetzt dauert es noch mal irgendwie fünf wochen bis er seine
updates installiert hat okay könnte ich eigentlich eine bewegung machen ich weiß nicht wie das ist
ich weiß nicht wie das ist ich weiß nicht wie das ist ich weiß nicht wie das ist ich weiß nicht wie das ist ich weiß nicht wie das ist
ich weiß nicht wie das ist ich weiß nicht wie das ist ich weiß nicht wie das ist ich weiß nicht wie das ist
ich weiß nicht wie das ist ich weiß nicht wie das ist ich weiß nicht wie das ist
steht mir das zu da werde ich dann verklagt ich bin nämlich der meinung
direkt abmahnung rausgeschickt
windows nicht ins rechenzentrum
ja da hat er recht
seh ich auch so
hier wärs es eigentlich so wenn wir noch nen raid controller verbauen müssen
da hat er recht true true chat true 0w
so nen großen nachteil gibt es jetzt hier eigentlich nicht beim ssc tausch fand ich den nachteil schon größer gegenüber nem tower server weil man da ja dann
quasi einfach nur vorne hotswap hopp fertig getauscht hier musste man den ja jetzt noch rausnehmen hier wie man sieht auch wieder ein schöner server zwei cpus
ah yes ein schöner server zwei zwei tower kühler drinne okay
naja das ist halt keine wirkliche wie soll man sagen so business enterprise hardware was sie da haben aber dafür geht die natürlich geht die warum sollte normale
hardware nicht funktionieren und ist wahrscheinlich schlicht ergreifend viel günstiger
kunden jetzt gleich seine zusatz festplatten ziemlich sportlich mit dem
kabelbinder hier gemacht ich mach das erstmal ab der kunde hat hier noch daten
drauf gehabt er hat uns gesagt hey das könnt ihr überschreiben braucht er nicht
mehr hat er gesichert ich hab auch das würde ich mir immer das
würde ich mir immer nur schriftlich geben lassen
die kunde kriegt nicht zwei terabyte verbaut also zwei terabyte festplatten
er kriegt vier terabyte festplatten verbaut und das hier müsste eigentlich auch
ein
vier terabyte sein ja vier terabyte so dann bauen wir die noch mal ein so ein
bisschen im prinzip ist im prinzip ist es halt ein ganz stinknormaler tower mit
mit zeug drauf aber es ist wahrscheinlich billiger
einbauraum aber das liegt daran dass wir halt hochwertige gehäuse von super
micro verwenden für die hochwertigen server es gibt halt auch hochwertige
server tower gehäuse und das ist eins davon das stimmt wie man merkt das geht
eigentlich auch aber kriegst wahrscheinlich könnte mir vorstellen dass
du sogar mehr
sachen in so einem schrank rein kriegst als wenn du da rex hinstellen muss man
braucht keine rex du kannst einfach hier so ein bisschen besseres ikea-regal für
nehmen wenn man einfach günstig sein will ist das sicherlich nicht verkehrt
meistens so von unten nach oben und großartige nachteile hast ja dadurch
nicht letztendlich mich als kunde interessiert ja auch nur mal zweitrangig
wenn ich sowas kaufe ob das jetzt in einem 19 zoll rack gehäuse steckt oder
in das ist mir doch scheißegal solange der kram funktioniert das schon mal gut
valuator super neuen rede objectives haben wir malimatmaumening für das
oder chat wird ihr sagen nein ich miete mir den nur an einzelne zoll rex hängt
warum wer dafür das günstig ist schnell ist und funktioniert der einbahn am
besten ja müssen wir hier sein jetzt kommen die leute die sich
beschweren wie gandhi stadt digital haft ist in elf jahren ist wirklich gar
nicht so schlimm bis jetzt haben an die staaten natur kaputt gegangen an die
antistatischer natur ja stimmt wo hat er dann sein big brain
antistatik
ja ich habe schon ich habe schon gerätselt wo das ist winkor ich habe gedacht vielleicht in der kleierstraße
da sind ja viele rechenzentren also bei interaction wird es nicht sein es zu teuer
Der ist auch verbaut keine ahnung wo der ist
wunderbar ich habe schon ein bisschen gerätselt jetzt geht der spaß los der kunde hat hier oben auch noch zwei sscs
ich sehe 860
ein terabyte zweimal ein terabyte sscs sind hier oben auch noch verbaut jetzt müssen wir mal gucken wie wir das mit dem strom machen
single power supply und sata haben auch nicht viel im rz zu tun es kommt immer drauf an also wenn das was halt eben
viel viel günstiger ist
und die da schnell austauschen warum nicht ja man muss nur wissen auf was man sich einlässt das ist ja immer das wichtige
also wenn ich jetzt die auswahl hätte zwischen dem oder was was doppelt so viel kostet nämlich lieber das
die machen es wahrscheinlich mit mit günstig
dass wir übrigens eins unserer hardware lager wo wir so die gängigsten teile die wir immer mal ok sehr gut dass sie uns das hardware lager zeigen
Ohne das hardware lager zu zeigen exzellent
festplatten teil haben wir auch gerade drüben
rechenzentrum weil die haben noch ein viel größer keinen fall
können wir das vielleicht noch mal einblenden bin ich seid mir nicht böse
und deswegen lassen uns das auch alle zeit der welt weil der kunde gesagt hat ihm eilt das nicht was macht er denn da
erst mal sata kabel durchschneiden wir wahrscheinlich kabelbinder
aber gleich schon dass wir hier bestimmt
noch adapter kabel brauchen könnten um von vier pol
zwölf volt auf
bot auf eine dieser karte
der entscheidet jetzt wirklich durch kabels durch
bekommen ja was haben wir denn 1 2
Noch mal drüber laufen
okay viel passiert da glaube ich jetzt nicht oder zwar
bots
dauert ein bisschen länger als bei der sport
ist die bilder bis die booten ihr da genau da wir haben jetzt mal so ein bisschen wir haben jetzt mal 10 tagen das ist so ein bisschen lang, bis die booten hier, das muss man jetzt mal ein bisschen länger bringen, wir müssen uns aussehn, man darf noch kurz auf ein bisschen.
Bis sie booten, ja das stimmt.
Die machen ja auch zig Geschichten beim Start.
Von Hardwarechecks bis sonst was.
Das sind irgendwelche Raid-Geschichten.
Okay, das ist nicht so spannend.
Was haben sie da eigentlich hinten dran?
Ist das irgendein Remote-Management-System oder was ist das?
Ich meine, das geht rein.
Irgendein KVM-Gedöns.
Ich meine, das geht rein in...
Was ist denn das? USB?
Ich erkenne das jetzt nicht richtig.
Ne, PS2 ist das.
PS2?
Was geht an PS2 dran?
Was? Net-Resetter.
Habe ich noch nie gehört. Zeigt mal her.
Der Telejet-Web-Resetter.
Was es nicht... Ja, das ist das.
Was es nicht alles gibt...
Der Telejet-Web-Resetter, inklusive professioneller Beratung.
Ah ja.
Und was... Das ist doch im Prinzip...
Drückt das für ein Control-Alt-Entfernen oder was macht das?
Es ist PS2.
Ah, das drückt Control-Alt-Entfernen.
Exzellent.
Gut, das ist bestimmt billiger als eine richtige KVM-Lösung.
Nice.
So.
Der Kunde meinte, mach das ruhig so.
Kein...
Also Kunden meinen in der Regel viel, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Ups.
Ja, ja. Mikrofon gehen wir aus meinem Hemd raus.
Richtiges Ghetto-Setup.
Ja, schon, ne?
Guckt euch das mal an.
Das würde ich jetzt nicht unbedingt im rechten Zentrum erwarten.
Das ist wirklich richtiges Ghetto-Setup.
Aber es ist wahrscheinlich billig.
So, ich muss jetzt mal gucken, was der Kram bei denen kostet.
Also, wie heißen die?
Host Unlimited.
Was kostet denn da sowas?
Kostet da irgendwie...
Da ist ja der Dude schon wieder.
Gehört dem das, oder wie?
Ähm, so.
Also, was gibt's denn da?
H00.
Ne, H.
Ist das H unendlich?
Oder was soll das sein?
Who.
Der Who-Server.
Who wie Server LXC.
Äh.
Okay, das ist irgendein Container-Ding.
Irgendein Shared-Container-Ding.
Shared-Container.
Kein Wunder, dass das nur Linux ist.
Geht ja nicht anders.
Okay, also eine Sache, die mir hier...
Das ist, dass das alles so bis zu ist.
Ich meine, das ist klar, dass das ein geshareder ist, aber das ist jetzt ein bisschen vage, ja.
Ich meine, dann bei dieser 1&1-Kiste, da steht zumindest dran, was ich bekomme, ja.
Das ist ja auch absolut Dumping-Preise hier, bei diesem einen Ding da von 1&1 für 1 Euro im Monat.
Aber, da steht zumindest dran...
Jetzt habe ich mir eine Testweise mal gekauft.
Äh, hier.
Zu den Tarifen 1 Euro im Monat.
1 Euro im Monat.
Da steht zumindest dran, du kriegst...
Eine virtuelle CPU, je nachdem, was da drin ist.
Du kriegst 512 MB RAM, 10 GB SSD und ich glaube ein bisschen Traffic kriegst du auch.
Das andere ist aber schon echt vage.
Und dafür ist es gar nicht mal so billig.
Klick mal auf das Angebot bei HU.
Äh, das da?
Was?
30?
3 Euro Aufladen, 3 Euro gratis?
Zu den Paketen, okay.
Ah, okay.
Ah, jetzt, jetzt.
Jetzt verstehe ich es.
Okay, also.
Moment, ich denke, es geht ab 2 Euro los.
Warum geht es nicht ab 2 Euro los?
Eben haben die gesagt, es geht ab 2 Euro los.
Guck hier.
Hier steht noch, es geht ab 2,99 Euro los.
Und hier geht es ab 4,99 Euro los.
Was ist, was ist da los?
She baited?
Ähm.
So, also 2 Cores, 4 GB RAM, das ist schon mal ein bisschen mehr, als beim anderen.
Ach hier Laufzeit.
Nee.
Ich mache doch nicht, ich mache doch nicht zwei Jahre.
Laufzeit.
Also so wirklich lohnen tut sich auch nicht.
Ich meine, wenn ich was mit wirklich Wumms brauche, also was mit wirklich Power, dann brauche ich diese Power meistens nicht dauerhaft, sondern nur ab und zu.
Dann gehe ich Hetzner Cloud, Digital Ocean, wo auch immer hin.
Miete mir eine ultra fette Kiste mit, frag mich nicht, 128 GB RAM, 96 Kern, sonst war 2 TB SSD, mache da mal eine Berechnung, 4-5 Stunden, beispielsweise OpenStreetMaps, Zeug konvertieren.
3 Stunden bin ich fertig, habe 2,50 bezahlt.
Eben an den Monat für 650 Euro kosten, aber ich brauche es ja meistens nicht lang.
So, ähm.
Ansonsten kann ich mir auch, wenn ich dann nicht so einen großen Anspruch habe, dann reicht auch diese 1&1 Kiste.
Oder irgendeine Hetzner Kiste, die sogar noch günstiger ist, ne.
Du kannst ja bei Hetzner, guck dir das mal an.
Was ist hier?
Prices.
Pricing.
Eine Runde Kirby.
Ja, ja.
Prices, hier.
Ja.
Dann reicht mir auch so ein Teil.
Oder eben den bei 1&1, wenn du ein Jahr dich binden willst für 1 Euro im Monat.
Ich habe mir den ja ehrlich gesagt bei 1&1 nur gekauft, weil ich mal ausprobieren wollte.
Wie gut das so kleines...
Klappt und ich muss sagen, bis jetzt kann ich mich nicht beschweren.
Ja, und du bist hier ja auch noch...
Also.
Und der größte, der große Vorteil dabei ist, dass der Kram eben minütlich quasi abgerechnet wird.
Hier steht zwar pro Stunde, also sprich, du kannst, mal angenommen du willst irgendwie sowas hier in der Richtung machen.
Und du sagst, hey, ich brauche mal was Fettes.
16 CPU-Kerne, 32, geh ran.
Dann mietest du dir den und schmeißt ihn nach 2 Stunden weg und hast dann irgendwie...
2 Cent?
Ne.
20 Cent bezahlt oder so.
So.
Und wenn man mal bei den...
Bei der Server-Auktion guckt, dann geht das Ganze ja noch ein bisschen billiger.
Was es da gerade so gibt.
Was haben wir denn da so Schönes?
Guck mal, da gibt es für...
Was ist da gerade der günstigste?
Oh.
Top aktuelle Server-Hardware.
Exzellent.
Das ist ja antik, Alter.
Das ist ja eine CPU von 2003 oder so.
Okay, 2008.
Ich habe mich ein bisschen vertan, aber es ist richtig Oldschool-CPU.
Aber sowas hier geht doch.
Guck mal, da kriegst du für 30 Euro im Monat...
Kriegst du...
Einen i7.
Was ist das für einer?
Quadcore?
Dualcore?
Oh, das ist doch okay.
Da kriegst du einen Quadcore.
16G ran.
3TB Platten.
Für 30, das ist glaube ich auch ganz okay.
Wenn man denn das braucht, ja.
Ich finde das...
Ich finde diese Cloud...
Ich finde dieses Cloud-Abrechnungsmodell ehrlich gesagt am besten.
Wäre das eben nicht noch billiger?
Hat das nicht...
Kostet das normalerweise nicht 2,89?
Hä?
Das kostet 2,89?
Ich weiß, dass das 2,89...
Warum ist das jetzt teurer?
Was ist das?
Oh, guys.
Warte mal.
Easy.
Hä?
Debate?
Falsche Mehrwertsteuer?
Warum?
Ah!
Warum denkt der denn jetzt, dass ich aus Italien komme?
Jetzt stimmt's wieder.
Excellent.
2,89.
Alles klar.
Ich dachte schon, es ist...
Die wollen einen quasi verarschen.
So...
Alles klar.
So, was kommt uns als nächstes an hier?
Wie gut oder schlecht sind eigentlich Gaming-PCs von Lidl?
Äh, ich glaube, das müssen wir uns noch nicht angucken.
Das ist wieder so ein Video...
Das ist wieder so ein Video, wo er 8 Minuten nichts zum Thema sagt, glaube ich.
Xbox Series X Teardown.
Das gucken wir uns jetzt mal an.
Was ist da drin?
Aber ich spule bis hier vorne.
Sag ich euch gleich.
Okay, so this is the Xbox Series X.
Ich spule ein bisschen vor, worauf er aufmacht.
Also, was haben wir für Anschlüsse?
Netzwerk.
Was ist das?
USB 2.
Sehe ich das richtig?
Haben die da eine USB 2 dran?
Superspeed USB.
Das ist USB 2.
Das konnte sich Microsoft nicht leisten, da USB 3 dran zu machen.
Das geht nicht.
HDMI.
Storage Expansion.
Was kommt denn da rein?
Bestimmt keine SD-Karte.
Home.
Gut.
Next.
And I think it's definitely...
Guck mal, die haben sogar einen X in der Xbox drin.
Paints Champ.
Superspeed ist 3.
Siehst du mal, wie gut ich bei USB-Standards durchblicke.
So.
Aha.
Ich sehe, dass ich nichts sehe.
Passende Musik dazu.
So, Kühler?
Komm, zeig doch, was drin ist.
Massive Kühler.
Also richtig fetter Klotz-Kühler.
3x USB 3.1 Gen 1.
Exzellent.
Aber USB 3.1 Gen 1 ist die falsche Bezeichnung.
Das darf nicht mehr so heißen, sagt das USB-Forum.
Laut dem USB-Forum ist das USB 3.2 Gen 1.
Oder vielleicht ist es jetzt der USB 4 Gen 1.
Ne, USB 4 darf es sich ja nicht nennen.
USB 4 darf es sich ja nicht nennen.
Um sich USB 4 nennen zu dürfen, muss man mindestens USB 3.2 Gen 2x2 sein.
Das ist jetzt kein Witz, das ist echt so.
So, zeig mal her, was ist drin?
Oh.
Gut, letztendlich wird das wahrscheinlich die AMD-CPU sein, oder?
Series X ist die langsamere.
Sind die unterschiedlich schnell?
Ich dachte nur, die sind unterschiedlich ausgestattet mit Laufwerken und sowas.
Aber seht ihr mal, wie gut ich mich damit beschäftigt habe.
Ja gut.
Leute, da könnt ihr davon ausgehen, dass die ersten sich schon an die Debug-Ports dran gelötet haben.
Das ist das erste, was passiert.
Bei manchen Leuten, das ist das erste, die kaufen sich so eine Konsole,
und dann wird erstmal irgendein Debug-Ding dran gelötet und geguckt, was kommt denn da raus.
Wo ist denn eigentlich die CPU?
Und das ist nicht die CPU, ne, das sieht auch wirklich nicht aus wie die CPU.
Wo ist die CPU?
Bestimmt unterseite oder so.
Da oben vielleicht, drunter, ja?
Debug?
HDI.
Ach, hier drunter.
Ah, ne, das haben wir jetzt nicht abgemacht, okay.
Doch, doch, jetzt hier.
Easy.
Jetzt.
Ja.
Das ist die SSD, ha?
M2 SSD.
Da sieht man mal wieder, dass aktuelle Konsolen einfach mehr oder weniger kompakte PCs sind.
Ja, so spannend finde ich es ehrlich gesagt jetzt nicht, ne.
Ist halt mehr oder weniger PC-Hardware.
Auch wenn sie da immer was anderes erzählen, dass das jetzt die most performanteste...
...bestes und innovativste Konsole aller Zeiten ist und noch nie dagewesene, äh, bahnbrechende, tolle, geile Sachen bietet.
Letztendlich ist es mehr oder weniger.
Bisschen auch ein paar kleine Ausnahmen, so fast nur nach 15 PC genügt es.
Ich meine, die Zeiten sind vorbei, dass das...
...irgendwelche obskuren Power-PC-CPUs waren oder...
...irgendwelche Cell-Cores und sonst was.
Da war die 360 und die PS3.
Das war die letzte Konsolengeneration, wo die Hardware wirklich irgendwie ausgefallener war.
Und was ich immer noch witzig finde bis heute, dass die CPU von der Xbox 360 und der PS3 von den gleichen Leuten bei IBM entwickelt wurden.
Die eigentlich offiziell voneinander nichts wissen durften.
Kann man Windows Linux auf einer Konsolengeneration...
...installieren, ähm, kommt auf den Herstellersupport an, können, also rein von der Hardware dürfte das nicht so das Problem sein, äh, sondern nur eher, dass die Hersteller sich da keine Custom-Software drauf ausführen lassen, die nicht signiert ist.
Also, theoretisch bestimmt, praktisch eher nicht.
Auf der PS3, oder was, die PS4, da gab es irgendwie Yellow-Dock-Linux.
Wie hieß das, glaube ich?
Aber, letztendlich so wirklich...
...was gebracht hat das jetzt ja auch nicht.
Zumal du da ja auch keine Zugriff auf die Grafikeinheiten und sowas hattest.
Du konntest im Prinzip, du konntest quasi mit Linux und dann auf der PS3 nicht mal Super-Tux-Card-Ruckel freispielen.
Also, ja.
Nee, das ist mir zu advanced jetzt, das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an.
iPhone X Durability Test.
Okay, zeigt mal her, was hält das iPhone X aus?
Excellent.
Heute werden wir einen Durability Test machen.
Das iPhone 12 Pro und seine Ceramik-Schilde, die den Frontschutz betrifft.
Ey, ist aber anpacking.
Nein, habe ich nicht, Notheist, ehrlich gesagt.
Weil...
Wobei doch jetzt, woraus sagt, ich habe das...
Jetzt, jetzt merke ich es, die Box ist kleiner, die ist nicht so hoch.
Aber ich kaufe mir nicht so oft irgendwelche iPhones.
Um ehrlich zu sein, ich habe zwar seit Jahren iPhones, aber ich habe mir noch nie ein iPhone gekauft.
Hört mir gerade so auf.
Dann die HDMI auf ihren Laptops.
Und jetzt ist das Charging-Brick selbst, das ist weg.
Es ist immer aufregend, zu finden, was als nächstes verschwindet.
Apple hält dich definitiv auf den Beinen.
Ehrlich gesagt, ist es wahrscheinlich eine gute Sache.
Sein 5-Watt-Inbox-Charger war der sloweste Charger eines Telefons, der jemals war.
Und jetzt gibt es keinen Grund, nicht zu verbessern, den schnelleren Charger, Anker Nano,
der weniger kostet, während er noch drei Mal schneller ist.
Na gut, dass was billiger ist und besser funktioniert,
beziehungsweise technisch besser funktioniert, was sowas wie Lade,
das ist bei Apple ja fast schon normal.
Aber Apple, die Sachen, die kosten immer ultra viel.
Die offiziellen Teile und es gibt andere Sachen, die funktionieren genauso gut.
All while still keeping the same size as the old brick.
Thanks to Anker for sponsoring this video.
Now iPhone users will get to experience the fast charging that Androids have had for years.
I'll leave a link down in the video description that will give you a 10% discount.
Anker ist ja auch irgendwelche China-Kram.
Cause you know, if Apple isn't gonna hook you up, Anker for sure will.
Now it's time for the durability test.
Let's get started.
Weißt du, erst so leise und entspannungsmäßig reden und dann erstmal so ein richtig übelst lautes Intro.
Ah, guck mal, hier hat er Stifte mit verschiedenen harten Spitzen, würde ich sagen.
Um zu gucken, ob es kratzt.
Weil eins muss man ja mal wirklich sagen, diese Saphir-Glas-Display-Sachen, die sind extrem hart.
Also es ist kein Wunder, dass ihr das nicht verkratzt bekommt.
Es gibt nicht viel Material, was diese Displays wirklich kratzen kann.
Das ist extrem hart.
Ich meine, das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt diamanthart, aber es ist gar nicht so weit davon entfernt.
Das Zeug ist brutal hart.
Warum kostet das 40 Dollar?
Weil der Headphone-Jack am gleichen Zeitpunkt, als die Wireless-Airpods entstanden sind,
ausgelöst wurde.
Weißt du, total normales Verhalten.
Du kannst sehen, dass innerhalb der magnetischen zirkeligen Verbindung ein Grupp von bewegten
Gehältern ist, die den Druck auf die andere Reihe von bewegten Gehältern im Handy vermitteln.
Wir werden sehen, wie diese wirklich aussehen, wenn wir sie für das Teardown-Video öffnen.
Aber während wir hier draußen sind, können wir sehen, wo die Magneten sind, mit einigen
Metall-Schäfungen.
Die Magneten formen einen perfekten Kreis um die Außenseite der Koppelgehege.
Ah, so ist das.
Ich glaube, es ist ziemlich cool, auch wenn du dein Kreditkarte und dein Handy nicht mehr
in der gleichen Tasche hältst.
Es ist wahrscheinlich eine gute Idee im Allgemeinen, die Metall-Schäfungen von deinem Handy wegzuhalten.
Wenn du dich erinnerst, sind die Earpiece und der Lautsprecher auch beide mit Magneten
hergestellt.
Also, wenn irgendeine kleine Schäfung innerhalb des Handys versäumt wird, kann sie die
Gehälter in Schrecken zerstören.
Ich bin sicher, dass die IP68-Waterprüfung den Druck und die Schäfungen verhindern wird,
aber trotzdem ist es besser sicher als sorry.
Sprechen wir über die Sicherheit.
Apple hat sich in ihrem Handy-Design dieses Jahr ziemlich stark auf die Schauflage
gesteckt, mit viel Fokus auf die Schauflage.
Apple sagt, dass ihr neues Ceramic Shield ...
Ja, dafür kostet es wahrscheinlich wieder 1200 Euro.
Oder Leute, was kostet ein iPhone 12 Pro?
Das ist wahrscheinlich unsinnig teuer wieder.
Das ist mir dann das Smartphone doch nicht wert.
Das muss nicht sein.
Aber es ist auch wichtig, dass ihr eindeutig zu ihren vorsichtig gestrukturierten, buzzword-geführten
Szenen hört.
Apple sagt, dass sie nanoceramische Kristalle in der Glas-Matrix eingestellt haben, um dramatisch
zu verbessern.
Ah gut, Apple erzählt viel, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Jeder Hersteller erzählt viel, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Aber diese neuen Kristalle sind immer noch in einer Glas-Matrix, was bedeutet, dass es
immer noch Glas ist.
Ihr müsst euch mal überlegen, ihr könnt euch quasi zweieinhalb Playstation 5 kaufen
für ein iPhone Pro.
Und wenn Glas immer noch Glas ist, wisst ihr das.
Ihr wisst den Rest.
Apple sagt nicht viel über Widerstand von Widerstand von Widerstand, sondern nur Widerstand
und Schwachheit.
Die Dinger sind ziemlich hart, das heißt, Kratzer kriegt man nicht drauf, aber das Problem
ist halt, umso härter ein Material ist, zumindest in der Regel, umso leichter splittert es halt
auch.
Das heißt, die Kombination aus Schlagfestigkeit, also Sturzüberleben auf Steine und Kratzfestigkeit
zusammen ist halt schwierig zu bauen.
Ja, das ist der Grund, warum ich mir keine Top-Smartphones kaufen würde.
Ich sehe es nicht ein, für ein Smartphone 1.000, 200, 1.100 Euro auszugeben.
Das macht das iPhone stärker als jemals.
Also ist es nicht nur das neue Glas.
Ich denke, eine große Teil der viermal mehr Widerstand kommt vom Design her.
Mit dem Glas völlig flach, das sich nur auf der Oberfläche des Frames befindet.
Ein Stück Glas hat sechs Seiten, Vorder-, Rückseite und alle vier Ecken.
Und mit fünf dieser sechs Seiten, die von diesem Smartphone vorhanden sind, ist das
das Smartphone-Frame, in einer Art, in der die meisten Smartphones nicht gebaut sind.
Es macht wirklich dieses iPhone 12 Pro stärker schadenswürdig.
Also glaube ich, dass Apples Begriffe über das Glas nicht stärker werden können.
Aber ich denke, dass das vorhandene Design mehr damit zu tun hat, als die Wörter.
Ich habe Hunderten und Hunderten von Smartphones in diesem selben Weg gescratcht, und Apples
Ceramics Schild ist immer noch bei Level 6, mit tieferen Gräben bei Level 7.
Es könnte nur meine Vorstellung sein, aber es sieht so aus, als ob die Level 6-Scratches
etwas feiner sind.
Aber sie sind definitiv noch nicht so gut.
Oh.
Der Apple-Fan weint jetzt.
Erst mal ein neues iPhone und erst mal zerkratzen.
Ne Basti, EW haben ich nicht mitgekriegt.
Oh.
underneath the glass. But there's an alcohol wipe and a dust sticker in the box to help
mitigate that. The screen protector is held in place by a thin layer of nano adhesive,
so there's no residue left on the glass when it's ever removed. And since the iPhone 12
Pro display is totally flat, the precision cut screen protector makes it look like it
was meant to be there. Just like you wear safety glasses to protect your eyes and a
mask to protect your lungs, a screen protector is a cheap way to avoid a lot of future regret.
I'll leave a link for dbrand screen protectors down in the video description. Plus, these
aren't your normal plastic rubbery screen protectors either. It's an additional layer
of protective tempered glass. And as we know, glass is glass and glass can. It's much easier
to replace a $10 screen protector than it is to replace a $10 screen protector.
I'll leave that link in the description. Now I'll leave it totally on. But who'd have to say that the iPhone 12 Pro is one of the cleanest looking and best feeling phones that I've held in a really long time?
Oh, der Apple-Fan weint jetzt, ich sag's euch, wenn er das sieht.
And the frame is surprisingly hard to scratch. The sides of the iPhone 12 Pro are made from
stainless steel. The sides of the iPhone 12 Pro are also made from stainless steel. They're
having a hard time damaging each other.
Oh, der Sound, Alter, oh, das tut weh.
The frame is obviously still going to scratch off. Most phones are usually made from softer
aluminum.
Oh, hör auf zu kratzen, Alter.
It's just that there is no expandable memory, of course. There never was. The magnets on
the back and behind are still part of the old tool board.
Gleich schneidet er sich aus Versehen, ja.
And then, of course, at the bottom we still have...
Alter, was mit dem los?
I'm also a big fan of the textured glass back here.
Was geht mit dem ab?
...other objects. Since glass is a very hard material, softer objects like this penny
will leave marks behind on the glass. But the marks aren't permanent, it's just dust
caught on the rough surface and can be rubbed away.
Erstmal das ganze Centstück hier abreiben dran.
The top camera bump is relatively reasonable this year when compared to Samsung's monstrosities.
The bottom lens is a 12 megapixel, two times optical...
Wie sie einfach wieder 50 Milliarden Kameras mittlerweile an Smartphones haben. Okay, es
sind glaube ich...
...und ich glaube, dass wir das auch noch mal sehen. Ich glaube, dass wir das auch noch mal sehen.
...und ich glaube, dass wir das auch noch mal sehen. Ich glaube, dass wir das auch noch mal sehen. Ich glaube, dass wir das auch noch mal sehen.
Es sind glaube ich nur drei Kameras, ne? Das ist der Blitz und was ist das? Was ist das da unten?
Infrarotgedöns?
Leider, das ist doch so Entfernungsmesser und sowas, oder?
Okay.
...zoom Telephoto, dann haben wir das 12 Megapixel Ultra Wide im Zentrum und den Haupt 12 Megapixel Sensor oben.
Und jede Kamera-Linse wird wieder mit ihrer eigenen Sapphire-Kristall-Linse-Kamera geklebt.
Es bekommt noch Marken bei Level 6 und 7, aber ihr wisst bereits, wie ich mich damit fühle.
Die Kamera des iPhone 12 Pro ist ein 6,1-Inch-Super Retina-XDR-Display, also ein OLED-Display,
und hat eine etwas höhere Resolution als 1080p.
Erst mal kurz das Display anfangen!
...P.
Eine coole Sache ist, dass, selbst nach 30 Sekunden von der Heizung meines Leiters,
die Pixel auf dem OLED immer noch unbefasst sind, mit null Schaden.
Andere Smartphones starten, weiß zu werden, und werden nicht wiederholen.
Ich bin kein Material-Expert, aber Ceramic ist ein langsamer Heizungs-Konduktor als Glas.
Das bedeutet, dass es nicht so einfach ist, es durchzuführen.
Es ist also möglich, dass Apples neues Display-Material das Heizungs-Konduktor von den Pixeln abhängt.
Das bedeutet nicht viel, was die Leiters angeht,
aber es gibt ein wenig Validität zu der neuen Ceramic-Kristall-Material-Klammer, die Apple herstellt.
Das oleophobische Kleidung ist definitiv evakuiert, also probiert nicht den Burn-Test auf eurem Smartphone.
Was ist mit dem Bind-Test?
Ich meine, es ist wahrscheinlich leicht zu überlegen.
Aber mit dem mehr soliden Stahl- und Stahl-Framen und dem Resset-Glas auf beiden Seiten, der die Klammer schützt...
Oh! Hört ihr das Knacken?
...rigid.
Der iPhone 12 Pro ist ein unvergleichbarer Tank eines Smartphones.
Und ich bin beeindruckt.
Kein Bind-Gate.
Kein Bind-Gate wieder.
Apple ist, und immer war, premium und teuer.
Aber zumindest in den letzten Jahren haben die Materialien angefangen, den Preis-Tag etwas besser zu ergreifen.
Ich habe mein letztes Smartphone seit über drei Jahren benutzt.
Und ich hatte nur mein aktuelles Smartphone seit ungefähr einem Jahr.
Also bin ich noch nicht bereit, es zu verbessern.
Die sollen mich mal draufsetzen lassen. Mal gucken, ob es dann bindet.
Ich warte bis nächstes Jahr das iPhone 13 Pro Max Ultra Plus 6.
Eine 6G, keine Display-Edition.
Bevor ich meine Gedanken ausdrücke.
Ich lasse die Links in der Beschreibung.
Für die Sachen, die Apple vergessen hat zu verwenden.
Wie den Charger und den Display-Protektor.
Lasst mir wissen, was ihr von Apples neuem Smartphone in den Kommentaren denkt.
Seid ihr cool damit, den Charger zu verlassen?
Kommt mit mir auf Instagram und Twitter.
Und danke fürs Zuschauen.
Also, was lernen wir da draus?
Man kann es kaum kratzen.
Also, man kann kaum Kratzer reinmachen.
Und man kann es nicht verbiegen.
Aber es kostet 1.100 Euro.
Was haben wir hier sonst noch?
Windows 10.
Also, wenn der KDE Colorchooser eines der Top-Windows-Programme sein soll.
Äh, Top-Linux-Programme.
Dann muss ich mir das...
Okay.
Wir gucken es uns nicht an.
Wir gucken mal, was er dazu zu sagen hat.
Was die Top-Linux-Programme sind.
Also, wir scrollen mal durch.
Wir scrollen mal durch.
Was sind die Top-Linux-Programme?
Skill-Share.
So, was haben wir als erstes?
Darktable.
Okay.
Das ist wirklich gut für Foto-Leute.
Ich kann dazu nichts sagen.
Aber das ist nicht schlecht.
Das habe ich schon an vielen Stellen gehört, dass das taugt.
So, was haben wir als nächstes?
Darktable.
Skill...
Haha.
Erstmal gleich den Sponsor reinhauen.
Skill-Share.
Excel.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass Skill-Share eine Linux-App ist.
Übrigens.
Seit wann ist das eigentlich so allgemein, dass man zu allem Apps sagt?
Früher waren Apps die Sachen auf dem Smartphone.
Und normale Programme, das auf dem Desktop, mittlerweile sind alles Apps.
Ich meine, letztendlich ist Apps der Abkürzung.
Das kommt schon hin.
So, was haben wir als nächstes?
Gimp.
Igitt.
Geh mal weg.
Gimp.
Ganz, ganz schlimm.
Okay, da kann der Color-Chooser.
Brauchen wir nicht.
Ja, also das habe ich jetzt schon von ein paar Leuten gehört, dass das recht erträglich
ist, da mit Videos zu machen.
Ich weiß nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich bin mit diesen ganzen Audio-Videosachen unter Linux nicht wirklich warm geworden.
Was PDF-SAM, kenne ich nicht.
Thunderbird.
Da gebe ich ihm recht.
Das ist aber nicht eines der besten Linux-Apps.
Das ist so allgemein eines der besten Apps.
Eines der letzten übrig gebliebenen Mail-Programme, die man irgendwie noch einfach bedenkenlos
verwenden kann.
Wobei die bei Thunderbird auch einiges verkackt haben in den letzten Versionen.
Zum Beispiel, dass die immer wieder es geschafft haben, inkompatibel zu sein.
Das ist meiner Meinung nach auch das hauptsächliche Problem, warum Firefox nicht mehr so beliebt
ist.
Firefox war eigentlich immer so der Browser für, nennen wir es mal so, für die Pros,
ja.
Die auch zigtausend Erweiterungen, also Auswahl aus zigtausend Erweiterungen hatten, sich
auch ein paar abgedrehte Erweiterungen installiert haben und viele Settings hatten zum Einstellen
und sowas.
Dafür war Firefox immer beliebt bekannt.
Und die haben die letzten Jahre sukzessive angefangen, Plugins rauszuschmeißen, Plugins
schnittstellen inkompatibel zu machen, Versions-Upgrades zu machen, die dann Plugins nicht mehr unterstützt
haben.
Letztendlich ist halt heutzutage die Frage, warum genau sollte ich Firefox verwenden?
So die wirkliche Identität hat Firefox nicht mehr.
Die wissen es selbst nicht so genau, glaube ich.
So.
Aber Thunderbird ist okay.
VirtualBox, okay, das würde ich auch unterschreiben, ja.
Wenn es nicht vor allem eine Workstation ist, dann VirtualBox ist okay.
Jaja, aber Thunderbird ist auch so, ja.
So.
KeyPass, ja, gebe ich ihm recht, ist auch sehr praktisch, habe ich auch am Start.
Das ist ein Terminal, das sagt, mag ich nicht.
Dolphin, wenn man grafische Dateimanager mag, okay, warum nicht.
Okay, das war's.
So schlimm, so schlecht war das jetzt gar nicht.
Ob das jetzt wirklich die zehn Besten sind, ja, Geschmackssache.
So war das von Intel wahrscheinlich nicht gedacht.
Ah, ja nice, guck mal.
Der hat vor fünf Minuten das neue Video rausgebracht, was wir vorhin noch, das von letzter Woche
geguckt haben.
Das gucken wir uns jetzt gleich nochmal an.
Hallo zusammen, herzlich willkommen zu einem weiteren Video.
Wir haben uns vor einigen Tagen den Intel Cryo Cooler angeschaut.
Genau, und angeblich geht es ja nur für Intel, aber scheint jetzt auch für AMD zu gehen.
Dieses wunderschöne Teil hier, womit wir eben durch das eingebaute Element unterhalb
der Raumtemperatur kühlen können.
Da das eben ein Intel Cryo Cooler ist, der ist zwar jetzt von EKWB gefertigt.
Der große Unterschied zu Outlook ist, dass Thunderbird Open Source ist und kostenlos.
Ist der eben nur mit Intel kompatibel.
Und ich habe mir aber gedacht, wäre es nicht mega interessant zu sehen, was so ein aktueller
Ryzen 5000 unter solchen Temperaturen erreichen könnte.
Und deswegen dachte ich mir, montieren wir das Teil heute auf einem aktuellen Ryzen 5V.
Ich habe hier den 559X, den wir uns beim Launch Video angeschaut haben.
Ist ja eine relativ gute CPU, da haben wir ja um die 5,8 GHz im Cinebench erreicht.
Deswegen bin ich mal sehr gespannt, was das Ding mit dem Intel Cryo Cooler erreicht.
Da bin ich auch mal gespannt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das aus der Kameraeinstellung sehen könnt, aber ich habe hier eben nicht
nur dieses Board hier, das Crosshair 8 Dark Hero auf dem Tisch.
Das sind wieder 500, 600 Euro Mainboards.
Auch ein Maximus XII Extreme.
Okay, okay, wir gucken mal, was das kostet.
Die sind doch alle nicht mehr ganz dicht.
Moment, das hatten wir doch vorher schon.
Das hatten wir uns doch vorher schon angeguckt, oder?
War das nicht das Board, das wir uns doch vorher schon angeguckt haben?
Okay, was hat der hier vorher gehabt für ein Board?
Nicht nur dieses Board hier, das Crosshair 8 Dark Hero.
Was? Crosshair Dark Hero.
Ah, ein Schnapper, nur 400 Euro fürs Mainboard.
Auf dem Tisch.
Und das ist ein XIII Extreme.
Das ist ein XIII Extreme, sondern eben auch ein Maximus XII Extreme.
Denn wie gesagt, der Cooler ist jetzt nicht nur physikalisch nur mit Intel kompatibel,
also aufgrund der Halterung, was kein Problem ist, das passen wir gleich noch an,
sondern eher auch softwaretechnisch, denn ich gehe davon aus, dass wir bei der AMD CPU
die Software gar nicht erst installieren können, aber ist ja kein Problem,
wenn wir noch ein zweites Setup einfach nebendran stellen.
Ja, ich würde sagen, legen wir los.
XII ist eine Firma aus Finnland. Die Firma hat ca. 1700 Mitarbeiter in 60 verschiedenen Ländern.
Sellout-Mode activated.
Die Firma ist seit 1988 im IT-Security-Geschäft tätig.
VPN.
Oh nein, es ist wirklich VPN-Werbung.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es jetzt Finnland-VPN gibt.
Ey, ist das Ganze überhaupt vertrautwürdig?
Und wer steckt eigentlich hinter so einer Firma?
Was ist der Unterschied von den teuren Mainboards?
FCQ ist auf jeden Fall eine der größten Firmen dieser Welt.
Ja, schwer zu sagen. Also, das kann man wirklich schwierig sagen.
Also, meistens haben die ein bisschen bessere Spannungswandler drauf oder mehr Spannungswandler drauf
oder haben irgendwelche Overclocking-Features oder unsinnig viele M2-Slots, USB-Anschlüsse und sonst was.
In der Regel braucht man diese ultra-teuren Mainboards gar nicht.
Die Branche sitzt in der EU und hat mit die längste Erfahrung überhaupt.
FCQ-Freedom VPN blockierte Tracker-Mapper-Werbung und gleichzeitig könnt ihr im Tracker-Mapper feststellen,
was genau der VPN da im Hintergrund für euch ist.
Was genau der VPN da im Hintergrund für euch ist.
Damit schützt ihr euch im Internet, egal ob zuhause oder unterwegs im öffentlichen WLAN.
Ich selbst habe Freedom VPN für ca. 4 Wochen ausprobiert und alleine heute wurden bei ca. 5 GB Daten 3 Trackingversuche blockiert.
Mit dem Code FREEDOM20 erhaltet ihr 20% Rabatt beim Kauf von Freedom VPN.
Mehr findet ihr über den Link in der Beschreibung.
Wie gerade schon angekündigt, hier haben wir eben den 10900K darunter und dieses Setup.
Deswegen ist es auch übrigens nur luftgekühlt. Das wird einfach nur dazu dienen.
einfach nur dazu dienen, dass wir die Softwaresteuerung für den Kühler übernehmen können,
denn eigentlich müsste das komplett ohne CPU funktionieren, beziehungsweise...
Ah, das ist Big Brain, der nimmt sich ein Intel-System, um die Software zu verwenden.
Also der steuert die über ein Intel-System mit der Software,
hat aber den Kühler auf einem AMD-System.
Ja, kann man machen.
Normalerweise montieren wir ja den Intel-Crew-Kuhler über die typischen Nasen,
wie es auch bei den ganz normalen EK-Waterblocks-Wasserkühlern der Fall ist,
mit eben diesen Standoffs und einer typischen Backplate.
Ich habe jetzt hier eine EK-AMD-Backplate, die wir gleich versuchen werden zu verwenden.
Da müssten zumindest mal die Standoffs gut reinpassen.
Und dafür müssen wir auf jeden Fall die Original-AMD-Halterung entfernen.
Und wir haben hier noch dieses Stencil, also dieses Schaumstoffteil, was zur Isolation sein soll.
Es sieht wirklich aus wie irgendein Prototyp aus einem 3D-Drucker, ne?
Das sollte eigentlich gut hier drüber passen.
Weil die AMD-CPUs bzw. der AMD-Sockel ja ein bisschen kleiner ist als Intel.
Ganz ehrlich, Basti IW, das kann ich da keinem vorwerfen.
Warum denn nicht?
Ich meine, der macht die Werbung ja nur wirklich nicht so,
als wäre er persönlich da jetzt voll dahinter her.
Das ist auch kein Problem, du musst gucken, wo du bleibst.
Funktionieren zumindest mal, wenn wir die Kunststoffteile abgemacht haben.
Das sieht ja eigentlich schon mal ganz gut aus.
Also das Isolationsteil passt auf jeden Fall schon mal sehr gut.
Gerade die Kunststoffnasen hier entfernt.
Ich habe mir die Montage jetzt doch ein bisschen einfacher gemacht,
ich habe jetzt hier M4-Schrauben genommen.
Ich glaube, die sind von Corsair-Radiatoren.
Bin mir nicht ganz sicher, könnt ihr auf jeden Fall hinkommen.
Sieht von der Länge her gut aus.
Und dann habe ich mir diese Teile hier Laser geschnitten.
Einfache 5mm Acryl-Teile.
Die äußeren Maße sind vom Sockel 1151.
Und die inneren Maße einfach vom Sockel AM4.
Das Ganze dann hier einfach an den Kühler von unten angeschraubt.
Und dann sollte das eigentlich auch funktionieren.
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt jetzt.
Lassen wir den einfach...
Jo.
Sieht doch eigentlich ganz gut aus.
Da sehe ich gerade, das sind zwei unterschiedlich lange Schrauben.
Aber wurscht.
Da muss ich nochmal nacharbeiten.
Nachschärfen, haben wir jetzt gelernt. Nachschärfen.
Vielversprechend aus.
Also man sieht hier an der Seite so ein bisschen, dass das so ein bisschen zur Seite gequetscht wird.
Also dieses Isolier-Schaumstoffteil liegt einfach daran, weil der Interestsockel, glaube ich, minimal höher ist als das AMD-Teil.
Deswegen wird das so ein bisschen mehr nach unten gequetscht.
Aber ansonsten...
Basti sagt, eine gewisse Moral sollte jeder noch behalten oder nicht, um nicht jeden Scheiß zu vermarkten.
Ey, ich habe auch G2A-Wärmung gemacht, ja.
...sitzt das Ding.
Auf jeden Fall mega solide drauf.
Ja, und soweit ist unser Setup aufgebaut.
Sieht schon mal sehr, sehr gut aus.
Rechts die Intel-Plattform, links die AMD-Plattform.
Alles läuft jetzt aktuell über ein Netzteil.
Wir haben hier hinten das Seasonic 1600 Watt Netzteil.
Das speist die komplette Intel-Plattform plus den Kryo-Kühler, der jetzt gerade hier...
...auf der AMD-CPU montiert ist.
Und ihr seht, oben das USB-Kabel geht nach rechts rüber zur Intel-Plattform.
Das ist Big Brain Setup.
Wahrscheinlich, also vermute ich jetzt mal, wenn man diese Intel-Software hat,
wahrscheinlich muss man da mit einem Hex-Editor oder irgendwas ein paar Werte ändern,
dass die auch auf einem AMD-Board startet.
Könnte ich mir gut vorstellen.
Wahrscheinlich ist da gar nicht wirklich viel an Checks drinne.
Das gleich aktivieren, alles mal anmachen.
Und wenn wir das starten, dann startet eben...
...erst mal das Intel-System, auf dem wir die Software installieren.
Und bei dem AMD-System sollte dann der Kühler eben kalt werden.
Aber das System läuft erstmal nicht, also ist ja noch keine Grafikkarte drauf.
Der Kühler an sich ist auch noch nicht angeschlossen.
Das heißt, wir können die Wärme auch noch nicht abführen.
Aber um so einen kurzen Test zu machen, zu schauen, ob das funktioniert, reicht es auf jeden Fall erstmal aus.
Wie erwartet, Intel-Kryo-Kühler-Software installiert.
Soweit alles gut. Power 0 Watt.
Jetzt bin ich aber gespannt.
Hier oben seht ihr den Kühler in Standby-Mode.
Taupunkt 14 Grad aktuell.
Kühler-Bodentemperatur bei 23,5 Grad.
Jetzt ist eigentlich nur die Frage, wenn wir das Ganze in den Kryo- oder Unregulated-Mode schalten, ob das dann funktioniert.
Müssten wir jetzt direkt mal sehen.
Also, Success ist schon mal sehr gut.
Und wir sehen, Temperatur...
Ja, Kühler-Bodentemperatur sinkt ab.
Perfekt.
Wie kriege ich das jetzt wieder aus?
Gar nichts. Gleich friert es sich durch den Boden durch.
Wieso kann ich das jetzt nicht mehr in Standby-Mode schalten?
Kommt gleich vom Nachbar unten raus.
Ah. So.
Jetzt ist es wieder im Standby-Modus.
Alles klar. Ich musste erst von Kryo auf Unregulated gehen, um wieder in Standby zu kommen.
Das ist auch interessant.
Aber hat auf jeden Fall soweit funktioniert.
Ihr seht, Kühler-Bodentemperatur ist auf jeden Fall deutlich unterhalb Raumtemperatur.
Und das, obwohl wir natürlich eine AMD-CPU befeuern.
Aber der Kühler kann es ja nicht wissen, weil der Kühler denkt ja, er sitzt auf einem 10900K.
Es wird interessant. Es läuft.
Und es ist auch richtig schön warm.
Also der 550X hat gerade 84 Grad Celsius.
Wir lassen hier gerade den R20 Single-Threaded laufen, weil der Kühler ist jetzt gerade noch im Standby.
Das heißt, das PLT-Element ist aktuell nicht aktiv.
Und jetzt switchen wir mal den Monitor zum anderen System und aktivieren das Ganze mal.
Jetzt bin ich aber gespannt.
Und jetzt aktivieren wir hier den Kryo-Mode.
Das bedeutet, dass der Kühler überhalb des Taupunktes gehalten wird.
Wir sehen hier jetzt gerade Taupunkt knapp 15 Grad Celsius und Kühler-Bodentemperatur sind 46 Grad.
Ja, da sehen wir schon, das sinkt jetzt rapide ab.
Ah, nur 170 Watt Verbrauch. Easy.
Bei einem anderen System sieht es jetzt auch schon viel besser aus.
Wir haben jetzt beim CCD2, da haben wir...
Also im Prinzip verbraucht der Kühler jetzt wahrscheinlich sogar das Doppelte von der CPU oder sowas.
Was verbraucht so ein 5059X unter Volllast?
Über 200 Akku. Dann verbrauchst du ungefähr so viel wie die CPU.
Kühle Temperaturen, da sind wir immer so bei 30 Grad Celsius oder 20 Grad Celsius.
Du hast quasi vom Stromverbrauch her ein Dual-Sockel-Board, aber mit nur einer CPU und nochmal einem fetten Kühler drauf.
Und CCD1, da läuft eben gerade der Test drauf.
Da sind wir jetzt bei 50 Grad Celsius. Das ist schon mal 30 Grad weniger als vorher.
Ich bin gespannt, wo sich das Ganze gleich einpendeln wird.
Ja, viel tiefer kommen wir tatsächlich nicht.
Also wir bleiben hier bei einer Maximal-Temperatur.
Bei CCD1 bei einer Single-Threaded-Load natürlich von ca. 55 Grad Celsius.
Ach, das ist Single-Threaded.
Und CCD2 ist schön kalt.
Ich würde sagen, wir switchen einfach mal in ein Spiel rein.
Und schauen, wie das Ganze da aussieht.
Das sieht doch soweit schon mal ganz interessant aus.
30 Milliarden Kerne, ey.
Das ist der Grund.
Ich bin immer noch hin und her gerissen.
Kaufe ich mir einen 5950X oder nur einen 5900X?
MrSchokokuchenMonster abonniert auf Stufe 1.
Dankeschön.
Excellent Subscription.
Moment, wo ist mein Sound?
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Was spricht?
Was spricht für einen 5900X versus einen 5059X?
Und wir sehen hier in der Regel.
Es ist natürlich davon abhängig, auf welches...
Twitch Prime, Dankeschön.
Huge Sub.
IIQ Sub.
...die gerade das Spiel läuft.
Das sieht man ganz eindeutig.
Wir sehen ab und zu mal Boost-Takt auf 5050.
Das ist, weil wir den OC-Switcher verwenden.
Und dann sehen wir Boost auf 4,9 Gigahertz auf den restlichen 8 Kernen.
Es gibt auch ab und zu mal, dass wir 4,9 hier haben und 4,8 hier.
Also beides zusammen.
Aber 4,9 ist ordentlicher Boost, oder?
Das ist das OC-Setting, das ich hier gerade eingestellt habe.
Ich kenne mich bei AMDs nicht aus.
Wirklich krass.
Ja, es ist natürlich die ganz große Frage, wie sieht das im Cinebench aus?
Oh ja, zeig her.
Was natürlich wirklich krasse Last ist.
Excellent.
Und die CPU auch extrem fordern wird und gleichzeitig auch den Kühler wahrscheinlich überfordern wird.
Den Single-Core-Run habe ich schon gemacht.
Da sind wir bei 274 absolut in line.
Und jetzt machen wir mal den Multi und schauen, was passiert.
Hatte der Bauer nicht vorhin den 10900K getestet mit dem gleichen und hatte der nicht 600 irgendwas Single-Core?
Kann doch eigentlich gar nicht sein.
Ah, das ist ein anderer Cinebench.
Aha, okay.
Ah, verstehe, verstehe.
Vielleicht war das Vorgabe.
Vielleicht war das Vorgabe von Intel.
Wir dürfen keine schlechteren Nummern haben als AMD.
Xerox Zeno, 15 Monate, danke für den Sub.
Huge Subscription.
Big Brain Sub.
Massive IQ für Chat-Boost.
Der ist flutscht, hä?
Der ist flutscht.
Oh, Crash.
RIP.
Das habe ich mir schon fast gedacht.
Das war zu viel.
Allerdings haben wir ja noch einen Assenärmel und zwar haben wir noch den Unregulated Mode.
Dann schauen wir mal, was passiert.
Wenn wir die CPU einfach mal so weit runterkühlen, wie es geht.
Das sieht schon mal sehr, sehr geil aus.
Wie viel Stromverbrauch?
Er soll jetzt mal den Strom verbrauchen.
Da bin ich mal gespannt drauf.
Die Kern-Temperaturen hier unter 10 Grad, also zwischen 0 und 10 Grad.
Das ist einfach immer ein geiler Anblick, sowas zu sehen.
Dann starten wir das Cinebench und schauen, ob wir es diesmal hinbekommen.
Boah, das ist ja...
Ich kann mich noch an die älteren Cinebench-Sachen erinnern, die du mit dem Quad-Core gemacht hast.
Das ging dann flup, flup, flup.
Und jetzt macht es einfach nur flup und ist fertig.
Zack, zack, easy.
Oh, guck mal, das ist aber auch schon viel.
4829 Punkte.
Ihr dürft jetzt aber logischerweise nicht vergessen, dass das hier der Cinebench R15 ist, nicht R20.
Und die Taktraten, die lagen jetzt gerade...
Ja, wir können es gleich nochmal machen, aber ich glaube, die lagen eben bei 4,9 und 4,8 GHz.
Ja, ihr seht hier 4,9 und 4,8.
Probieren wir nochmal den R20.
Ist halt deutlich härter und deutlich länger.
Ja.
Not stable.
Ja, das ist das Maximum, was geht.
Wo ich mir nicht so ganz sicher bin, ist, warum mein Score so, ich sag mal, relativ niedrig ist.
Irgendwie schwankt es bei der CPU so krass.
Ich weiß nicht genau, woran es liegt.
Single-Core passt immer, Multi-Core schwankt immer so ein bisschen krass.
Ja.
4,85 auf CCD1.
4,80 auf CCD2.
Das hat tatsächlich funktioniert im R20.
Krass.
Krass, wirklich krass.
Interessant.
Wie schon beim 10.000-mal-Weltkarten.
Ich meine, es war irgendwo klar, dass das Ding auch mit einer anderen CPU funktioniert.
Wenn Sie jetzt noch die Intel-Software irgendwie gepatcht kriegen, letztendlich ist es auch auf AMD-CPUs nicht sinnvoll, ja.
Das Teil.
Ich meine, wie gesagt, du hast quasi einen Kühler, der nochmal so viel verbraucht wie deine CPU.
Das hat mich jetzt natürlich auch noch interessiert, wie sieht das Ganze bei einer Validation aus.
Das bedeutet, wir fixieren die Kerne alle auf den gleichen Wert und auch die gleiche Spannung und versuchen dann einfach mal zu schauen,
wie hoch kann man die CPU auf den gleichen Wert aufnehmen.
Wie hoch kann man die CPU takten, ohne jetzt einen Benchmark auszuführen, aber einfach nur mal, um zu sehen, wie hoch der Takt an sich geht.
Die CPU ist jetzt so kalt, wie sie eben, ich sag mal, werden kann.
In der Einstellung, die ich jetzt vorgenommen habe.
Wir haben knapp 1,5 Volt auf der CPU.
Auf allen 16 Kernen.
Ist das viel oder wenig für Ryzen? Ich habe keinen Plastenschimmer.
6 Gigahertz sind jetzt hier typischerweise so um die 10 Grad Celsius.
Wenn mal kurz Last kommt, vielleicht so Richtung 20 Grad Celsius.
Jetzt schauen wir einfach mal ganz kurz.
Was denn geht.
Was denn geht bei einem Allcore OC?
Wir setzen uns erstmal alles auf 4,8.
Das sollte eigentlich noch funktionieren.
Das haben wir ja vorhin schon gesehen im Game.
Und jetzt schauen wir einfach mal, wie hoch wir kommen auf allen Kernen.
Machen jetzt natürlich quasi nur eine Validation.
Das bedeutet, wir checken einfach nur, wie hoch die CPU-Kerne im Idle kommen, ohne wirkliche Last.
Wir haben natürlich die Last der Programme, die gerade läuft.
Wir haben die Windows im Hintergrund natürlich logischerweise.
Aber jetzt kein Cinebench zum Beispiel.
Hast du eine mechanische Tastatur benutzt?
Die Frage ist...
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das eine komplett mechanische ist.
So eine halbe mechanische ist das glaube ich.
Ich habe jetzt...
Wie heißt das Ding, was ich für eine Tastatur habe?
Ich hatte davor eine Corsair, eine richtig komplett mechanische Corsair-Tastatur.
Aber die hat massig Probleme gemacht.
Habe ich eine G413 oder so? Kann das sein?
Oder eine G513?
Ja, eher die hier.
Ich glaube, die habe ich...
Davor hatte ich eine Corsair K95 Platinum.
Und die war einfach Müll.
Doppelte Tastenanschläge, Kack-Software.
Voll auf den Sack.
Jetzt ist nochmal das Video vom Bauer fertig.
Äh...
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir 5 GHz auf allen Kernen so erreichen können.
Oder vielleicht sogar noch ein bisschen mehr.
Das ist schon mal sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr cool.
5 GHz, ordentlich.
Ich meine, 5 GHz auf 16 haben die Ryzen-Kernen, die natürlich unfassbar schnell sind.
Ja, aber sobald du wahrscheinlich im Benchmark aufpasst, ist das Ding jetzt erstmal direkt RIP.
5050.
Und 5,1 GHz.
Okay.
Das ist mehr, als ich dachte.
Mach mal den Benchmark auf, ich will sehen, wie es crasht.
Weil wir ja 5,8 mit Flüssig-Schickstoff gemacht haben.
Das darf man jetzt nicht vergessen.
Geht 5,8 natürlich noch.
Okay, 5,2 GHz.
Das ist mehr, als ich dachte, dass das möglich ist.
Wir sind ja auch so, sag ich mal, beim Sweetspot.
Wenn wir jetzt wirklich mehr Spannung machen, dann wird die CPU dadurch deutlich wärmer.
Und dadurch verlieren wir wahrscheinlich Potenzial nach oben.
Ja.
Aber schauen wir mal, was passiert jetzt.
5,2.
Force Champ.
Ey, wenn wir jetzt 5,3 GHz schaffen, das ist ja natürlich...
Okay.
Ja, aber sobald der ein bisschen Last drauf macht, gibt das Ding wahrscheinlich komplette Geister auf.
Ich fasse es nicht.
Das ist schon mega krass.
Was der Links von der Software hat, irgendein AMD-Overclock-Tool oder so.
Okay.
Das war's.
RIP.
Unfassbar.
Also, der Intel Cryo Cooler ist nach wie vor ein lustiges Spielzeug.
Es ist natürlich schade, dass er nativ nicht bei den AMD-CPUs unterstützt wird.
Er meinte dieses Programm hier neben.
Das hier meinte er, nicht das hier.
Ja, mit den Cryo Coolern.
Ich meine, ist klar, dass es auf eine AMD-CPU geht irgendwo.
Ich finde es aber geil, dass er es nochmal ausprobiert hat.
Ich bin schon am Start.
Drei Stunden, ich kriege Hunger.
Was empfehlen sie uns denn heute noch?
YouTube.
How to make Windows 8.1 look almost...
Ja, aber warum?
Ich kann einfach Windows 10 verwenden.
Sieht zwar nicht aus wie Windows 7, aber es ist noch lange support und funktioniert.
Halbwegs.
Wenn man davon funktionieren sprechen kann.
Wann kommt denn jetzt Windows Unleashed raus?
Wollte schon mal gucken.
Das ist quasi dieses Battlefield 3.
Remake kann man es nicht nennen.
Battlefield 3 mit Modding Tools.
Irgendwann im Dezember, aber wann?
Kriegen wir nicht.
Kriegen wir nicht erzählt.
Ah ja, dann nicht.
Was hältst du von den neuen ARM Macs?
Ich habe mich da kaum drüber informiert.
Ich habe mal bei Heise irgendwas gelesen, dass die performancemäßig wirklich gut abschneiden.
Letztendlich hat Apple ja auch den großen Vorteil.
Äh, ich weiß nicht.
Ich weiß nicht.
Wie man hat Discord genommen und möchte jetzt halt auch da irgendwie mitmischen können.
Na, guck mal hier.
Das sieht halt mal original aus wie Discord, nur in TeamSpeak-Farben.
Nein, es gab kein TS4. TS4 haben sich, glaube ich, übersprungen.
Ich meine, es gibt Oldschool-Leute, die verwenden auch TS2.
TeamSpeak 2 sieht wirklich massiv Oldschool aus, wenn man sich das guckt.
Das sieht wirklich aus wie aus dem letzten Jahrtausend.
Das ist ja auch aus dem letzten Jahrtausend im Endeffekt.
TeamSpeak 2.
Tja, so hat man zu alten Online-Gaming-Zeiten Voice-Chat gemacht, TeamSpeak 2.
Gerade als ich viel MMOs gespielt habe, auch mit PvP,
war man in der damaligen Zeit übelst im Vorteil, wenn man TS gespielt hat,
weil die meisten anderen Leute haben damals noch Ingame-Chat verwendet.
Und Ingame-Chat versus TS ist klar.
Wer gewinnt?
Ja, das stimmt. Es wäre wirklich cool, wenn man private Discord-Server machen könnte.
Also private Discord-Server meine ich jetzt nicht.
Ich kann bei Discord einen Server erstellen, sondern man könnte Discord selbst hosten.
Das wäre schon cool, aber das werden sie nicht machen.
So, was möchte denn YouTube, dass wir noch gucken?
Ich habe übelst Hunger. Ich weiß nicht, ob wir noch was gucken.
Ich weiß noch gar nicht, ob wir schon wach sind.
Eventuell machen wir heute Abend wieder Proggers-Stream.
Wir müssen das...
Wir müssen das Webcam-Tool weiter basteln.
Exzellent, Musik.
Das ist eine coole Playlist, die speichere ich mir.
Solange es kein Monka-Toss gibt.
Marine reacts zu MW2, alles klar.
Nee, zu Modern Warfare.
Ach.
Reactet heute, reactet jeder auf alles.
Sagt mal, ich habe ja Cold War noch nicht installiert.
Hat jemand von euch schon die Kampagne gespielt?
Es ist seit Jahren echt mal wieder eine Call of Duty, wo ich wirklich auf die Kampagne gespannt bin.
Was sie da gemacht haben.
Taugt die?
TestsiegerTV.
Das klingt schon so nach Scam Channel.
Jetzt nicht, ich will das nicht unterstellen, dass sie sind.
Aber sowas klingt irgendwie immer...
Weiß nicht.
Sketchy.
Russen gleich böse, ja gut.
Das ist die typische Call of Duty-Story.
Die Russen waren fast in jedem Call of Duty die Bösen bisher.
In jedem, das ich gespielt habe.
Sogar in Battlefield.
Die Comrades.
Ja.
Also, YouTube will uns gerade keine ordentlichen Videos mehr vorschlagen.
Deswegen werde ich glaube ich jetzt mal was essen gehen.
Die Windows Tier-List.
Das ist vollkommen egal, welche Tier-List Windows oben ist.
Das einzig sinnvolle zu verwenden ist halt nun mal aktuell Windows 10.
Achso, es gibt einen Factorio Trailer 2020.
Warum das denn?
Gibt's da irgendwie ein Remake von?
Faktorio ist Massive Puggers Game.
Das ist echt so ein wissenschaftliches Spiel.
echt so Wissenschaft für sich.
Ach so, das wurde released.
Ich hab das vor drei Jahren oder so gespielt.
Das ist jetzt released.
Stimmt, stimmt, das sieht anders aus
als noch vor drei Jahren.
Ja, das sieht wirklich ein bisschen anders aus.
Faktorio ist auch so ein Game, wenn man das
erst mal angefangen hat zu spielen, man hört nicht mehr auf.
Aber, aber only
Big Brain, Leute.
Wisst ihr was?
Das ist richtig nice.
Es sieht jetzt aus, als würde
Warte mal.
Das sieht aus, als fährt
der Kopf gleich auf dem
Fließband. Guck mal.
Okay, ich weiß, ich lass mich durch easy Sachen
begeistern manchmal, ja.
Boah, das sieht wirklich so aus.
Boah, wie der Kopf langfährt.
Ja, auch Züge und so
glaube ich
doch gab es schon, als ich Faktorio gespielt hab.
Aber noch nicht so in diesem Umfang.
Was macht man in dem Game?
Ja, das ist schwierig zu beschreiben,
was man in Fakt...
Fabriken bauen.
Also die Story ist, glaube ich,
dass man auf irgendeinem fremden Planeten
gestrandet ist und jetzt eine Fabrik bauen muss,
mit der man eine Rakete bauen kann, um wieder heimzufliegen
oder so. Story in dem Game, vergiss es, ja.
Du baust im Prinzip eine Fabrik,
um dich gegen Aliens zu verteidigen,
die ab und zu mal angreifen
und größere Fabriken zu bauen.
Ja, das ist eigentlich der Sinn von Faktorio.
Ja.
Fabrik bauen, um größere Fabrik zu bauen.
Und viele Laufbänder.
Und Greifarme.
Und Zeug.
Ist aber übelst süchtig machend.
Genau, ab und zu gibt es noch irgendwelche Aliens,
die dich angreifen.
Das sieht jetzt auch viel moderner aus.
Viel besser.
Das sind jetzt richtige,
halbwegs ansinnliche 3D-Models,
die Aliens.
Bäh!
Hat er zuge...
Nice.
Ja, und die Drohnen kenne ich auch schon.
Die gab es da auch schon,
wo ich gespielt habe.
Das ist eines...
Ohne Scheiß, Leute.
Das ist eines der besten Spiele der letzten Jahre,
finde ich.
Faktor ist richtig poggers.
Um nicht zu sagen.
IO Games and the Rise of Fake Multiplayer.
Moment, das haben wir schon gesehen, oder?
Whole IO.
Der Name ist echt unglücklich gewählt.
Das ist so, wie Banggood
ein schlechter Name für eine Shopping-Seite ist.
Ja.
Das Video haben wir, glaube ich, schon gesehen.
Das sind die Games, die so tun,
als wären sie Multiplayer,
aber es sind gar keine Multiplayer.
Das ist Faktorio.
Faktorio Videos.
Jetzt kriegen wir Faktorio Videos empfohlen,
weil wir den Faktorio Trailer geguckt haben.
Dual Booting Windows XP und Windows 10.
Die große Preisfrage ist ja eher,
warum?
Weil es geht, wahrscheinlich.
Großartig im Sinn.
Also, es fragt...
Würdig, ja.
Es gibt so viele Schwachsinns-Videos auf YouTube.
How to create a simple Makefile.
Das ist einfach.
Einfach eine ordentliche Sprache verwenden und nicht C++.
Da braucht man auch keine Makefiles.
Okay, vielleicht für C noch, aber.
Einfach kein C++ verwenden ist das Beste, was man machen kann.
Tja, irgendwie schafft YouTube nicht mehr,
sondern die spannende Sachen zu empfehlen.
Da gehe ich jetzt, glaube ich, doch echt was essen.
How to...
But why?
Aber warum?
...why perks extra.
And in this video I'm going to...
...
For example, you could make a home security setup...
Ja genau, ich mache einen Home Security Setup mit Laptop-Webcams.
Alles klar.
Lohnt sich ja auch richtig.
Erst mal fünf Laptops kaufen und dann die Kamera rausbauen.
...
Excellent.
... security setup, because they're so thin and discreet.
Weil man auch immer so viele alte Laptops und Webcams noch rumliegen hat.
And you could even do an eye-contact webcam system.
Links to...
... dead Laptops for wanting to repurpose them.
Die sehen ja auch schon wirklich wasserdicht aus, ja.
Ey, wisst ihr was? Sieht aus wie so eine Nord 15 Raspberry Pi Kamera.
The first job is to actually disassemble the screen. Best thing's easy...
Was machst du denn da jetzt auf und zu?
... of course, the data connections.
These are actually super easy, as they will almost certainly be the pair that are twisted together.
As this is...
Sind's USB-Kameras?
... done to repurpose them.
... to reduce interference on the data lines.
It's impossible to tell which one is data positive and which one is data negative,
but thankfully it's unlikely to cause any damage if you get them the wrong way around.
... the issue.
...
Either way, the first electrical tape I did...
Also das ist ja mal wirklich hardcore sinnlos.
Es sei denn, man hat 20 Notebooks da herumliegen und braucht unbedingt Händeringenkameras.
Es schließt sich mir jetzt nicht.
Alter, was Kirby ist ja gut regt sich ab.
...
Besser.
Windows 10 vs. Ubuntu vs. Manjaro.
Xfce SpeedTest, okay.
Hello?
Es ist eigentlich auch wieder ein komplett sinnloser Vergleich.
...
Okay, gucken wir mal.
Das ist richtiger Schwachsinn, CaptainPage !!
Komplett sinnlos.
Das sind komplett unterschiedliche Systeme.
Wie willst du das vergleichen?
Du kannst vergleichen,
wie sinnvoll der Vergleich ist am Ende.
Das ist fragwürdig.
Also ich tippe mal drauf,
dass...
Also ich könnte mir sogar
vorstellen, dass
Windows am schnellsten installiert.
Manjaro definitiv
nicht, wenn er es mit dem Architekt-Installer
macht. Weil der Architekt-Installer,
da musst du so viel manuell machen,
da bist du eine Stunde mit beschäftigt.
Ach, Moment.
Der ist schon fertig?
Alter, meine Tür rappelt gerade.
Das war die Katze.
Die hat sich voll
in die Tür geschmissen anscheinend gerade.
Keine Sorge,
ich werde nicht gesquattet oder so.
Okay, die Installationszeit dazwischen zu vergleichen
ist komplett hirnrissig.
Ubuntu.
Also, I know I disconnected the
Wi-Fi to all the systems and made
sure there was no updates or additional
third-party software to install.
Once in the system, I opened the default
file manager on each to see
the initial response time. They were all
close, but you can see them opening with...
What? What?
Okay, das kann man
vergleichen, muss man jetzt
aber nicht wirklich...
Also, vor allem würde ich nicht das erste Mal öffnen
vergleichen, sondern weitere öffnen Vorgänge.
Naja, aber schon ziemlich sinnlose Vergleiche.
They were all close, but you can see them opening
with almost perfect timing.
First Manjaro, then Ubuntu and Windows.
Now I went ahead and took a look at some of the storage space requirements
or the amount of storage space the systems were taking up.
Okay, das kann man mal wenigstens halbwegs sinnvoll vergleichen,
wobei die Sache halt auch da ist.
Was ist denn alles vorinstalliert?
Weil ich meine, mal angenommen, ich brauche
zehn dieser Programme, die, sagen wir mal, hier dabei sind
und die muss ich da nachinstallieren,
dann macht es auch keinen großen Unterschied mehr, ne?
Also, wobei ich das unter Windows krass finde, ne?
16G nach einer Installation, wo irgendwie nur
default drauf ist, ist schon ganz schön viel.
Aber da vergleiche ich mal.
USB-File-Transfer.
Okay, da würde ich eigentlich erwarten, dass es ziemlich...
exakt gleich schnell ist.
...files to see if there are any significant differences
in this file transfer.
For me, this was probably the most...
Ubuntu cheated bestimmt.
Ubuntu skippt wahrscheinlich einfach Sachen vom File.
...surprising result as Ubuntu came out far ahead
of both Windows and Mac.
Ah, ich weiß, woran das liegt.
Ich weiß, woran das liegt.
Also, ich könnte mir vorstellen, ich weiß, woran das liegt.
Äh, die machen keinen Sync hintendran.
Also sprich, die schreiben wahrscheinlich in RAM.
Die schreiben... oder was heißt denn RAM?
Die schreiben in Cache und machen keinen Sync.
Und den Sync machen sie erst quasi später.
Oder irgendwie sowas.
Vielleicht machen sie auch keine Checksum-Gedöns oder so.
Keine Ahnung, also ich gehe mal davon aus,
dass wirklich der eigentliche Übertragungsgeschwindigkeit
per USB zwischen den Systemen nahezu exakt identisch ist.
Das kann ich mir gerade anschauen.
건데 gut dass kanste auch nicht wirklich vergleichen gerade gerade linux ist ja der meinung unbenutzter
haben ist schlechter ramm das heißt unter unter linux kann man gar nicht danach gehen
was als Frieda steht überhaupt gar nicht.
Und unter Windows mittlerweile eigentlich auch nicht.
울ces Microsoft wurdeester.
Consumer Business Management 31 Всем inequity.
CHRISOS ZELDALO.
Und den anderen K modifier.
Ich meine, guck mal, ich habe hier jetzt, mal gucken, wie viel bei mir belegt ist jetzt, ne?
Hör mal, ich habe hier angeblich 3,6G belegt.
Ich habe im Leben nichts auf, was jetzt irgendwie aus ein paar Chrome-Tests, was 3,6G braucht.
Aber Windows preloadet halt die Sachen auch teilweise.
Das ist, äh, im Prinzip ist es ja auch wirklich so.
RAM, den du nicht benutzt, ist verschenkter RAM.
Die Vergleiche sind so hardcore sinnlos, Alter.
Das sind komplett unterschiedliche Betriebsregeln, komplett unterschiedliche Programme zum Anzeigen.
Und das ist ein VLC.
VLC würde ich sogar erwarten, dass VLC, ähm, relativ langsam startet.
Ne, guck mal, VLC ist instant da.
Tja, vielleicht hat man in Jaro VLC schon preloadet, deswegen geht es schneller.
Now I went ahead and opened up a 1080p video.
And it followed basically the same results as the file manager test.
With the video opening right to left with Manjaro first and then ending with Windows.
Opening up Firefox resulted in a near tie between Windows and Manjaro with Ubuntu lagging behind.
And then loading up the YouTube website had Manjaro coming first with Ubuntu.
Tja, und da seht ihr jetzt schon eine Sache, wo alle beide Windows-Installationen, äh, alle beide Linux-Installationen mega verkacken.
Barely beating out Windows.
Wenn er jetzt ein Win...
Wenn er jetzt ein Video abspielt, ähm, und mal die CPU-Auslastung sich anguckt, dann wird er feststellen, dass Windows, keine Ahnung, 2% CPU-Auslastung hat und ordentlich Grafik-Auslastung.
Und Linux fast komplett, äh, Video abspielen über CPU macht.
Weil es immer noch, mittlerweile ist es jetzt zumindest halbwegs möglich in der richtigen Konstellation.
Aber, ähm, Hardware, äh, Dings hier, äh, nicht Decryption, Decoding.
Also GPU-Decoding unter Linux im Browser ist, ähm, ein absolutes Minenfeld und, äh, klappt öfters nicht, als dass es klappt.
Und wenn es klappt, dann auch nur für die Standard-Formate.
Und, ähm, ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob es überhaupt schon Patches gibt, dass zum Beispiel Chrome oder, oder Firefox unter Linux, äh, sagen wir mal VP9 oder sowas oder H.265 Hardware decoden können.
Das liegt gar nicht so sehr an Nvidia, in dem Fall.
Das liegt an einer Mischung aus...
Äh, ganz vielen unterschiedlichen Sachen unter Linux.
Das sind die, einmal die Browser-Hersteller, natürlich auch die Grafikkarten-Hersteller, die Grafik-Treiber-Programmierer, äh, X, ähm, irgendwelche Grafik-Schnittstelle, das ist ganz, ganz Mia.
Und jeder sagt, der andere muss es implementieren.
Also ich mein, es ist schon ein Witz, dass du quasi seit den letzten, ich übertreib jetzt mal, aber es kommt, kommt wahrscheinlich sogar ungefähr hin, seit den letzten 10 Jahren unter Windows, äh, GPU-Decoding machen kannst.
Und unter Linux vielleicht seit dem letzten halben Jahr es anfängt...
Und manchmal out of the box zu gehen.
Ja, das sind alles keine guten Vergleiche, die sind alle scheiße.
Boot-Speed.
Okay, Boot-Speed würde ich mal vermuten, dass...
Ah, wobei, da oben steht's ja schon, da muss ich jetzt gar nicht raten.
Dass Windows gewinnt, hätt ich mir, hätt ich mir denken können, ja.
Ähm, aber das ist auch...
Auch ein, auch ein komischer Vergleich, je nachdem, was die Dinger beim, beim Booten laden, ja.
Also, wenn die jetzt hier mehr Pre-Lo...
Das ist, das ist generell kein Vergleich.
Total bescheuert.
Ey, eigentlich mega, mega sinnloses Video, Alter.
Täusch, irgendein China-Ding.
If imitation is the sincerest form of flattery, I can confidently say that a Linux-Distributor would often...
...the panel layout to the desktop...
Okay, es sieht schon, es sieht schon relativ...
...ähnlich...
...aus, ja.
Wobei man hier...
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Man erkennt schon, dass das wahrscheinlich irgendein...
Wahrscheinlich irgendein Gnome...
...irgendein Gt...
...irgendein Gnome-Shell ist.
Es könnte aber auch ein KDE sein.
Schwer zu sagen, aber hier unten an den Icons erkennt man es eigentlich schon...
...dass das eher nen, eher nen...
...äh...
...eher nen Linux...
...eher nen Linux ist, wenn man das wüsste, ja.
Und auch hier, auch dieser Progress ist so'n typischer GTK-Progress-Balken.
Aber warum?
Die Frage ist, warum will man das?
Ja, das versteh ich auch nicht.
Weil das hauptsächliche Problem ist bei diesen ganzen Linux-Dingern, die aussehen wie Windows,
dass es den Leuten vortäuscht, es wäre Windows.
Aber ist es eben nicht.
Und sobald man auch nur ein bisschen an der Oberfläche kratzt, stellt man fest, es ist eben kein Windows.
Und dann sind die Leute frustriert, weil sie denken, sie können das machen wie unter Windows.
...des Bestop's Appearance from the Start-Logo and Basic Animations as Cortana on your first boot.
Moment, die haben ernsthaft Cortana nachgebaut?
Also das Beschissenste von Windows haben sie nachgebaut, oder was?
Zumindest von der Animation her.
...an assistant called Helloa that uses roughly the same logo and basic animations as Cortana.
Warum?
Das Letzte, was ich nachgebaut hab, will ich Cortana.
...on your first boot, the Helloa assistant will help set up your graphics drivers...
...despite the fact, that you have to display your graphics in a different way every time you start a new game.
...and resolution, and a couple other basics before you dive in.
Moment, wo gibt's das, wo gibt's das?
Das probieren wir mal in der VM aus, das ist so...
...was für Schwachsinniges.
Die Founders Edition sogar, hohoho!
Moment, ich soll da was bezahlen?
Null.
You've got to make it.
Pay as much as you want. Minimum ist fünf.
...you've got to make it. Pay as much as you want. Minimum ist fünf.
Aha, aha.
...Temi Linux fixen.
Moment! Ein Telegram-Download?
Was ist mit euch los?
Macht ja einen super Eindruck!
Ich scheu da gerade eine Telegram-Gruppe.
Ja, ist klar, ist alles.
Okay, manche wollen einfach nicht, dass man das ausprobiert.
Die sagen quasi, probier es nicht aus.
Du kannst es per Mail bekommen, ja genau.
So will ich Downloads 2020 in der VM machen.
Also per Post wahrscheinlich da auch noch.
Okay, es ist ganz normal Ubuntu Reskin.
MBstone.
OK, es ist ganz normal Ubuntu Reskin.
Flieger- Russian Mittrater.
...the Outlook-Logo, again-
Das ist so schlecht, Alter!
Das ist so schlecht!
Im Prinzip ist es ein stinknormales, wahrscheinlich ein ganz schlechter KDE, vielleicht Nix-FC oder so, irgendein ...
...Gnome Shell Reskin oder sowas
wo die einfach
die Sachen ausgetauscht haben durch Windows-Icons, sonst haben die ja noch nicht mal was gemacht.
Oh, das ist so dermaßen schlecht.
Warum will man sowas denn haben?
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, Microsoft, wenn das irgendwie auch nennenswerte Verbreitungen hat,
dann verklagt die Microsoft, die sind jetzt weg vom Fenster.
Du kannst nicht einfach ein Xbox-Logo reinmachen in der Linux-Distro.
Stimmt, in Cinnamon ist das. Ja, du hast recht, das ist in Cinnamon.
Ja, genau, jetzt wo du es sagst, auch mit dem Startmenü, das passt, das ist in Cinnamon.
Das hat bestimmt einer mit krassen GIMP-Skills zusammengebastelt, da hinten, dieses Hintergrundbild.
Dann klickt, oh Mann, jetzt kriegt LibreOffice, kriegt ein Excel-Logo.
Oh Gott, das ist so schlecht. Es ist so, oh, das tut weh, wenn ich das sehe.
Genau, Winra, das ist unbedingt das Allerwichtigste,
was ich unter jedem Lieblings-Logo sehe.
Ich meine, wer kommt unter Linux nicht mit Winra aus?
Putty, Putty ist auch mit Abstand das wichtigste Programm, was ich unter Linux brauche.
Putty.
Weil es unter Linux ja auch kein ordentliches Terminal und kein SSH gibt, da brauche ich Putty.
Was übrigens kein Witz, es gibt wirklich, du kannst unter Ubuntu Putty nachinstallieren,
wo ich bis heute nicht verstanden habe, was die Daseinsberechtigung ist.
Hier ist der Download, South Forge gehostet, das sagt schon mal alles.
Na gut, ich muss jetzt gar so sehr haten.
Don't accept. Ist übrigens auch geil, man kann sagen, don't accept, die Seite geht genauso.
Ja, es ist ein Cinnamon.
Was ein Crap.
Nein, nein, Putty unter Linux ist richtig echtes Putty, auch mit dem Fenster und so.
Ich guck mal, wartet mal
Ich guck mal, vielleicht gibt es Putti auch
Für Manjaro zum installieren
Über irgendeinen User-Repo oder so
Dann installieren wir uns erstmal Putti
Guck mal, ich hätte auch noch eine Ubuntu
Ach ne, das ist gar keine Ubuntu
Heißt eine Ubuntu, Jibadebundu
Warum?
Das weiß ich auch nicht, warum
Gucken wir mal, ob es
Putti gibt
Auf, geh an
Ah, exquisite Musik hier
So, ähm
Was auch immer da noch läuft
Vom letzten Mal
Putti, wie ist das?
Putti, Putti, Bäm
Zack
Ich weiß mein Login nicht
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was mein Login ist
Stimmt 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6
So wie ich mich kenne
Ne, auch nicht, okay, keine Ahnung
Okay, dann machen wir was anderes
Putti
Was fällt mir noch so ein?
Accept
Äh
Ach was weiß ich, ich weiß noch
Ich hab überall SSH-Keys, ich weiß noch
Mein Passwort jetzt doch nicht auswendig
Ja, also wirklich ernsthaft, es gibt Putti
Also so unglaublich das klingt
Es gibt Putti
Wenn man das hier startet, geht auch das Fenster auf
Okay, wo war ich denn zuletzt per SSH drauf?
Auf meinem Staubsauger
Ja, wir locken uns auf meinen Staubsauger ein
Mit Putti
Das geht
Da weiß ich das Passwort nämlich für
Warum kann
Äh, Moment, weiß ich das Passwort?
Cleaner
Cleaner ist es, glaube ich
Oh, Key, oh, Leak
Übrigens nicht schlimm, also ihr müsst in meinem Netzwerk sein
Dass ihr das verwenden könnt
Also, ist nicht schlimm
So, also probier ich mal Putti
Putti
Äh, was, Root war es, ne?
Yes
Root
Wir verwenden wirklich Putti
Putti
Es ist unglaublich unsinnig, dass es das gibt
Zufrieden mit dem Roborock, ja
Richtig, richtig nicer
Richtig nicer Staubsauger
Und ein Staubsauger mit
Ein Staubsauger mit Ubuntu 14.04 drauf
Das musste auch erstmal
Also ein Staubsauger mit Root SSH Login
Und theoretisch sogar die Möglichkeit
Keine Ahnung
Äh, Zeugs nachzuinstallieren
Also wenn man
Also ein Staubsauger, wo man Update machen könnte
Was jetzt nicht geht, was jetzt nicht geht
Weil das geblockt ist von mir, aber
Was ist das für ein Staubsauger?
Big Brain Staubsauger
So, wichtig
Das ist der hier
Moment, also ich zeige euch mal die Oberfläche
Ich hab schon öfters jetzt hier gezeigt
Das ist das Webinterface vom Staubsauger
Äh, na, das sieht man zum Beispiel in meinem Wohnzimmer
Wo er zuletzt dann rumgedüst ist
Da kann man Zeugs machen
Das ist ein Roborock S50
Staubsauger flashen?
Ne, Staubsauger ist geflasht
Flash ist raus
Ja, der da ist das
Ja, muss man gucken, dass man den günstiger kriegt
Ich hab den auch noch gekauft
Weil er mal im Angebot war
Für knapp 200, 300 Euro
Für 295 oder so
Direkt zugeschlagen
Guck mal, wir haben sogar
Es gibt sogar ein Ausrufezeichen Staubsauger
Kommando
Excellent
Ja, aber das hat mich jetzt echt geschockt, dass es
Guck mal
Die haben sogar dieses, dieses
Kack Windows Setting Menü kopiert
Hahaha
Willst, du hast recht
Mark Jojo
Du hast vollkommen recht
Wo wir gerade dabei sind
Äh
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich euch das schon mal gezeigt habe
Das ist die Oberfläche für meine Überwachung von der Heizung
Da sieht man, wie warm das Wasser aktuell ist
Was für eine Kesseltemperatur man hat
Ob es einen Fehler hat
Was der Brenner gerade macht
Was die Pumpe gerade pumpt
Welche Abgastemperatur das Ganze drin hat
Ja
Das funktioniert über einen Raspberry Pi im Keller
Mit so einem Adapterkabel vom Hersteller
Natürlich nicht mit Software vom Hersteller
Weil der Hersteller natürlich nicht will
Dass man diese Sachen ausliest aus der Heizung
So und by the way
Ich muss gerade mal gucken
Ob äh
Äh
Wird ein Zertifikat
Oh
Zertifikate laufen ab
Bam
Ach guck mal, der hat Zertifikate refreshed
Porgas
Komm her
Porgas hat seine Zertifikate refreshed
Zumindest ein paar
Nicht alle
Aber ein paar Zertifikate hat er refreshed
Magst du eigentlich Java, euer?
Ich bin der größte Java-Fan aller Zeiten
Meinung zu Rust
Big-Brain-Programmiersprache
Eines der, der äh
Interessantesten Konzepte der letzten, der letzten Jahre
Ich habe auch schon ein bisschen
Rust rumgebastelt
Aber das ist, da war Rust noch nicht mal Final
In der ersten Version
Äh, Rust ist richtig geil
Rust ist aber Massive-Brain-Programmiersprache
Also du brauchst ein zweites Gehirn
Damit du Rust richtig gut programmieren kannst
Ein Gehirn reicht nicht
Du brauchst Expanded-Brain für Rust
Nee, Rust ist nicht zu Beta
Du kannst in Rust schon gute Sachen machen
Aber, aber du brauchst, wie gesagt
Du brauchst das zweite Rust-Gehirn
Sonst geht das nicht
Nee, aber das macht mich jetzt echt
Jetzt haben die jetzt wirklich dieses
Kack-Windows-Settings-Menü nachgebaut, ja
Also die haben zwei Sachen, die mir unter Windows
Und die mich unter Windows nerven
Cortana
Und
Das da
Haben die wirklich nachgebaut
Und dann richtig
Guck, und sogar auf den ersten Blick
Sieht man, es ist eben kein Windows
Es sieht, es sieht, es sieht noch nicht mal
Noch nicht mal den ersten Blick hält es
Stand
Nein, es ist nicht
Oh, nö, wenn es kein Update ist
Musst du auch neu starten
Geh mal in die Kommentare
Es ist nicht mal shocking similar
Es ist einfach richtig schlecht
Auf ähnlich gemacht
Ok, Kommentare, ok, Kommentare guck ich mal
Ok, eigentlich nur Leute, die lustig sein wollen
Hier
Das finde ich gar nicht lustig
Weil, ich
Ich hatte es euch ja schon mal erzählt
Ich hatte letztens wirklich eine meldepflichtige Krankheit
Vor einem Monat oder so
Und es ist das erste Mal in meinem Leben
Dass ich eine meldepflichtige Krankheit hatte
Und es war nicht Corona
Ich habe mir bei irgendeinem Lieferservice
Irgendwelche
Darmbakterien
Gedöns da
Eingefangen
Ich habe einfach im Prinzip, wenn du es so willst
Ich habe vier Tage geschissen und dann war wieder gut
Aber laut
Dem Gesundheitsamt
War das eine meldepflichtige Krankheit
Ich musste so einen
Zettel ausfüllen, wo, was ich gegessen habe
Was ich arbeite
Und so Zeug
Wann .NET 5 stream?
Das kann ich dir ganz genau sagen, Kenji
Wenn es .NET 5 stream gibt
.NET 5 stream gibt es, wenn .NET 5 Rider Support raus ist
Ist noch nicht
Gibt es den Lieferservice Laden?
Gibt es noch
Ich habe zwei Lieferservice im Verdacht
Ich habe ja so eine
Ich habe ja eine History in meinen Mails
Was ich bestellt habe
Doch ERP hat, aber ich will kein ERP jetzt erst mal installieren
Weil ich bastel ja auch gerade an anderen Sachen rum
Wenn ich ERP und normale Sachen nebeneinander installieren könnte
Dann wäre das cool
Ähm
Was wollte ich jetzt gerade noch sagen
Ja genau, also den Lieferservice gibt es noch
Ich habe zwei Sachen in der Vermutung
Die das gewesen sein können
Weil ich habe ja in meiner E-Mail History gesehen
Wo ich bestellt habe
So und es kommt in Frage
Ich habe zweimal beim türkischen Lieferservice bestellt
Und ähm
Das eine mal war auch Döner Teller mit
So Joghurt Kram und sowas
Aber das war eigentlich zu kurz
Das war quasi an dem Tag vorher
Bevor es richtig los ging
Und das braucht meistens zwei bis acht Tage
Bis es anfängt
Okay, das heißt das kann es
Das kann es wahrscheinlich nicht sein
Dann habe ich ein paar Tage vorher nochmal bei diesem türkischen Lieferservice bestellt
Und da war es aber glaube ich nur
Döner Pide mit
Also nicht so die klassischen Sachen
Wo man sich das einfängt
So und dann habe ich aber
Bei einem italienischen Lieferservice
Habe ich Rahmenschnitzel und Salat bestellt
Und das war genau
Glaub 4 oder 5 Tage her
Und auch diese Sachen mit
Äh mit Rahmsoße und Salatsoße
Ist genau sowas wo man sich diesen Kack einfängt
Den ich hatte
Das heißt ich tippe ehrlich gesagt auf den italienischen Lieferservice
Wo ich mir den Kram eingefangen habe
Ich habe schon wieder vergessen
Was es war was ich hatte
Ähm
Chat ich habe es doch glaube ich mal gesagt
Äh
Irgendein Bacta
Ah der hier der hier
Das da
Campylobacter enteriiritis
Ah exzellent
Also nicht exzellent ist es nicht
Man hat Bauchweh und äh
Man muss laufen aufs Klo
Aber schön ist es nicht
Campylobacter
Genau
Ähm
Verlauf
Genau 1-7 Tage
Also es könnte auch der türkische Döner Teller gewesen sein
Nein
Nein das ist kein blutiger Durchfall
Hatte ich nicht
Also eigentlich habe ich es noch ganz gut überlebt
Ähm
Ich hatte Bauchschmerzen
Aber richtig ordentlich
Nur Durchfall
Keine blutigen Durchfälle
Aber Fieber hatte ich
Ich hatte bis zu
Was hatte ich denn 39,8 oder irgendwie sowas
Also ich hatte richtig ordentlich Fieber
Ja und das stimmt
Bevor ich richtig Durchfall bekommen habe
Habe ich schon angefangen Fieber zu bekommen
Kopfschmerzen hatte ich
Es fuck
Muskelschmerzen hatte ich auch
Gelenkschmerzen nicht so wirklich
Müt war ich auch
Ich konnte gar nicht aufstehen
Also ich habe im Bett gelegen und wenn ich aufstehen wollte
Hatte ich so das Gefühl es zieht mich was zurück
Zurück ins Bett
Das war ganz merkwürdiges Gefühl
Ja ich habe genau so 4-5 Tage hat es gedauert
Bei mir
Alles klar
Zumindest das hatte ich
Und ich wusste gar nicht das es meldepflichtig ist
Ich hatte
Ich habe das nur gemerkt
Weil mich das Gesundheitsamt angeschrieben hat
Nachdem sich das Labor da informiert hat
Ja und um auf eine andere Frage einzugehen
Bevor ich jetzt essen gehe
Ähm Rider
Man kann echt ne Side by Side Installation machen
Wirklich
Das muss ich mir gerade nochmal kurz angucken
Toolbags
Wie? Wo?
Wo macht man ne Side by Side Installation?
War das das Auto Update von denen gerade?
Wo kann ich hier ne Side by Side Installation machen?
Ah
Aha
Wusste ich gar nicht
Dann ist die nächste Frage
Gibt es .NET schon hier über
Überdings?
Ne das ist ja noch bei 3.1
Aber gut das macht nichts
Da kann ich das Snap
Das Snap installieren für
Und hat er das jetzt doppelt installiert?
Mal gucken mal gucken ob das jetzt funktioniert
Oder ob er das alte jetzt updatet
Also ich mag dieses
Das Chat Brand Zeug drauf
Auf meinem anderen Linux habe ich
Ah cool nice
Wusste ich gar nicht das das geht
Ich habe normalerweise immer GoLand Rider
Mittlerweile habe ich C-Line auch drauf
Für das Arduino und ESP32 Gedöns
Weil ich das viel angenehmer finde
Als Visual Studio C++
Visual Studio C++ kackt ja immer auch mit der Autocompletion ab
Äh unter was habe ich sonst noch drauf
Nix mehr
Das ist irgendwie
Wenn ich Ruby oder Ruby was mache
Aber das ist selten in letzter Zeit geworden
Die drei Sachen habe ich meistens drauf
So tatsächlich man kann es parallel installieren
Ja das ist ja nice
Das gefällt mir schon mal richtig gut
Ja ja wir akzeptieren das alles
Oh je da haben wir ein neues Start Logo
Äh New Solution
Ok
Ja das könnte man tatsächlich ausprobieren
Da muss ich mich aber erstmal schlau machen
Was es bei .NET 5 jetzt exakt für Neuigkeiten gibt
Also ich meine
Das wichtigste ist ja C-Sharp 9
Und da weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht was es gibt
Es gibt Record Types das habe ich im Kopf
Und ansonsten keine Ahnung
So und jetzt kommen wir mal
Machst du viel mit Go?
Ne nicht wirklich
Ich habe so eine Video Überwachungssoftware gebastelt
Die einen Teil Go hat
Aber die will ich eigentlich loswerden
So aber ich wollte noch was anderes beantworten
Und zwar
GRPC stimmt
Das wollte ich wirklich mal ausprobieren
Ich wollte ein paar Sachen ausprobieren
Reactive Extensions wollte ich schon mal eine Weile ausprobieren
GRPC
Ein paar Dinger
So also was kann Rider das ist eine IDE für
C-Sharp .NET
Ich glaube Rider kann Rider
Ne oder
Ach du Scheiße
Die können wirklich VB
Hätte ich jetzt gar nicht gedacht
Ok übrigens eine Sache die mir an Rider
Voll auf den Keks geht
Vielleicht kennt da einer was von euch
Man kann nicht Auto Format on Save einstellen
Wozu ich noch was sagen wollte gerade
Genau
Findest du Rider besser als Visual Studio
Im Prinzip ja
Ähm
Visual Studio selbst kommt mir
Ein bisschen mehr
Also responsiver vor
Wie könnte man das auf deutsch sagen
Kommt mir ein bisschen
Reaktions also ein bisschen
Reagiert schneller
Ein bisschen direkter
Also Visual Studio macht den etwas
Ähm
Mehreren Eindruck was Performance angeht
Als Rider letztendlich wissen wir ja alle
Unter Rider läuft jedes menge Java
Gedöns aber ok
Ähm an sich gefällt mir aber Rider
Von den Features besser
Und der riesen Vorteil
Von Rider ist und das ist für mich
Der das Killer Argument
Schlechthin Rider zu verwenden
Es geht unter Linux
Ich programmier mittlerweile die meisten .NET Sachen
Nur noch unter Linux
Und
Da gibt es kein Visual Studio es gibt nur Visual Studio Code
Ist noch nicht wirklich auf dem Level
Wie Visual Studio und
Rider was
Csharp.net angeht
Ja
Achja und übrigens die Sache hier zu dem Debugger
Kann ich gar nichts sagen
Weil ihr wisst ja
Ich bin bekennender Printline Debugger
Außer manchmal
Wenn man wirklich wissen muss was in irgendwelchen Variablen drinsteht
Oder vielleicht nicht genau nachvollziehen kann
An welcher Stelle was abkackt oder so
Aber ansonsten bin ich
Ja
Printline ich gerne
Rightline ich gerne
Da regt sich der Chat ja immer gerne auf
Wenn wir Programmierstream machen
Max setz doch nen Breakpoint mach den Debugger an
Und was macht der Max erstmal
Console Rightline 1 2 3 4 5
Wo bricht's ab
Tja
Das heißt es juckt mich gar nicht so sehr
Dass der Debugger besser ist
So machen das die wahren Profis
Genau so ist es
Außerdem
Wenn ich das nicht mache ist
Ich lass die Software auch nie in Rider laufen
Ich mach immer nen .NET Watch Run
Das ist übrigens auch was richtig gutes
Wer das nicht kennt
Man kann wenn man ein .NET Projekt macht
Zeige euch das mal kurz
Das machen wir jetzt
Dann geh ich wirklich essen
Es ist eben schon fast 14 Uhr
Ich hab übelst Hunger
Oder wie man im Osten sagt
Ich hab übelst Knast
Das ist bei uns ein Gefängnis
So
Wer das nicht kennt
Wenn man ein .NET Projekt macht
Hier sieht man es ja
Und sagt hier .NET Watch Run
Dann scannt der
Im Hintergrund die Dateien auf Änderung
So und wenn ich jetzt hier irgendwas ändere
Und speichere
Dann startet er automatisch die Applikation neu
Guck ich ändere was im Source Code
Drück Save
Applikation wird neu gestartet
Finde ich unglaublich praktisch
Und deswegen lasse ich das nicht in Rider laufen
Ich weiß das es theoretisch auch über die Rider Run Settings geht
Aber ich habe das lieber wenn es im Terminal läuft
Ich brauche eh ein zweites Terminal hier nebendran
Ja das ich irgendwie mal einen Curl machen kann
Klar man kann das alles mit dem Rider eingebauten Zeug nehmen
Aber eh Geschmackssache
So deswegen ist es mit Breakpoints und Debuggern eh schwierig
Bei mir
Weil da müsste ich erst mal stoppen
Dann im Rider starten und meistens habe ich da schon zwei
Ride Lines gemacht weil es was abkackt
Ist so ein bisschen Geschmackssache
Ich bin ein Print F'er genau
Ja so sieht es aus
Und Razer du hast recht meistens lohnt sich das gar nicht
Das ist nur
Also ich finde diese ganzen Debugger Breakpoint und sonst was
Die sind nur sinnvoll wenn es wirklich was ist
Wo man schwer selbst drauf kommt
Wenn man zum Beispiel
Nicht richtig nachvollziehen kann
Auf welchem Thread läuft das jetzt
Was steht in irgendeiner anderen Variablen drin
Wo ich gerade keinen zu
Irgendwie solche Dinger
Dann ist das mit so einem Debugger gar nicht verkehrt
Aber ansonsten
Ich mag Print Line
Ride Line ist es ja
Rechts ist das
Gut Leute
Gibt es da irgendwas im Chat
Ich gehe jetzt nämlich essen
Vielleicht bin ich heute Abend nochmal am Start
Und wir programmieren das
Habe ich nicht gemacht
Ich war gestern wandern komplett andere Richtung als Nordsee
Diese
Webcam Anwendung das man aufnehmen kann
Ich habe damit ja schon angefangen
Oder wir gucken uns wirklich .NET 5 an
Kommt drauf an
Muss ich mich mal schlau machen
Wie man das am besten hinkriegt
Gibt es schon ein Snap
.NET 5 Snap
Da kann man es nämlich wieder
Rücksichtslos
Entfernen
Snap Install .NET SDK
Ja ja
Muss ich das eigentlich ganz gut machen
What
Minus Minus Classic
Weil ansonsten kann man die Sachen
Schlecht nebeneinander über den offiziellen
Paket Manager installieren
Ah guck mal .NET 5 SDK
Das bedeutet ich könnte jetzt
Tatsächlich
Rider Early Access starten
Kein Sudo Ausrufe
Ah ja ja du hast Recht
Starten
New Solution machen
Und dann haben wir
Ah ne das muss ich noch einrichten
Warum mache ich das jetzt eigentlich
Ich könnte essen und wir machen das später
Egal who cares
Language and Frameworks
Ach du Scheiße wo ist das immer
Ich brauch da immer ewig
Bild Execution
Bild Tools
Ne Moment wo kommt man die Sachen nochmal aus
Ah hier Tools Set and Build
Das ist Max FPS der alle echte
So
Da findet es nicht
Und vielleicht machen wir nachher noch einen Stream
Ich glaube wir sind jetzt alle wach
Ich bin lange genug on 4 Stunden
Übelst Hunger
Also Leute wir sehen uns machts gut bis später
Und vielleicht bis später bis denn wir sehen uns see you